[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
is brewing we see a statement
performance from Magnus Carlsen oh
Nakamura is surviving
[Music]
HD what a tactic holy smokes my brain is
exploding
stop it oh my God it didn't happen oh my
God that's a devastating Intermezzo and
he can play
it's your mess so he missed it and now
it's a draw the moves will be fast
starting to seem Bishop C7 oh my God
where's the mate though I don't know but
it's gotta be there oh my God
the stakes will be high
Rook 85 and you can't stop check me I'm
gonna get I gotta get out of here the
2022 speed Chess Championship is now
fasten your speed belts my friends we're
in for a wild ride
this is Championship Sunday the World
Cup concluded earlier today now it's
time for the speed Chess Championship
I'm Grand Master Robert Hess alongside
me my good friend my co-commentator in
crime grand master Daniel the Prophet
nerdinski Donya it's Hikaru versus
Magnus I can't believe this moment has
arrived I cannot believe it is actually
2 p.m on Sunday December the 18th and
listen Magnus fancy Caro fans chess fan
soccer fans let's begin by acknowledging
that this is one of the most anticipated
chess matches ever
it certainly is there's a lot at stake
the world of Chess is at stake these are
the best online players in the world the
best chess players on the planet and as
we talk about what is actually at stake
specifically in this match there is
Glory there is Fame there are titles but
there's a lot of prize money as well so
in this individual matchup ten thousand
dollars is given to the winner and
there's a split of an additional ten
thousand dollars based on win percentage
Dania every single game counts in the
speed Chess Championship final it most
certainly does and the prizes have
continued to increase as the field has
thinned out but let's acknowledge
another thing these players Magnus the
car they eat ten thousand dollars for
breakfast hey they a hundred thousand
dollars for breakfast what they are
really going for today is the glory the
glory of beating either the world
champion or the greatest online Blitz
player of all time these players are at
each other's throats and it's not
because of the ten thousand dollars but
the prize is definitely a nice bonus
and their run to this point has been
glorious for both of these players as
you look at the bracket we started with
16 of the world's top players Hikaru
Nakamura the number one seed the
reigning Champion four years straight he
was in the top left he beats the
qualifier David paravian handily then he
beats Lavon aronian bites seven points
he beats Neil sarin by a four point
margin that was actually quite a close
Affair and now he finds himself squaring
off against Magus Carlson in the final
it's been a pretty smooth path for both
of these players but definitely Magnus
he's just blown everybody out of the gym
they haven't even managed to get a shot
off I mean look at those scores by the
world champion but Hikaru not to be
denied arguably his only close
nerve-wracking moment in his entire run
came in the bullet segment against knee
Hall when Yeehaw had that brief chance
Robert that one move chance to get
within one point that's it everything
else was wired to wire [ __ ] and span and
Magnus well his performance speaks for
itself
it certainly does and that moment was in
the highlight video Neil started missing
opportunity but Hikaru Nakamura punishes
everybody will he be able to do that
today that's the big question because in
today's matchup we have ikaru Nakamura
aged 35 happy birthday he just had that
recently against the recently turned 32
year old world champion Daniel it's the
Fisher random world champion against the
classical world champion these are two
of the most experienced players of all
time and they have lost none of their
strength none of their luster none of
their speed none of their ambition none
of their Drive none of their resilience
they've got all of the skills at the
ready they've got that ambition they've
played so many games Head to Head Robert
you can see Carlson leads the overall
Blitz score by a pretty healthy margin
but that record doesn't tell the whole
score because in the past few years
really since the dawn of covet and the
start of those rapid tournaments Hikaru
has turned their record around he used
to lose almost every classical game to
Carlson Magnus was his most
uncomfortable opponent but ever since
around 2017 he struck his fair share of
blows as well and you mentioned 2017
that's when Magnus Carlson doubled his
card nakamura's score in the SEC final
but this is a new Hikaru as you're
pointing out and it's a new SEC final
this is The Clash of the Titans number
three it's their third time meeting in
the SEC final Magnus won in about 2016
and 2017 but done is something that
sticks out about the year 2022 is Hikaru
has not lost to Magnus Carlson no matter
the variant no matter the time control
it's been one of the best years of
hikaru's career wherever you look I mean
it's been achievement upon achievement
obviously the Fisher random World
Championship Championship which is going
to be underestimated that was not an
easy tournament to Win It featured the
participation of one Magnus Carlson as
well as a couple other decent players a
great performance in the cgc icaro has
been indefatigable this year he has
jetted from one corner of the globe to
the other and wherever he has gone he
has put through either tournament
victories or at the very least Robert
extremely Stellar performances well
he'll need to be indomitable today
because against Magnus Carlson he makes
people pay that's for sure and well we
need to remind everybody of what's going
on if you're new to the channel welcome
subscribe do your thing but in all
seriousness we are looking forward to
today's action because we started this
event with 16 players and they play in a
format across three different time
controls if all is tied when it's said
and done we will get four games of one
minute one second increment and if that
Still Remains tied to the two we'll go
to Armageddon with bidding but that's
not for the moment we want to talk about
the overall format a full hour and a
half of five minute plus one second
increment then we get an hour of the
title Tuesday time Patrol 30 minute plus
one second increment that's the card
nakamura's bread and butter and then we
have 30 minutes of bullet chess one
minute plus one second increment so
Dania as you see the three different
time segments how do you see this
panning out who is the favorite in each
type control you're asking the difficult
questions the million dollar questions
and listen normally I'm slicing it up
and dicing it up and saying well he's
got to get off to a good start and this
player has an edge and bullet these two
are the most consistent Blitz players
and bullet players of all time they've
got all of the ingredients speed they've
got strength they're good at five plus
one they're good at time scramble so I
really think it's futile to talk about
who's the favorite in each segment I
really think this match is not going to
be decided until the final seconds of
the match clock takedown and it's one of
the most evenly evenly matched matchups
ever Robert ever
it certainly is and for a change seems
like you're agreeing with smarter chess
no no never mind never mind no no no one
of them uh too late it's already out
there for the world's smart chess
predictions brought to you by
chessgoals.com it is an even split in
the five plus one then a one point
margin in Magnus Carl's favorite in the
three plus one and then ties it up
Hikaru Nakamura this is the prediction
before winning it in the one minute plus
one second you commit tie break for a
final score of 16-15 so Dania I have to
say
this surprises me I think when Madness
Carlson plays he is always the favorite
definitely is and I think there's two
factors at play here and the world
champion almost always gets the benefit
of the doubt should he get the benefit
of the doubt well that's a itable
question what's not debatable is as we
discussed previously Carlson's path to
the SEC final has been unbelievable it's
been wild he's crushed everybody and his
form has been told I mean it's been it's
been Unthinkable and if he repeats the
form against Fabiano caruana even Hikaru
Nakamura will have to admit that he will
have a difficult Journey but Robert
ikaro is Hikaru and he is always a safe
bet he never goes down without the
fightiest of fights and that's not even
a word
right I enjoyed it anyway we'll pretend
that it is and we must say that even the
biggest hiccard Nakamura fans seem to
suggest that Magnus Carlson is the
favorite the community got involved over
15 000 brackets were submitted 65 of
which predicted this very final match-up
and the nod goes to Magnus Carlson it's
a slight knock 56 to 44 but still the
nod The Edge is given to Magnus it is
indeed and to those who filled out the
brackets thank you for your engagement
the chat and the community really adds
that additional element of magic 65
predicting this matchup we all wanted it
Robert and we all got it
we certainly do get it we are excited
for it and let's break down the
nitty-gritty between these two players
because chess.com provides insights
saying stuff about the Styles the speed
the you know wins by losses so as we
dive into some of the insights between
these two players they can see it broken
down that Hikaru Nakamura I think one of
the most impressive things he never
really loses by Flack he's just that
good in time pressure and not only does
he not lose by flag but he doesn't even
really lose by position when he's low on
time which is an impossible stat to
capture on paper but he is one of the
best if not the best time scramblers in
chess history and I'm using a lot of
superlatives today I'm ending a lot of
sentences with in chess history of all
time ever and I think we can all agree
that those superlatives are well
deserved when we talk about Hikaru and
Magnus but Magnus Carlson he might lose
more games by flag but in this
particular SCC if we take this
cross-section Robert he has been
unbelievable with even one or two
seconds left on his clock he had a
couple of wins against mvl when the
Frenchman had 30 40 seconds and a better
position he was up at peace and Magnus
had three seconds and he didn't lose
that game either so the numbers here
they don't tell the whole score uh the
whole story and Magnus has just been
unbelievable this particular event
he certainly has been he has been a
menace to society and that Society
includes every top chess player in the
world and you know as we break it down I
think some of these numbers can be a
little bit misleading because Hikaru
Nakamura plays so many more games and I
would say misleading but there's a
sample size difference a car also plays
against uh you know fans and people in
this community so the win percentage is
especially high for a car 77 are you
kidding me he's already amazing when
he's playing against people like me like
he adopts me all the time but if he's
playing against others it buoys that
percentage up but that's neither here
nor there because hikar Nakamura is
special he has been dominant in the year
2022. go and vote chess.com Awards uh
it's voting season you can vote for him
as your player of the year because he is
one pretty much at all every single
title Tuesday it feels like he won the
Fisher random World Championship he was
a semi-finalist in the global
Championship so Donny it almost feels
like a car can do no wrong he made it to
the candidates the only wrong that went
for him there was losing that last round
to daily rent
no it's it's been incredible and perhaps
what impresses me the most about these
two players is their ability to keep
composure it's crazy how when things
just don't go quite according to plan
and no matter how successful you are
you're gonna have matches and
tournaments where you lose a game here
and there but neither of these players
ever tilt it's like they are totally
untiltable they can lose a game they can
blunder a piece but they're just gonna
come back stronger the next time and
that ultimately I think every great
athlete shares that quality Robert this
ability to keep getting up when you get
knocked down whatever cliche you want to
use Magnus Carlson and hikaranakamura
possess that skill to the maximum and
that perhaps above all is what I'm
looking forward to in this match how are
they going to recover when they get
dealt blow after Blow by the other
player the big question and both players
are seated they are ready
on the study for the very first move
I I'm excited for the first move until
the last move ladies and gentlemen this
is an amazing occasion we live in the
best time for chess we're about to watch
Hikaru take on Magnus in a three-hour
match
and Robert I'm gonna have to lean back
from the screen I'm gonna have to keep
my own composure because I'm I can't
even imagine how the players feel right
now
well Magus Carlson he has got those arms
crossed Hikaru he's dressed sharply for
the occasion and here we go Nakamura
with the white pieces in game one we see
him use the King's Pawn no bong clouds
today I don't think we're gonna see that
we get Knight F3 Knight to six and a
Spanish Donya uh Spanish both of these
players we expect them to bring their a
game from the very first moves no 1a3 no
one G4 from Hikaru Nakamura he is taking
this seriously and Magnus repeating what
he played against mvl clearly indicating
that he wants to play a Marshall and he
does we get that Marshall and it's C6
this time so Magnus Carlson he is kind
of mixing it up here causing some
problems for a car who you would think
except for the fact that a car is
playing instantly he is well prepared
and Magnus has played the Marshall
before C6 is the main move against mvl
Carlson was playing the sideline Bishop
B7 that has surprise value this has the
reputation and notice Hikaru putting his
Pawn on D3 Robert this line got very
popular about 10 years ago I think
vicious was the first to popularize it
at the highest level generally it's
considered a risk-free way to fight for
a small advantage and often white
actually ends up giving up the extra
Pawn
and look at this room Queen H4 the
bishop 105 was under attack but H2 was a
checkmated threat so that's why the Palm
went to G3 to blunt the bishop on D6 now
the queen slides up into the compromised
light squares protecting the bishop on
F5 and if that Bishop can join the queen
in the king side party there could be a
Checkmate against the white king oh
absolutely that's why the Marshall was
invented Frank James Marshall was one of
the greatest attacking players of the
late 19th early 20th century and
nowadays the Marshall is often used as
an equalizing weapon engines have
breathed new life into this line and
what you often see white doing here is
quickly bringing this Knight up to E4
Robert White has to start developing his
Queen side or there will be hell to pay
on the e-file and he does bring his
Knight to D2 but look at this black is
taking advantage of the fact that white
lacks development the move F5 is played
The Rook on E1 is loose but the bishop
on D6 is also loose but you take a
bishop you lose a rook that might not be
a good trade and wow what a concept here
sacrificing a piece to win it whoa look
at this
I had a game just like this against ding
in the Pro chess League two years ago I
remember this move Bishop F3 check
catches a card by surprise he looks
upset right now and the point is that
they're the king is dragged to the F3
Square Rook takes F4 is check you win
one pawn and then you're gonna win the
pawn on e4 next by force and remember
just because the Knight is pinned it
still protects that Rook on F4 you can't
play King tig's Rook the Knight covers
the square
PPP pinned pieces protect you cannot
take the Rook The Rook takes the pawn
material equality has been restored and
I hesitate to use the words Dead Drop
because both of these players Robert
they are known for their ability to
squeeze a win out of the most unlikely
types of end games they can win Rook vs
Rook Hikaru has won a lot of Rook vs
Rook end games throughout his career but
with the one second increment and plenty
of time on their clocks I think this
first game is likely to end in peace now
is Hikaru the one actually fighting for
the edge here as he prepares C4
some people like the rapper Hoodie Allen
others might like hoodie Carlson over
here he has his hood up over his head he
wants to be the Grim Reaper right now
it's even material you're talking about
the move C4 but let's talk about the
king side black has a healthier Pawn
structure on G7 and H7 so it's clear
what a car's intentions are he wants to
push that pawn go after the targets on
the queen side and I have to say that if
white isn't careful if the game is
prolonged I feel like the Knight being
able to hop from color complex to color
complex can be very dangerous in this
position
that's a fantastic point the bishop
obviously has to stay on its initial
color and the Knight with every move
switches to a different color and
speaking of switching to a different
color the Knight hops back to E7 and
then forward again to F5 and I think the
point of this move is to keep the
Integrity of Black's Queen Side Pawn
structure alive if C takes B5 black can
actually take either way but I like hxp5
to keep the C file shut
I like the look of that as well the
Knight on E7 is doing an important duty
and this King wants f8 right it's out of
The Bishop's path the king can keep
marching towards the center King E8 King
to D7 and the white king at some point
would probably want to go the F3 square
but the Rook cannot even go over to H4
putting pressure on that isolated Pawn
on H2 so I feel like for Hikaru he
doesn't really have something to
threaten just yet and because Black's
Pawn structure is healthier and Magnus
is a healthy minute and a half up on the
clock I prefer his chances I agree and
Hikaru should I think take the first
opportunity to repeat moves if he can
make that happen there is a repetition
with King F3 Rook H4 and then King back
to G3 but black does not have to oblige
she can jump into F5 with check and
simultaneously defend the Rook so with
every ticking second the likelihood that
Magna starts playing with us for a win
Robert I'm totally on the same page
increases
yes it is so there King goes after
rookie King GP Knight F5 check it starts
to feel like black is gaining some of
the momentum in the position so hey Card
cannot just make a draw here and I want
to give a shout out to the over 65
000 people watching this map This Is The
Clash of the Titans it's akara Nakamura
and Magnus Carlson and you do not want
to miss the rest of it I'm so glad we're
just getting started and The Rook is
just getting started that is a Checkmate
threat the bishop covers F7 the Knight
probably has to jump out the way but
Daniel the Knight on E7 is doing an
important duty is protecting the C6 Pawn
so the Knight jumps to say G6 maybe the
white Rook will slide into the D6 square
at some point or even to D7 but not yet
because the four cut E5 so Knights being
tricky pieces you have to watch out for
checks and forks took the words right
out of my mouth you don't want to miss
the rest of this match you also don't
want to miss a Checkmate in game one of
the SEC final and something tells me
Magnus sees the threat he's thinking
about how to Parry it there are
alternatives you could slide the king
over to E8 you could push upon to G6 and
create some Luft on G7 but that allows
The Rook to run amok with Rook DJ check
and then back to D7 Carlson does
entrench his Knight on F5 and will
Hikaru now try to infiltrate the seventh
Rank and threaten Rook F7 check Robert
what do you think is the most clinical
way here to secure the draw
look at Magnus I mean he just got up in
his chair there he is ready to pounce
and the reason why is Rook D7 looks
threatening because that shotgun of
seven black simply slides the pawn up to
G6 it's very important to note that Rook
on H4 is not just an attacking piece it
is protecting that vulnerable so Rook D7
it threatens to win a piece you can just
protect that piece keep your Pawn safe
and sound now the C6 Pawn that's the
target you want to have and let's talk
about something long-term donut we
should not forget to mention if white
can play Pawn B3 and pawn A4 there is
some potential for an outside pass Pawn
as this game continues so that's what
Magnus needs to keep an eye on that's a
great point and what you're showing is
that this is still a three result game
it's not like black has target practice
here Magnus has to keep that in mind
Bishop C2 by Nakamura no he is not
blundering a fork on D4 because the king
will slide over to G3 and Magnus will
have to spend the tempo as he just did
to defend the Rook the bishop is going
to move away from C2 you can also
protect it with Rook D2 you can just
sense that Magnus has the initiative
he's calling the shots but for the time
being Robert there's basically nothing
to attack that King on G3 is perfectly
situated from a defensive point of view
and at some point you have to be able to
look out for Bishop takes H7 oh there's
The Rook on H4 now gets distracted
what's wrong with it nothing it wins
upon and it forces to enter the
defensive right if the Rook takes and
they both Miss they both completely
missed that option I mean my gosh that
was a pawn that if captured distracts
The Rook away from the defense of the
Knight so I'm a little confused what the
players are seeing maybe we are missing
something but I don't think so I think
that was just a hanging Pawn I don't
think so Robert I think this is
pre-match Jitters the matches just
started listeners
notice that yep you can just tell in the
body language how could I have missed
Bishop takes H7 a little bit of jitters
here to start the match from both
players and Magus Carlson's talking to
himself he's like where do I get these
witty chances from I'm up admitted on
the clock I'm better C5 looks like a
great move he takes the bishop which is
surprising but objectively it might be
best look at the evaluation bar better
for black what's his idea King activity
in the end game the king is a weapon
it's an aggressive piece here oh he
doesn't go up why not King D5 and Rook
D4 and the pawn end game is winning due
to the massive disparity in King
activity now Robert you pointed out that
white could create a pastor on the queen
side well black can do the same thing on
the other side imagine if the Rooks are
off the board C5 C4 and then B4 C3
that's a lot of pawn moves but white is
nowhere near creating a pass spawn
either so I think Magnus should go for
the win here but he's black it's game
one maybe he wants to play with an
abundance of caution and I'm kind of
surprised I kind of surprised yeah it
doesn't really seem like the magnets
were used to where he just beats
everybody no matter the position I think
it's a fine choice he's like it's I'm
only slightly better I get the white
pieces now and I think he believes that
with the First Advantage he could take
down
and a king's Indian from Hikaru Nakamura
in game two if you're familiar with
hikaru's career you would not be
surprised at that choice at some point
hikar was playing the king's Indian
almost exclusively he scored countless
brilliant victories in over the board
chess and the big surprise Robert is not
the opening Choice it's what Magnus has
just played Bishop to D3 rather than the
typical Bishop E2 what do you make of
this
and it's the small things that make the
biggest difference at the highest level
look at that Bishop D3 dragging the
bishop out to G4 and then Bishop E2 that
looks like a loss of a Tempo but what is
gained that light Square Bishop is so
important in the king's Indian if the
bishop takes the Knight on F3 you're not
going to get your typical attack when
you eventually move your knight away
from F6 push your Pawn to F5 and storm
on the king side so black does not want
to capture this Knight on F3 so Magnus
does what Magnus does best he kind of
lures his opponent into an unknown
position that deep dark Forest that
Mikhail tall like to talk about and he
said there's only room out for one of us
and lilac that's a great quote one of my
favorites Lila and stockfish they have
breed New Life from the white side of
the king's Indian I have to begrudgingly
admit as a biased Kings Indian player
myself but they have found so many new
variations obscure lines that seem to
give white a small but stable advantage
and you can see Magnus dropping his
Knight away forcing the exchange of
light scored Bishops and that doesn't
mean Robert that Hikaru is not going to
try to go F5 it's just going to be a lot
harder to infiltrate down the light
squares with the bishop now absent from
the board
it's a lot of scary right because F5 can
always be met by F3 and one of the big
features of the king's Indian defense is
that dark Square Bishop for black is bad
I'm sorry to say it Dania I know this is
respect and love that Bishop on G7 is
one only a mother could love because
it's stuck behind a Pawn on E5 that is
why sometimes you want a pawn break it
opens the board up and look at this
movie G4 you want to play F5 I dare you
come at me because GF then it will open
the G file and that bad Bishop on G7 I
was just talking about will get in some
big trouble and I'm almost positive
Hikaru is going to switch his attention
to the other side of the board let's
bring up our first analysis Board of the
day I'll show you what can happen if you
play F5 this is Unthinkable you never
play F5 if it allows the G file to open
white can simply take twice and we're
not talking about the positional
concessions black makes giving up this
massive E4 Square for white snides look
at the G file Rook G1 let's say
blackplay is a random move and you can
already resign after Rook takes G7 and
queen G4 with the Knight sinking its
teeth into E4 on the next move Robert
Hikaru didn't even take a second to
think about F5 and as predicted he
situates his Knight on on C5 instead
yeah that's why we study our openings
right Hikaru Nakamura hasn't memorized
this position but he has a great
fundamental understanding that F5 is too
dangerous now he might need to play that
move just to get some some activity
because what can you do on the other
side of the board you would like to push
upon A5 back to A6 and play the move B7
to B5 but you can't do that pawns don't
go backwards in chess unfortunately how
else do you crack open that side of the
board maybe C6 but C6 comes at a cost
the D6 Pawn will be a long-term weakness
you're still not getting the move B5 in
so white has a free hand on the king
side Donya where black has absolutely
nothing to show for on the queen side
and black needs to get down to business
to defeat the Huns here because if he
doesn't the attack is coming at a
furious Pace Magnus is about to play H5
and open up the H file and you basically
have if you're Hikaru three or four
Tempe maximum to create some Intrigue on
the other side of the board you can see
Hikaru desperately trying but Magnus he
calmly brings his Knight to B1 why is he
doing that why is he contorting himself
like that it's to stop Beast 7b5 which
is one of the only options that black
has to open up the queen side and the
Knight on C3 is in integral in stopping
that advance from happening
you know contortionists usually freaked
me out it scares me what they do with
their bodies but I'm loving the way that
white is maneuvering those Knights the
Knight back to B1 Wesley so did this
against Maxine vashilagrove we talked
about a lot he knows where to put his
pieces the Knight is best placed on C3
here and now again white has nothing to
fear on the queen said King B1 looks
like a generally useful move just in
case black has any ideas of opening up
the queen side and you're just pointing
this out blackout closes the kick side
and look at the Petrosian King Marsh
that King is going away from the queen
side to E1 to F1 to G2 where it will
just sit safely on the king side and
then when white is ready to strike well
Magnus try to push pawns on the queen
side and I think the real reason he's
marching his King as you point out is to
go from defending to attacking on the
queen side but it's also to liberate
this night where does the night really
belong where the Knight is eyeing this
beautiful F5 Square where it's going to
Lord over the entire King side well you
couldn't do that easily with your King
on the queen side because because of B7
B5 and Hikaru is reminding Magnus of
what is going to happen the moment he
moves his Knight away from C3 but Robert
I just want to point out age six by
Hikaru was a necessary move that was a
really really strong idea that freezes
the king side and gives Hikaru the time
he needs to set things up on the other
side of the board the engine might give
plus two here but it's actually
incredibly hard to make progress even
though you're positionally dominating
you're going to use that word Fortress
Magnus Carlson of years past may not
believe in it but a car knock more
certainly does and the reason why how
can you make progress you need a pawn
break where's the pawn break going to
come from you can never play the move F2
to F4 because black has both of the
pawns staring there and similarly black
can never play F7 F5 for the same reason
so the king side remains completely
locked what about the queen side maybe
an eventual Pawn A3 Pawn V4 but that
seems forever away especially because
black is ready to meet that there's and
he plays A4 if you you play A3 you'll
never get played B4 if you play Pawn B2
to B3 thank you for opening up the queen
side my Rook on A8 is developed in its
starting home and then Knight moves out
the way and there will be some activity
and Magnus has to be a little bit
careful because two can play at that
game he strikes first with B4 he waited
until the precise moment that Hikaru was
ready to play B5 this is White's last
opportunity to push the beep on and he
does I love that decision from Carlson
Robert I think if Hikaru could squeeze
B5 in we could students start having a
completely different conversation with a
king side locked up it might very well
have been black who would have held all
the cards on the queen side as it stands
Magnus will get a rook to B3 in the
event of an on passant and then B5 will
once again be virtually unachievable
especially if a pawn lands on A4 this is
getting very bad for a car so he plays a
little yeah E6 I think he's a very smart
play he wants to keep the position as
luck as possible if the move B5 is
played by white here the Knight goes
back to C7 and then the question becomes
where to make progress there are no Pawn
breaks the issue for black is this Pawn
on A4 it sticks out and that's why the
move A3 was played both to defend the B4
Pawn at some point as you're
highlighting the queen is going to come
to C2 that Palm may go from B4 to B5 and
the A4 Pawn May collapse so that's the
thing that needs to be looked out for
however found it we should not forget
the G4 Pawn you beat me to it you know
where my mind's going the queen on E2 is
doing an important task and we know
where magnus's mind is going and we know
where his King is going it's going to
defend the G4 Pawn to free up the queen
so that it can move to C2 and attack the
A4 pawn and Robert engines are still
very bad in these types of positions
stockfish was myopically suggesting the
move B5 leading to a totally locked
positions engines don't always
understand the concept of not being able
to make progress Magnus of course is
going to keep his Pawn on before in
order to open up the possibility of
reopening the queen side at his
convenience this is Hikaru was in Dire
Straits here he certainly is but our
viewership is Sky High through the roof
over 100
000 people across YouTube twitch and all
the platforms thank you so much we are
just getting started the fun is just
beginning at the fun maybe getting
started from Magnus Carlson because it's
right now it's tied a draw in the first
game and that for a takes B4 here black
is sitting very passively the pawn on A4
will be captured I believe right now but
if Knight takes A4 Donya there may be
the response B6 to B5 C4 Pawn is pinned
to the queen over there on C2 there's an
incredible idea that involves taking on
A4 and then actually sacking the Knight
driving the C Pawn up to C6 and banking
on the protected and connected passers
but we'll cross that bridge if we get
there Magnus he needs to defend the C4
Pawn Robert I have been very impressed
with hikaru's defense here in the early
going he is challenging Magnus he is
posing problems and he's trying to get
this into a Time scramble
right and P5 played by Magnus take your
knight if it goes to B8 it's trapped
there it's not getting out anytime soon
but if it goes up to C5 then white can
take on C5 and I actually think this is
quite ingenious in many ways the A4 Pawn
is dropping but even if it weren't done
yet that Knight on C3 we like to think
of dream squares the night might land on
F5 and guess what or C6 is your point C6
yeah light squares dark Square Bishop
good luck pairing off that threat it is
going to be very unpleasant you got
Bally on F5 you've got Hawaii on C6 that
Knight has prospects and right now
Magnus needs to get rid of hikaru's
Knight on C5 take the pawn on A4 and
Magnus well he's got to make sure that
he keeps the C4 Pawn defended this might
be the only tender spot in White's
entire position most importantly here
white is really in no hurry Magnus could
take his time to get this Knight around
again either to F5 C6 I think is a
little bit more accessible although it's
not too hard to get to F5 either as long
as you defend the spawn which he just
did you could start the maneuvering
process right about now but Hikaru he
prepares to grab control of the a file
which may be his only asset at this
point well it's a dual threat the AFL
and Rook takes B5 was a threat because
the queen was loose on C2 so if white
makes a move let's say where the free
turn with Knight D1 immediately Brook
takes B5 is available because the C4
Pawn is pinned to the White Queen but
the Queen Seven it wants to go to F6 and
up to F4 causing that white king some
problems but Dania I think it's just
scary looking but not scary in principle
and magnets down to 18 seconds he's got
to find a way out listen scary looking
things actually become scary when you've
got 10 seconds on your clock the enemies
become magnified and Hikaru is second to
none at twisting you into a knot even if
you're completely winning when you're
down to those last seconds Rook to A3
pins the Knight and suddenly black
getting really active here yes because
the next Rook B3 you lose the C4 Pawn
he goes backwards a huge move and black
suddenly has the upper hand but he goes
Rook 8 that was a big missed opportunity
for Hikaru Nakamura Queen F4 forced the
favorable Queen trade because the epon
would have captured opening up a pathway
for the black Bishop but we've moved on
from that this is still a game and
Magnus is very close to getting his
Knight to that promised land on F5 and
he does oh this is terrible for black
because now you're just getting squished
you have no space for your pieces and
don't be surprised if white makes move
C4 to C5 at some point
Gary Kasparov it's a clearance rate
reference get a pass Pawn so look for
that option at some point for white but
Magnus he's Dilly dallying he's trying
to build some time up on his clock it's
time
he has no other way to make progress he
can't play the move I understand he
might be a little bit nervous about it
he's just trying to keep consistent on
the clock moving his Rook back with
Queen E3 again now C5 repetition is on
the card strong and he's got to be
careful to avoid three-time repetition
I think he'll be okay with it I think he
sees the position as being locked up he
just wants to escape what's losing
Rook be three to C4 pawns a little bit
loose but not actually capturable and I
don't know with two seconds is he gonna
decide on C5 he decides to exchange
trucks but he gives up the pawn oh my
God and he's giving up another one I
think it's just a draw Queen E1 and we
have a drawable repetition oh my lands
and Magnus doesn't decide on C5 it was
difficult to calculate the ramifications
especially against dicaro it's a drop by
Perpetual check
oh now both players can be the sigh of
relief there because Hikaru was worse
but he also had a shot with Queen F4 and
Magnus down in time trouble saying my
mouse speed is there I can hang with the
car Nakamura and it's not just a hoodie
hanging on my head so we see that it's
one to one great defense from both and
we are just getting started done it's
still 68 and a half minutes remaining in
the longest time Patrol neither of the
players able to land a punch in the
first two games Magnus came oh so close
in that game it was an Exquisite
positional effort he outplayed Hikaru in
his pet King's Indian but at the end of
the day Robert if you think about
hikaru's greatest strength what does he
have to harness in order to try to knock
the world champion out of the SCC and
claim the title for himself it's his
time scrambling ability I think that
that is hikaru's biggest objective Edge
over Magnus when Hikaru is in top form
his time scrambling is unbelievable
yeah it's really tough to match up with
Magnus Carlson but a car Nakamura
proving he's capable of doing just that
we are in our third game of the match we
see that we had a Queen's Gambit
accepted so what's the dynamic right now
white has an extra Pawn in the center E3
and D4 versus just a single Pawn E6
white is castled the black king is in
the center but what does black have
going for no actual targets no weakness
in the position
Tanya Magnus is thinking he's spending a
lot of time here is he unfamiliar with
the setup
well I'm sure he's had this before in
OTB chess I think what he's really
trying to decide is whether to push B5
and I'm going to Echo a point you made
in an earlier broadcast in a galaxy far
far away if you play B5 prematurely and
the bishop drops back white has this
idea of pushing a2a4 and carving out a
very nice C4 Square for his Knight so
you actually see Magnus delaying the
move B5 and you might even see him
playing the more modest B6
right D5 is an idea for black and that's
why white plays A4 to stop it but it
gives up a key Square so let's see what
Hikaru Nakamura has in mind he's also
being a bit slow deliberate here taking
his time longest time Patrol he's used
to winning with five seconds of the
clock when he starts with five minutes
well that's quite a lot of time he
chooses A4 so what this is was an
approach does he want to give up control
B4 the answer happens to be yes but he
is taking squares away from black on the
queen side and it's not enough just to
see oh I weakened a square how
accessible is that square it's not that
easy for black to get a knight to B4 and
even if he does it's not the end of the
world for for white a night on before
looks pretty but it's not really
impacting the course of the game so I
like the decision to prevent B5 I think
White's got a tiny pull here Magnus has
to be very careful about the D4 D5 Pawn
break which is especially strong if you
play B6 okay Magnus takes on D4 and we
get a new pawn structure I think you can
play the move Knight to E5 the bishop on
C8 wants to get out the move B6 would be
a blunder because it gives white the C6
Square so that's why 95 with Tempo
against the bishop right Bishop D7 and
Dania I feel like these positions can
get very dangerous for white the reason
why is that B4 square and the B3 Pawn at
some point if black gets developed and
coordinated the B3 Pawn is an
approachable Target whereas B7 the
bishop needs to get to F3 easier said
than done well there's a knight sitting
on E5
you're absolutely right objectively the
position is clearly equal the engine's
always going to throw 0.00 in these
positions but I agree completely white
is the only one with a serious Target
and a seriously weak Square the B4
Square can be occupied by a bishop
rather than the Knight as originally
anticipated and Magnus you know what he
could do here he could take on F3 and
then play Bishop C6 to try to open up
the B file but instead he decides to
keep all of the pieces on the board with
Knight G6 yeah because surprisingly
white is the one with less space and the
position is pretty open so Knight G6
keeping more peace on the board is
saying that Bishop on E2 desperately
wants to get to F3 not so fast now if
you go Knight D4 back we could see a
repetition of moves with Knight back to
E5 or you read my mind once again
partner Han to E5 is available for black
so Queen B1 an odd looking move down
here what's the purpose behind it well
it could be to prepare Knight C3 to E4
and the purpose of that not only uh to
relieve the pressure a little bit by
trading a pair of binder pieces but
White's greatest asset arguably is his
dark Squad Bishop sitting pretty on the
long diagonal it's definitely better
placed than Black's Bishop so Knight E4
is an attempt maybe to accentuate your
strengths and minimize your weaknesses
but there's a lot of logistical problems
with it black can take and then throw
Bishop C6 with Tempo Hikaru instead
where is he going is he going to C4 but
then he's walking into Queen G5
I think he overlooked the queen sliding
across the fifth rank he plays Bishop F3
but this is just the start of White's
troubles the reason why are the squares
the control and the coordination the
connection between the Rooks and a and
Fa Tanya that Rook can go to d8 right
now and look at the Rook on A1 it's
Boxed In by that Queen on B1 so Queen B1
had the point of 94 it wasn't played and
now we see why it's going to backfire
Hikaru definitely Under Pressure that
Queen will have to move out of the way
to make space for The Rook but where do
you move it to go to A2 that looks ugly
if you go to C2 you walk into a pin if
you go to D3 you walk into Rook FDA so
white screen surprisingly is feeling
mighty uncomfortable on B1 and Magnus
could Target that B3 Pawn with a
well-timed queen D5 or queen B4
Queen D5 looks like the next move for
black so I think white should play the
move Rook to D1 challenge the D file
because if you can start swapping off
pieces your problems are not as
significant how do you attack B3 you
need Queens on the board it's the only
piece for black that can attack it so if
you could First Trade Rooks then trade
Queens you just feel like your problems
are not so significant so Rook doing an
excellent choice and a move for black I
don't know if it's good right now I was
gonna say Knight to D5 he choose Queen
D5 then I feel like Magnus when he has
the black pieces he's not necessarily
trying to win he's just trying to play
good solid chess and if it's a draw he
gets the white piece in the first to
advance the next game you read my mind
again I was literally about to say is it
fair to say and I don't like to make
these General pronouncements but it does
seem like Magnus is playing with an
abundance of caution early in the match
he wants to get his feet under him and
he really wants to press with the white
pieces as he did in the previous game I
think he judges that he's got the edge
on hikaru's opening repertoire uh with
with one D4 and can Magnus Force The
Rook trade with Rook d8 here is that the
best option or is it to play Roxy too
Rook d8 looks like just a simplification
forcing the Rooks off the problem there
though is it's a dark Square Bishop
white has light Square pawns so does
black so that means if the knights can
hop in maybe white has a chance to win
that game that is not going to happen
because it's you know we're near
attacking those uh pawns on the queen
side but at least from a practical
perspective it's only white who would
have winning chances of Rook V8 and
that's why I'm always worried about
these approaches when you try to go for
simplification and you're essentially
playing for a draw you're giving Hikaru
exactly what he wants maybe a tiny tiny
pull in the end game but the car has got
to be feeling really the most
comfortable he's felt all game Robert
especially compared to what he had in
the middle game and there he goes
grabbing space with a furious Pawn March
you might follow up with G5 and H4 I
love it and hate it at the same time and
the reason why I like the aggression the
ambition what I don't like is the over
extension because that pawn on G4 could
be a Target if you're not looking out
for it especially pushing to G5 then
your knight is stuck in place on F3
defending that pawn so I feel like with
Black's last move King f8 King E8 next
that Rook is gonna be booted from the
seventh Rank and then I feel like most
of Black's problems are behind him and
then it's maybe Magnus who can say I'm
gonna play for a win now the pendulum
continues to swing I was really Under
the Influence under the spell of that
Rook on the seventh but can you really
blame me Bishop to d8 sends The Rook
packing but Magnus is actually not
necessarily in a hurry he might throw in
a move like H6 if he wants to stop G5
you could also consider 97 to D5 because
Bishop d8 does compromise the activity
of Lex Bishop if only temporarily 97 is
on the board
97 to D5 going from the King side
towards the center and if G5 Knight D5
there might be G takes F6 it looks like
White's about to get a new Queen but
unfortunately for him once the king
slides off the last rank that pawn is
stopped but it's close there you're very
very careful looking out for the tactics
let's show that on the analysis board as
sicaro Ponders his next move he's
definitely calculating G5 Knight D5 G
takes F6 you give up The Rook on C7 it
looks like promotion is Unstoppable but
in Comes The Rook to the rescue and
white can play something like Knight F4
and Knight H5 Robert but it's become
very clear that white is firmly on the
defensive here and something like Knight
D5 to F6 knocks the Knight out of H5 and
picks up the Jeep on this is not an
option you can play G5 but you
definitely can't give up The Rook back
to the live position where Hikaru is
still contemplating his next move
G5 is actually quite a strength because
the Rook can come to H4 if Black's not
looking out for it and then H7 Falls but
if you Retreat the bishop on its
diagonal to say the square E7 or d8 as
you just played if Rook H4 you have this
for Pawn H6 but the reason why you have
it is the same exact idea yeah where the
king slides up at the end until the past
Pawn doesn't pick up a queen I I forgot
that that Bishop actually moved away
from d8 for a second got excited there
Rook H4 H6 is a tactical mechanism
otherwise black would lose that corner
Pawn but I always get concerned Robert
Robin Robert
hello Robin my new commentator when
you're hanging on on the basis of a
tactical mechanism like this because
it's very easy to forget about it and
the moment you move the bishop that Rook
is flan to H4 both sides now down under
a minute
Knight B6 played Rook H4 is still met by
Pawn to H6 it might be a worthy
sacrifice at some point yeah
Magnus if he just isn't looking out for
it it may hit him and he's gonna regret
it but now he carved down to 18 17 16
seconds Donya he is and definitely
thinking about Rook H4 but he's got to
make a decision he drops back to C2 and
we are going to get a rook trade
and look at this the evaluation is in
Black's favor the king can go up to D7
to C6 to C5 to B4 and watch out for that
B3 Pawn I was saying with liquidation it
shouldn't be much of an issue but that
black Kink Sprints out very quickly and
a prophylactic move trying to prevent
the knight from accessing the E5 Square
on the other hand this forces Black's
King in the opposite direction it wants
to go I think Magnus is saying hey
Knight why don't you attack the queen
side pawns my king is going to stay in
the center to defend the king side pawns
it looks pretty even but I think Magnus
is the one pushing here is the king your
E6 to D5 you and King of the Hill but
you don't win the game at least you have
some initiative the H4 Pawn cemented on
dark square if F5 is played the H4 pawns
loose but F5 weakens E5 that pawn would
be hanging so that's what king E6 but
Knight C5 check you can kick the king
back and then play Knight D3 so you're
not gonna have to face F5 and that's
precisely what he's going to do Hikaru
obviously final the repetition and
magnus's strategy has been to play with
an abundance of caution in these time
scrambles is he going to accede to the
repetition once again Hikaru is going to
be the one to play
and this is what I was saying one second
bishop and those are light Square pods
the king's coming over Knight takes B7
Magnus is starting to lose control kid
he trapped this Knight though Hikaru can
save it with his Pawn C5 and C6 he
drives the pawn and he cuts off the king
yes C6 the king cannot get in there it
should be six he needs to go King E6 the
king can't get to the pawn oh he's gonna
play he's got a flag he lost he just
died
and he can't believe it and look at
Hikaru he's cool as a cucumber he is
focused and he's acting like nothing
just happened but something huge
happened he gained the lead it's the
first lead in this match and it belongs
to Kara Nakamura and that final position
I think the reason Magnus flagged is
because he recognized that the white
King was going to move into the queen
side I think he may have forgotten that
the Bishop from B6 could attack H4 but
it's a mood point now Magnus panics and
this is a very concerning sign for him
in the early going because Robert one
thing I know for a fact about this match
is that we're gonna get a heck of a lot
of time scrambles
we're gonna get a heck of a lot of time
scrambles we're gonna heck a lot of
viewers we have over 125
000 viewers right now thank you so much
for tuning in your day is just getting
started you had the World Cup final now
you give the speed test Championship
final and it is exciting a card Nakamura
with a two to one lead he's looking to
the side like he does vintage Hikaru
trying to figure out this position and
Magnus with the white side the Catalan
Dania I think it's a good opening choice
in a blitz match and it's a good opening
Choice after a loss you're sort of
stabilizing or playing something on the
safer side something that you're
comfortable with and man facing Magnus
on the black side of a Catalan I know of
few more appetizing prospects maybe
facing a penalty kick from Lionel Messi
that's right about comparable
yeah that was not very fun right Lionel
Messi scoring for Argentina multiple
times today leading them to Victory
congratulations to all of Argentina but
right now we're focused on the chess and
what I'm focused on Donya is the
activity of White's pieces and the
relative passivity of blacks now black
control is the B4 Square just like in
that previous game that is an important
one to keep in mind and the Knight goes
to D7 often to go to B6 maybe to D5 when
you have less space you have less
control you want to exchange pieces if
the Knight on D7 is exchanged for the
Knight on C3 that gives black control of
the E4 square and you don't want to see
white push E2 to E4 right now it's
covered by both Bishop on C6 and Knight
on F6 but if white could play Rook fe1
and pawn E4 in one move then white would
have the advantage great insight and
explanation in these types of Catalan
structures you also sometimes see the
light squared bishops get traded and on
paper that favors black it weakens
White's King and obviously peace
exchanges favor the side that's more
cramps but there we go Robert that
doesn't tell the whole story because
Knights are incredibly good at chiseling
their way into the opponent's weaknesses
especially in these close positions and
apart from that I think Magnus is now
fully ready to play E4 but will he yes
he will there he goes
there he goes he can play F4 as well
just start throwing up all of his
kingside pawns and one thing to note
here is this should be reminiscent of
the previous game where there was a dark
Square Bishop that couldn't really make
an impact against some Knights now that
Bishop can take the Knight on C3 but
there's a huge problem you played Bishop
C3 white plays Pawn takes E3 the B file
is open Rook B1 Rook B3 Rook other to B1
hitting the B7 Pawn so Pawn chains are
only as strong as their base pawns the
B7 Pawn is safe and sound as long as
that file remains closed and Hikaru
bringing his Queen into B6 and putting
pressure on the pawn on D4 he is gonna
follow up with Rook a to d8 and it
concerns me that Black's play in this
position just seems very easy it's
free-flowing Rook d8 then perhaps you
can bring the Knight back to D7 to
exchange White's strongest piece on the
other hand what is magnus's plan he
doesn't seem remotely capable of pushing
D5 here I don't think that's the way he
should go maybe he should bring his
knight uh back to F3 and play E5 Robert
do you think he's just gonna tread water
with some of these improving moves
for now he will and it's often what it
requires in this kind of position Knight
F3 you mentioned it he Retreats he
defends E4 to E5 is something to keep in
mind you don't want to rush that
decision no because as soon as you play
E5 you give the D5 score and your Pawn
on D4 as a long-term weakness that said
You vacate the E4 Square for your knight
so what white sometimes does here is
Pawn H4 after E5 Pawn G4 and start an
attack on the king side because look at
Black's pieces Bishop on B4 Queen on B6
Rook on D7 they're playing on the other
side of the board so if you can get a
timely attack you may devastate
obliterate the black king a lot of
players a lot of fans they think of
these positions as boring but they're
not it's a slow burn for sure right
nothing happens fast in these types of
positions not even the moves played by
the players themselves but there's so
much going on behind the surface there's
so much tension on the board look at the
pressure the black exerts on D4 look at
the potential that white has on the king
side something's going to happen here
and it's only a matter of time but I'm
on the same page page you should not
play E5 until careful consideration
because as a very wise man once said
Pawn chains are only as strong as their
base Pawn
certainly the case that Knight and F3
doing a good job of Defending D4 but as
soon as that pawn goes up to E5 black
will try to strike with C6 to C5 at the
right moment undermining the center so
Queen C2 let's keep everything defended
but where to next Donnie I mean B3 an
option I mean where is that Queen going
I'm I have no answer for you Queen B3
where is it going from there in a big
decision by Hikaru as he takes on C3 and
immediately follows up with a center
strike help me make sense of this
I mean I like the B5 Square for white
now he goes Knight to E5 then Knight can
go to C4 take control of the light
squares but if the neck goes to C4 black
is Queen C6 putting pressure on the E4
Pawn so maybe white needs to play for F3
at some point but for the moment the D4
Pawn is loose look at all the pressure
the car's pieces are exerting on White
Center the knights attacking E4 the
Queen's attacking D4 Knight C4 is played
what is Magnus planning on Queen C6 I
think it is your move F3 and it may seem
to blunder due to C takes D4 but
remember after white recaptures the
Knight on C4 is then defended Hikaru
goes the other way Queen to A6 chasing
the Knight away but it re-centralizes to
E3 and I think the trend of the game is
by a slight margin starting to favor
Magnus here and I thought he's going
Knight A3 to B5 like that B5 Square was
an outpost for his Knight and said he
centralized you can't really blame
somebody for keeping their pieces in the
center of the board but that B5 Square
Was Juicy because it also defended the
D4 Pawn so 93 and we're past that point
for now and as I look at this position
Donya I'm thinking do I start pushing my
pawns is E5 on the agenda I don't love
it because allows the Black Knight to
slide into D5 again but I'm just trying
to figure out what Magnus has in store
for akaru after the car starts trading
pots well if it was magnus's move on the
previous in the previous position he
would have played D5 and then cemented
that pawn with C4 I think that's a big
reason why Hikaru has traded on Z4 now
the move D5 it's still possible it may
still happen but it loses a lot of its
luster because after the exchange that
passed Pawn it's all alone and pass
spawns in the middle game can be a
serious liability
it's true though that Knight would love
to jump to F5 eventually so if yeah you
do trade off the pawn on E6 you get
clearance for the Knight to land on F5
that's something to keep in the back of
our minds but Donya right now a car done
a full minute on the clock I was about
to say it once again partner you're
reading my mind can a car strike with D5
because right now that pawn is a
backwards pawn and if you play Rook B1
you stop that pawn in its tracks now
your car was saying I've defended B7 I'm
gonna go after the D file and he does
just that but Magnus claiming that he's
safe and sound pushing for a pass Pawn
well he's gonna have to reinforce this
spawn because Hikaru is actually
threatening I'm busy counting the
attackers and Defenders but I think he
is threatening to capture four or five
however many times on T5 and see the
problem for the last couple moves for
Magnus has been that the queen is kind
of pegged to the E4 Pawn if you
carelessly play Queen B3 that move may
actually work out tactically because
after Knight takes E4 there's D takes E6
and maybe e takes F7 check but that has
to be carefully calculated by Carlson
and he slide said back toward B1 using
the back rank to defend the pawn
indirectly what a move and stops B5 it's
defense by attack the H7 square is
covered so if we swap everything on your
shoulders I'll show this show it because
it's very instructive the white Rook
lands on the C8 square with not just
check but Checkmate because the H7
square is covered by that white queen
that would be mate that's why Hikaru he
took on D5 once but he is not going to
keep capturing back to the live board we
go he has indeed taken on T5 Magnus not
rushing to recapture I would have
assumed that he could pre-move e takes
D5 maybe he's thinking about starting
with Knight takes D5 weighing the pros
and cons of keeping the knights on the
board versus taking them off the board
and because of the prospect of Knight F5
he decides to keep them on the board but
Robert now Knight takes D5 that threat
has been renewed
it has been but the dark squares are
compromised so if this queen slides up
to B2 at some point watch out because it
does right now slicing across the board
the same background problem exists if
you take on D5 we swap everything Rook
C8 and as you're pointing out Rook or
queen to h8 will be Checkmate look at
the queen I'll be two it covers the
entire length of the diagonal This
spells trouble for akaru who simply
slides his Rook up but done you maybe
white can do the same bringing the Rook
up on the D file he can and you
mentioned it a slightly different
defensive mechanism but the same result
the pawn on D5 was Untouchable and
Magnus continuing to tighten the screws
this is where he is best as he tightens
The Noose from all sides The Rook moves
up to C5 it can slide over to B5 and
this is right around where Hikaru is
seriously regretting not pushing B5 when
he had a chance
and he said all sides I'm also looking
at the clock that may not be on the
board but it's definitely on the car is
mine 22 seconds to over a minute he goes
Queen A7 attacking The Rook The Rook can
simply slide over to B5 white can also
make the move Queen to C3 but you have
to watch out because there's Knight E4
with a fork so watch out for these jumpy
Knights you do not want to blunder here
if you're Magnus Carlson and queen A7 is
a classic Hikaru move this is what he
does he poses problems he forces you to
make decisions and before you know it
he's dragged you into another time
scramble Rook to D to C1 by Magnus the
evil bar disapproving B6 and Hikaru is
going to go after the pawn with Queen a
AIDs but Rook C6 I was expecting Rook C7
okay so Knight D5 Rook 66 96 E3 is
checked instrumental Queen back rank
problem he goes Queen eight wow what a
move because of Rook D6 Rook d66 D5 will
fall
oh my goodness and if it falls why can
end up a pawn down maybe Queen takes F6
here is a good practical try but you
give up your queen for a rook and a
knight after Queen takes F6 I'm just
thinking about this because the P6 Pawn
is also loose and Robert another detail
Queen E5 Knight takes D5 seems to
blunder a rook but Knight takes E3 is a
double check against White's gang and
White's the one who gets mated and look
at this look at this Magnus down to 15
seconds we've got another time scramble
in Hikaru is once again in his comfort
zone yeah and Max needs to move he's
still thinking he could suck the queen
he could take B6 but D5 will fall if he
doesn't move that Knight off the board
so the pawn is gone The Rook is
protected unseason
he goes H4 instead he wants to win he
wants to win but he's down to four
seconds we've seen this story unfold
before it's an equal position
objectively but both sides making
threats Magnus down to one second The
Rook can't move from D5 the F7 Pawn is
loose the queen hits The Rook Queen
lines up with Rook on F7 watch out the
second Rook for white can come into the
game it can it can come in the game
through C4 there goes blackstroke Hikaru
offering a queen trade and that's
basically a peace offering by Nakamura
well white and black both have one
active and one passive Rook but White's
passive Rook on F4 is still more active
there's nothing to attack the player
Shuffle Hikaru gets a draw Magnus shakes
his head it is still a one point lead
for Nakamura and we're just about
halfway through this time control we've
had three draws and three of the most
exciting games I've ever seen all of
these draws have been so combative so
professional so interesting so full of
detail and hikara with yet another
incredible defensive effort Robert
and look at the car he's surprised by
whoa whoa whoa five and look he's got a
mouse
I don't think so
gotta be a mouth it's like a souped up
Budapest game but with a bishop already
fan kettled also cars like I'm the one
who plays these lines I thought he was
drinking a beer that looked like he had
a nice little uh little pint there but
either way Hikaru is shaking his head
because this is a weird position Knight
G4 attacks the pawn on E5 even if you
played Bishop G2 the Knight could still
capture on E5 because the Knight on F3
will be pinned to the bishop on G2
behind it so this is what Madness is
aiming for at first
drinking something something that's uh
dark in color you know man both of these
players
having a good time I think it's just
wake up juice that's what he's looking
for what is going on here Knight takes
E5
he's allowed it and I think he's
basically just saying blank positionally
he just says I'm slightly better in the
resulting position because I've got a
pawn in the center and you don't
that is pretty good reasoning I stand
behind that and now we see some trades
but black is not really much worse here
you play D6 you put A5 you get your
knight out he starts with A5 but the
point is that black is very solid where
are the weaknesses there are none to
point out now the one thing that I'd
watch out for is if white plays Queen C2
here it gets clever look out for Knight
G5 it loses a piece on G5 but you gain
the bishop on B7 so it's easy to forget
about tactics like that it most
certainly is lpdo Ghost C5 loose pieces
drop off C5 looks so strong here
crunching through the center and forcing
weaknesses in Black structure another
Miss by Magnus and of course the idea is
BC Rook C5 exasperation on the face of
Magnus as he hands Hikaru another
incredibly Pleasant position out of the
opening and look at the car's side
eyeing Magnus he's like what are you
doing
and and Magnus also is like what am I
doing they're both asking the same
question but there's a big problem for
black there's a four pawn it wasn't a
five and about to be captured now it's
an A4 but it's a long term weakness you
have to keep your Rook defending it
maybe to bring another piece to the
defense as well I just feel like things
are going wrong for Magnus as of this
stage of the match definitely he covers
up a point he's in control he's in
control in this game but to take the
Devil's Advocate side it's really not
the end of the world for black black has
this Pawn chain it's relatively well
defended what's funny is that Hikaru
doesn't actually have to move the Rook
away from C5 just yet he can make a
combo like A3 now he does move the Rook
but not because he has to because he
wanted to he's attacking A4 he could try
to bring the queen up to B4 a lot of
energy among White's pieces here and
Magnus has to figure out a way to get
this Knight into the game maybe just
Knight D7 is the way to do it and the
good news for Megs is if you can
successfully get his Knight to C5 it's
kind of like an outpost because white
can't play B2 to B4 because of onpassant
the a pawn will capture a knight on C5
defends that pawn and A4 it stares the
E4 Square in the center so that's what
Magnus needs to go for but as you were
indicating there might be some pressure
against the black king that's a rook
lift on C4 it could swing all the way
over to H4 so be very very careful if
you're Magnus because your king may find
itself the victim of an attack and
there's another devilish idea that I
think Hikaru has cooked up let's bring
up an analysis board real fast Knight D7
I think his idea is Queen D2 to C2 and
you might say well that walks right into
Knight C5 it defends everything look at
that Rook on D1 there's an x-ray going
on and Rook takes C5 wins material you
win a queen and a piece for two Rooks
and then you top it off with Knight G5
the idea you mentioned earlier this is
out of the question and if Knight C5 is
impossible then how hikara might
politely ask are you defending the A4
and C7 pawns at the same time I think
black is way ways to tactically defend
them maybe Rook takes C2 against Rook C7
but Robert all of that has to be
calculated and planned out very
carefully when you're down a point you
don't want to walk uh walk the tightrope
you want a nice solid game
yeah and there's Bishop A6 ideas for
black as well at some point Bishop A6
hits The Rook on C4 and the pawn on E2
but right now I think black is just a
little bit too loose to play that move
because the A4 Pawn is that important
but you know that Magnus is calculating
Bishop A6 with rookie two to follow
Bishop A6 it does open up the diagonal
it's a very tactical move and my guess
is that Hikaru it's not necessarily that
he missed Bishop A6 I just think he
intuitively believes in the power of His
pieces he believes that he's going to
find something in that position and you
can just tell both players are hard at
work calculating Bishop B7 to A6 and
maybe A3 is worth throwing in for black
as well just a thought
and that pineapple is hard at work look
at it glowing in the background behind
the car right that is his streamer set
up when he is not in California and he
is focused look at him he's looking at
this board he thinks that Magnus is
going wrong here and Magnus let me the
look on his face is one of disgust and
he does develop the Knight to D7 so
Diana Queen C2 double attack there must
be something that Magnus has and A3 has
played but apparently not great and this
is what he has been cooking up for the
last minute and a half or he actually
spent two minutes and 25 seconds on the
Move Knight D7 and it wasn't that move
he was busy finding it was the move A3
what's going on here Robert there's so
many hanging pawns Rook take C7 comes to
mind I think he wants something like
Bishop E4 and he wants to use the
contact the black queen is making with
the white Rook to be able to play a
takes B2 so I think hikaru's first order
of business has to be to address this A3
Pawn am I on the right track here is
Knight G5 possible what's happening
Robert
so many questions and I think that if
you look B3 a very calm move just
avoiding the pawn trade there could be
Rook A7 so he goes Knight G5 hitting the
H7 Pawn the queen has to take the Knight
the bishop takes the bishop on B7 and
after black is Rook a to B8 saving the
rook and attacking the bishop the C7
Pawn Falls white goes up a pawn it looks
like a healthy extra Pawn so unless
Magnus can drum up some counter play he
is simply worse and he doesn't have much
time to drum it up rook takes D7 here
there's the move Queen G5 to B5 forking
the rook and the bishop Magnus saw that
from a mile away unbelievable
calculation by both players and talk
about Walking the Tightrope you're
automatically Walking the Tightrope when
you're letting a pawn live on B2 like
this that was impressive I mean Magnus
sees Rook D7 Queen B5 and the bishop can
move up to C6 but then black gets a
second Queen The Rook the queen and the
pawn all in the same line you get to
promote you win the game in short order
so right now it's a big moment for a car
you want to play Queen takes B2 give me
that pawn but you walk into a pin so
there could be a knight C5 shot putting
pressure on the pin piece white is well
defended for the moment but Dania it
looks scary even if white remains better
that was satisfying putting pressure on
a pin piece that was quite a bit of
alliteration Hikaru says I don't care
about that pin I'm just taking all of
your pawns look at that Rook takes D6
laughing in the face of danger and what
Hikaru is saying is hey look yeah my
Bishop's Under Pressure but how are you
going to put more pressure on it I've
got two Defenders that's all I need I
could slide my Rook to P6 if necessary
and Robert Magnus might be running out
of ideas here and he is down two pawns
let's not forget that he's down to pawns
his Knight doesn't have any outposts
anymore the pawn on D6 was captured that
was an important piece protecting the
Knight on C5 so where is that night
going you need to get some counter play
some threats I feel like he might be
close to Lost already yeah and the evil
bar is bearing that out
I'm looking at rookie seven try to get
this Rook off but then black is
experiencing problems with his
background there's Rook c a check it's
not that there's options and they're
complicated I don't think they're Magnus
is a single move here he might have to
just take twice on B7 and try to win one
of White's pawns back but even that's
easier said than done well if he could
trade on B7 and win the A2 Pawn if we
just toss that pawn off the board it
does give black pretty good chances to
survive because a rook and four against
a rook and three that's white with a
rook and the four pawns from E2 to H2
and black having a rook and three pawns
that is a theoretical draw it's not easy
your ruined BK beat Gary kaspar in that
exact end game so if garricksworth can
lose then any button the balloon can
lose but that said that is the aim for
Magnus Carlsen and he's down to 20
seconds on a second I feel like he is a
bit aimless
he definitely is and Hikaru doesn't even
need two extra pawns to win when the
opponent has 20 seconds on the clock he
drops the Knight back to E6 I like that
from a practical standpoint I think
magnus's only real source of counter
play is going to be that Knight hopping
around it can hop into F4 using the pin
so Hikaru is not out of the woods and he
doesn't think he's out of the woods he
drops The Rook back to C4 and look at
the attention to detail Robert in
hikaru's play what does that move do it
stops Knight F4 that's why he put it on
C4 and he can move it to B4 to finally
unpin the bishop and then he's free to
roam about the cabin or The Rook before
there could be the queen C5 just keeping
the pin alive he goes Rook B6 Queen A5
Queen E1 check is kind of a threat
doesn't lead to anything significant
just yet but the E2 Pawn May collapse to
be very careful I see a tactic actually
if black and queen he won tg2 Knight F4
check giving up the Knight taking on E2
things like that recognition it worry so
and he carves sending the queen to E1 I
think after Knight F4 check the Rook
takes on F4 I know you were talking more
hypothetically but what's not
hypothetical is that Magnus says five
seconds on his clock his counter play is
getting just brutally extinguished and
he carves just a couple more accurate
moves away from solidifying his material
advantage in winning this game is he
gonna move his Bishop is this the time
to move it to D5 or C6 I think it looks
seems like a great time Bishop D5 looks
very good there may be a swap on B5
because there is no Knight C7 The Rook
on E8 is loose in all these positions oh
look at this clinical technique but
Magnus desperately wants that D4 square
and a card doesn't play E3 and allows
the knight in and the reason he played
A4 was in order to meet Rook takes B5
with a takes B5 this is a passer and
he's gonna push it and Magnus has no
choice but to get a pair of Rooks off
the board stopping Knight D4 Hikaru
eliminating every sliver of counter play
that Magnus is coming up with here
brilliant play from Hikaru Nakamura he
could have played Rook B8 but then A4
would have dropped and a card does not
want to give up that pawn and now we
keep a question
and meet Queen B6 ah trying to trade the
Queens good call by you keep pushing or
Rook A4 get behind the pawn Magnus says
literally two moves to drum something up
because that pawn is reaching A8 in a
tizzy and Magnus Flags it's over he
actually resigned before he flagged with
0.2 seconds left it doesn't matter
Hikaru Nakamura Jets out to a two-point
lead over the world champion Magnus
Carlson akara Nakamura saying I am here
to fight I'm here to play and I'm here
to win so Magnus you may be higher rated
you may have been the world champion for
a long time now the highest rated player
in the world last decade beating me in
classical chess this is a speeches
championship and this is a car Nakamura
this and this was an incredible start I
was impressed with hikaru's resilience
his time scrambling ability but this
game Robert this game I think we can all
agree took the cake because this was a
wire to wire Victory he took that E5
opening experiment in stride he
responded with a conservative approach
he got a slight Advantage out of the
opening and he twisted the screws and
twisted The Noose and he played Magna
style until Carlson ran out of Counter
play ran out of time and now he's
staring down the barrel of a two-point
deficit well he also ran out of the room
he gets a break now so does hicaro so do
we so we are going to use that brick but
before we return I do want to shout out
the nearly 140 000 people watching this
match don't worry we'll only be gone a
couple minutes the excitement continues
here at the speed Chess Championship
final let's get a car Nakamura and
Magnus Carlson
what is this this is duck chess you guys
this is a new variant it's called duck
chess chess but with a duck quack quack
how to play duck chest the duck is a
brick pieces cannot move through the
square occupied by the duck you're gonna
score it to place the dog
oh he put the deck to prevent moves of
opponent not yourself
Yeah so basically you do this and this
cannot move I'm gonna go Knight F6 and
I'm gonna put the duck in the most
inconvenient place for my opponent to
move no Bishop no Queen so no londons
can permanently stop the London capture
the points Keen to win oh wow oh there's
no stalemate but still wait there is
still me but the still made the player
wins ooh if only that was real chess I
think I'm getting the hang of this game
I think I think I actually am getting
the hang of it
I think this works oh that's a horrible
blunder oh my God I just blundered I
have to move something else first then
dark and Knight will take my king this
is the best way to lose the dog chest
[Music]
there are some real bullet skills right
there boys this is the first time
winning duck chest
oh no no no no no no slip no no no no no
no
I won
and duck chess champion give me those
points baby
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
the fans have spoken that this
speechless championship match is more
exciting than the World Cup final they
chat said it you have to believe it but
I am Grandmaster Robert Hess alongside
me is Grandmaster Daniel narodiski Donya
right now at card Nakamura with a two
point lead it's been surprising but it's
been powerful from Nakamura it has
indeed and before I delve into that
Robert just wanted to to take a step
back and say first of all that I'm
having a huge bless I'm having the time
of my life and it's an honor to be a
part of this event I cannot believe the
viewership I can't believe the activity
and energy in the chat and this has just
been this is going to be one of the most
unforgettable three hours of my life I
can already tell you that and so far
it's been an unforgettable first half of
the five-minute portion for Hikaru
Nakamura he has displayed the whole
gamut of skills from time scrambling to
positional ability to Tactical sharpness
he hasn't made a single blunder early
signs pointing hikaru's way Robert
they often say third time is the charm
this is the third Clash of the Titans
it's Nakamura Carlson number three in
the SEC final Magnus Carlson won the
first two bouts in 2016 and 2017 and in
speeches formats Magnus does quite well
against Hikaru it's not surprising but
it isn't close and the car is getting
better and better in the year 2022 akar
Nakamura has not lost a game to Magnus
Carlsen and done if I'm not mistaken
Magnus has yet to win in the first five
games of this match and he's come close
he came close in the first game and he
played with an abundance of caution in
the early part of the match and maybe
he's starting to regret that and maybe
that's the change that Magnus needs to
make in those 50 50 situations where
he's got a tiny Edge in the end game
he's been kind of opting for those
drawers continuations and maybe we're
going to see Magnus consciously start to
take on more risk he's got plenty of
time right there's an eternity left on
the match clock but you just know Hikaru
has a way of stepping on the gas pedal
when he he smells blood
well he's up three and a half so one and
a half at the moment Hikaru Nakamura he
has won two games three games have been
drawn Magnus has won none and Magnus
Carson has changed quite literally he
has changed his attire we are gonna
bring him on screen now okay you can see
that something was not right chess
players can be quite superstitious and
now Magnus is in green and he wants to
win that green by taking down a car
Nakamura in this final that's hilarious
it reminds me of those you know those
psychology studies where they show that
you're actually not attentive to change
at all I'm impressed you noticed that
but I was like green Magnus Carl so we
definitely didn't see that before am I
crazy uh we have seen Berlin's before in
the chess career if he car Nakamura
haven't we
we certainly have we see eight four
played by Magnus and Hikaru looks to the
side he's like what is Magnus aiming for
what is my preparation and let's not
confuse the matter both of these players
prepare and maybe they don't prepare it
right before the match for this specific
game but they are so well prepared
throughout their careers that when
Magnus plays some sideline ikar says yep
I've seen this one before they're locked
and they're loaded and they review their
lines constantly and this move a to A4
it might strike you as puzzling it was
the recommendation of opening specialist
Grandmaster Daria schwerch uh in a
recent book that he wrote on the real
Lopez this is what he recommended
against the Berlin and the idea is to
keep this bishop on B5 for the time
being now eventually it often slides
back to F1 anyway and then the pawn
advances to A5 just kind of clamping
down on the queen side but look at this
look at this for Magnus he goes D4
sacrificing the pawn any car says no I
want the Berlin
he gives the Pod back on e4 and that's
what great players do they don't get
materialistic they say I will give you
that pawn back but I will get time and
activity you play D5 with Tempo Against
The Rook on e4 The Rook slides back now
the light Square Bishop can get out from
C8 and go to G4 as you're indicating so
one big thing that Magnus in a car would
need to figure out is Bishop takes C6 a
threat if you're reading my mind
structure and the Knight is trying to
come into E5 to follow so Bishop G4 at
least eliminates the Knight E5 follow-up
and that's why Cara played Bishop G4
with the pit and Magnus delaying for the
time being he procrastinates on the
decision but he improves his position
nonetheless the move C3 is necessary it
takes the sting out of Bishop takes F3
will he take on C6 now something tells
me he'd rather keep his Bishop on the
board but who knows he could also move
A5 right now and there's a reason why if
black responds to A5 with the pawn push
A6 now it is time to take on C6 so if we
can actually bring up an analysis board
and show that I think it's very
instructive that what white wants to
accomplish in inducing move A6 is to get
a clamp on the dark squares B4 no C5
Pawn push for you and once you've
established this control of the dark
squares yes right now the eval Bar says
that black is better but in the long
term black is stuck with these Pawn
weakness in place you're absolutely
right I think this is a great line and
this shows that there is a lot at stake
here well there's twenty thousand
dollars at stake and an SEC title but in
this particular position what's at stake
is the future of Black's Queen side this
is an idea Hikaru has to take seriously
and after A5 he might decide to drop the
Knight back to E7 maybe this is part of
the reason he put his Bishop on D6 but
first Magnus takes a rain check on that
and asks politely or not so politely
whether hikara wants to stay on this
diagonal and I think he does
well if he wants to play Bishop H5 he
has to be ready for the move G2 to G4 we
often tell our students don't push Pawns
in front of your king it makes your king
weaker less safe but sometimes you want
to break a pin it's that important so G4
is a possibility in some positions with
Knight E5 Galloping into the center so
right now Hikaru is Bishop F5 he drops
interesting 95 still a possibility here
for Magnus
it is indeed as is Bishop B5 to D3 if
you really want to bail out but if you
want to fight for the advantage here I
think you need to introduce some form of
imbalance Robert I don't think you're
beating Hikaru with a pawn structure as
it currently stands Bishop takes C6 and
95 looks pretty tempting and it's funny
that Hikaru is actually provoking this I
think he's doing that consciously I
think he senses that Magnus isn't quite
as comfortable as he normally is taking
these kinds of positional risks and he's
inviting it and taking the Hess approach
is there Knight A5 and C6 though
wow that's a big tactical shot and if
it's available that would be huge for
Hikaru and he's gonna look at it I mean
he's looking quizzically at the board he
plays A6 that's a big opportunity for
Magnus a car doesn't see that little
tactical shot Here and Now Dania Bishop
C6 and pawn B4 it looks like you get the
clamp that's desired on the queen side
that was a fantastic call and you get an
even better version of it because the
Knight is now free to jump into E5 when
necessary supplementing the potential
move Queen A4 and that pawn on C6 is
going to be under Fire from all angles
right and so Magnus hasn't moved yet he
might play your Bishop D3 just try to
gain space in the queen side first then
trade Bishops but I like Bishop takes C6
with Knight E5 or B4 first the point is
that you are just getting the activity
that you desire there is no pin on that
knight any longer and correct me if I'm
wrong it doesn't seem like Bishop takes
E6 is that much of a risk yes you're
giving up the bishop Bear yes in the
future you might have to consider some
sacks on H3 and you have to watch for
the safety of your king but it's not
like Bishop takes C6 Burns any Bridges
and Magnus doesn't want to burn any
Bridges at all is he playing a little
bit too conservatively not to criticize
the world champion of course but I think
you kind of get what I'm saying here
Robert
of course I get what you're saying I
think that he is just a little bit
sloppy in the early stages he'd be the
first to say that that's not an undue
criticism and for Hikaru when he's been
making mistakes it feels like they're
not as consequential I mean that game
where Magnus won a pawn he had some
great chances but he just couldn't make
the most of it and Hikaru on the other
hand he won a game on time that was uh
big it was a must and then he won
another game by stealing a couple pawns
and converting it with Precision so
Queen D7 is Bishop takes H3 a threat
Magnus didn't want to find out so he
takes place Knight H4 and he's gonna
play Queen G4 and try to get that Knight
to F5 and this is the kind of Chess that
we are accustomed to see for Magnus
Carlson tightening the screws playing on
both sides of the board and he moves the
queen up not to G4 but one square behind
on F3 you're not threat threatening
Queen takes D5 don't blunder Bishop H2
but what you are threatening is Knight
H4 to F5 and that is why Hikaru
Engineers pressure on on the e-file to
distract White's attention away from the
F5 square and force white to address the
subtle threat Robert of Rook takes E1
checkmate well A5 is a weakness that's a
big Point here Bishop D2 Rook takes E1
you'd love to take back with your Rook
on E1 get the open file but A5 Falls you
cannot afford to lose that pawn because
not only is it a pawn but the Knight
Will sink its teeth into those light
squares on the queen side so big choice
for Magnus he would Bishop E3 blocking
the Rooks axis in the e-file but you're
also blocking your own Rook on E1 and
that just doesn't feel very pleasant the
Blackboard can slide up to E4 and
suddenly it's Hikaru who has all the fun
in the position
well you like to observe when offense
changes into defense and I think we're
seeing and vice versa we're seeing that
here Magnus drove that pawn up to A5 it
was unequivocally a strength you were
grabbing space on the queen side all of
a sudden it's turned into perhaps
White's biggest weakness and I think we
are going to see Hikaru taking on E1 and
his magnet is going to recapture with
the bishop here no he's gonna sack the
ball and I think he's going to make a
serious play for quick King side attack
based on Knight H4 to F5 and nikaru is
like oh I didn't necessarily take this
as seriously as I could have because he
thought Knight takes A5 was a pawn but
Knight of five and queen G4 is the big
threat there some people may think
you're just trying to take this bishop
on D6 no no no no no no no you're
threatening Checkmate on G7 in a
discovery but pieces are on the same
line as each other in this case a queen
on G4 and a queen on D7 you have to
think what happens when the piece in
between gets out the way so G6 play to
stop Knight to five Magnus can play Pawn
to B4 here Dania that's available and he
just says I've gained all the space on
the queen side and now I don't have to
worry about losing that pawn and another
wise decision by Hikaru that's easy to
gloss over he says I'm avoiding Knight
takes A5 with the 10 foot pull but not
only that he didn't take 90 seconds to
make that decision he keeps his Edge on
the clock you're surprised by the move
G3
well D5 is now uh can be captured before
it could not because the bishop H2 check
with a discovery so H3 can be captured
A5 can be captured but no matter what we
captured black takes everything can be
captured but D5 will fall that's such an
important Pawn in Black's position it
frees up the rest of the white pieces so
a big move there from Magnus good
recognition and a car needs to find a
move does he just defend the pawn on D5
with Knight to E7 but that allows the
Bishop from D2 to go into H6 the queen
to go to F6 and watch out for checkmate
and that's because the move G6 it wasn't
all peaches and cream yes you stopped
Knight F5 you stop one thing you open
close some doors you open others and
after Bishop H6 and queen F6 uh the door
to the two point lead is going to be
closed for kikaru so he's got to do
something about this and he's got to
defend D5 at the same time he's got a
lot on his to-do list here Robert maybe
bishop back to E7 should be considered
but that is a little bit passive and I
think he cars hesitating uh to basically
hand the initiative over to Carlson
there's also this Knight maneuver to F4
so just because you defend upon once
doesn't mean you're going to keep it
alive forever
and one thing about B4 which has finally
been played is if the Queens are off the
board black will play B6 and if we get a
swap on B6 well that gets an outside
pass Pawn so keep that in mind that a
queen trade could be very very bad for
white with Rooks and pieces on the board
so right now Magnus has no interest in
trading Queens how piccard does that is
a great question and your idea Knight H4
to G2 to F4 that goes right after the D5
Pawn centralize the Knight and then I
can use the H Pawn as a battering ram he
car shaking his head he knows that these
are the exactly the kinds of positions
that we are accustomed to see Magnus
winning well over 50 of the time we're
also accustomed to see Hikaru defending
them well over 50 of the time who's
going to Prevail as Magnus continues to
tighten the screws but Hikaru defends
with C6 and that's a big move because
finally the pressure has been taken off
the pawn and Hikaru can focus on
protecting his King side
there's the move Queen F6 here threatens
Rook takes E7 but I think black doesn't
have rookie because Queen E5 you just
get a pin everywhere the Magnus making
Magnus moves King G2 small incremental
progress but a car is jumping in he's
making Hikaru moves and he's he's also
forcing Magnus to make a move Who's down
to 17 seconds reshuffling rerouting But
Here Comes hikaru's Knight sinking its
teeth into E4 I think he car is getting
the upper hand here well now we love 95
with Tempo so he didn't win the Knight
to E4 and well he trades Rooks now he's
gonna go 95 no he's just gonna trade
everything Queen E4 here forces the
queen trade that's a bad news for Magnus
who's in time travel if he takes the
queen Knight takes back and the C3 Pawn
is loose so goodness
98 almost wins the game why does the
cling to the bishop he carved down to
eight seconds he's played it where's the
queen going back to F4 wow Bishop H6
trade and then bring the knight in he
wants a repetition I don't think he
Minds a repetition he's up two points in
the match no need to do anything crazy
but we know Hikaru he's thinking about
it yeah three seconds I think he just
repeats he makes the draw Hikaru he
keeps his two-point lead that is good
match management by a car Nakamura
remember we see the eval bar go up and
down the players have no idea and that
looked like an equal position the same
amount of material for both sides so now
we're in game seven it's four to two
Hikaru are we gonna see a king's Indian
from Madness
we might and we saw King's Indian
earlier from Hikaru Magnus saying give
me some of that will Hikaru Play Bishop
D3 oh my gosh he does
we have the same position with colors
reversed I'll let up strategy a little a
little Verve from Hikaru Nakamura and
smiles like only one player Magnus is
not amused
and just like the recent movie that
smile is not pleasant that is gonna
haunt Magnus Carlson Bishop D3 induces
Bishop G4 looks very logical and then
the bishop would have gone back to E2 so
he said anything you can do I can do
better and he just says let's go Magnus
you're gonna have to come up with
something new and another perk of
putting the bishop on D3 is that it can
slide back to C2 and later on once the
Knight appears on C5 as it frequently
does in the king's Indian the pressure
on e4 often forces white to contort
himself with the bishop nicely sitting
on C2 white can just keep going about
his business in this move H3 we saw
Carlson play G4 ikara says Q can play at
that game
they certainly can and for Magnus he has
to figure out which strike he wants E5
or C5 he chooses neither he plays A5 he
wants to gain space on the queen side
and not allow bayonet style attack with
Pawn to B4 so I think that Magnus is
kind of playing this like dodgy chest
he's just sort of avoiding the tension
he's just making a car figure out things
but the issue for Magnus is usually that
works except in this match akaro has
figured everything out pretty much the
Perfection he most certainly has and I
think this opening Choice by Magnus it
signifies that he is ready to take on
more risk he wants to wipe this
two-point lead out going to the three
plus one portion he knows how confident
Hikaru is in that notorious title
Tuesday time control and Magnus doesn't
want to let this lead persist because
every game you play when you're down by
two you might go down by three and ikar
was not known to give away big leads in
the SEC even against someone of
Carlson's caliber no and you and I both
majored in history in college and well
history for Magnus does not he does not
want to repeat itself because the only
time he has lost the five plus one time
control was against Maxine vashir lagrav
in 2020 semifinals and guess what he
lost that match so he lost the segment
four and a half three and a half and
that's the only time that has happened
it's the only time he's lost in the SEC
so Magnus he needs to get things right
he needs to just play solidly not take
unnecessary risk but also kind of make
things a bit spicy and that's exactly
what he's doing we have in some ways a
similar position from their first King's
Indian Affair once again the colors were
reversed in that game no you're not
seeing things Hikaru was indeed on the
black side now he's on the white side
and he's taking a different approach on
the king side Robert the reason you
don't want to go G4 here is because the
Knight is going to jump into F4 never go
Knight back to F6 in these positions
that's a king's Indian crime you don't
mind sacrificing upon to open up that
dark scored Bishop
right I mean let's go for an attack and
well Magnus says Don't Mind If I Do A4
the problem is A3 one Pawn can attack
all of the enemy forces if you play A3
white pushes the B Pawn keeps the file
closed so I'm looking at this I feel
like Magnus sure he wants B5 easier said
than done right Dania because I can take
then bring a Queen to E2 try to protect
that pawn at all costs yeah and you also
have to watch out for a well-timed
bishop takes C5 normally white doesn't
want to give away uh the dark squid
Bishop but when the circumstances are
right Black's position it's really
flimsy it's cramped and we're also not
talking about the king side at some
point white could get the wheels turning
on the other side of the board with you
know a well-timed G4 you could try even
Knight C3 to E2 and G4 on the other hand
you got to be very careful about not
allowing B5 uh because Black's attack
comes really fast once the B file gets
opened what do you make of magnus's
decision to play a king's Indian against
the world leader in the king's Indian I
feel like it's a little bit almost
desperate
right I was attracted briefly to Knight
G5 check but icaro doesn't take the
adventurous route I agree that it smacks
a little bit of desperation and I don't
appreciate that you're calling the
king's Indian A desperate I'm not just
kidding I agree completely
yeah I just feel like a car is so good
at the king's Indian when he is the
black pieces so you know he knows how to
Parry off the immediate threats and
you're pointing out Knight H4 to F5 the
reason why that's a viable option is the
Knight on H5 is loose a car plays it uh
but something about the move is not
favored by the engine and I wonder what
it is Donya like how does black proceed
here C6 is a typical plan it doesn't
look so ideal right now so what can
Magnus do so I did cheat a little bit
apparently the best move is Knight H5
back to F6 now it's a logical move
because it parries Knight F5 but the
reason Knight H4 is a little bit awkward
I think is because it's just hard to get
things going uh after the Knight moves
back to F6 it's kind of a one move
threat and if black parries it
Blackstock playing for F5 in this
position but Magnus does not period he
allows Knight F5 and I don't like that
one bit even though the bishop is bad
from an attacking perspective Robert
it's integral from a defensive
perspective and I really think Hikaru
can get things going on the king side
once he eliminates this bishop
and I think Magnus is trying to use your
plan like Queen I think E8 and I try to
go B5 as quickly as possible Right the
Queen the bishop The Rook on B8 all
stare at the B5 Square so I believe
that's what Magnus is aiming for but he
keeps pausing he's down two minutes
there's an a knife on F5 it's daggers
and he goes Queen E8 but I feel like
he's just a little bit slow right now
and Hikaru is definitely not so he can
now play the move F2 F4 assuming black
takes for the Knight and why can he play
that move because there's no longer a
bishop on G7 so that Bishop it had a lot
of potential energy it was preventing
white from striking on the king side now
I think hikaru's got to step on it and
play F4
throw those pawns forward go for an
attack black is very much trying to do
the same with B7 to B5 that's magnus's
big idea but as you point out Bishop E3
takes Knight on C5 will shatter Black's
Pawn structure so D5 doesn't just get
you an attack doesn't win the game it
gets you a really bad Pawn structure and
you better hope your attack is in time
and there we go ladies and gentlemen
fasten your speed belts this is a good
old school attack on opposite sides
clearly Hikaru much much better the
engine isn't a fan of what Magnus is
doing but at this point Magnus has no
choice he literally has one idea in this
entire position it's to open the B file
pile up on the B2 Pawn maybe look for
some Knight B3 tactics but largely he's
playing hope chess
he has yeah he's it's wishful thinking
that he is going to get an attack but
look at the clocks a car had a two
minute lead it's now dropped to one
that's still a hefty margin for him he's
well ahead in the clock but I just feel
like Magnus he could scare people and
hikar is only human he may play like an
engine he's still a human being and look
at this he strikes in the center takes
on C5 goes D6 and the Evo bar doesn't
love it but I think from a practical
point of view it gets white activity and
that's exactly what you want whoa and it
also gets quite a huge Fork threat and
another Fork threat and how do you parry
both at the same time because F take C5
is also on the docket to open up the D
file oh I think F takes C5 and queen F2
just looks terrible for black
everything's falling apart at the seams
I think that was a brilliant try from
Hikaru a pawn sacrifice he didn't even
take back on D6 which he could have he
hops his Knight into D5 it was a
clearance move and now Knight F6 checks
a big threat if de5 as you said Rook F1
or queen to F2 actually looks even
stronger hitting C5 going down F7
everything is under attack and
apparently Robert I'm gonna rewind for
just a second the only move in this
position was Knight to H5 to keep in
contact with the E5 Pawn this is such an
engine move just dropping the Knight
back toward the corner Magnus played the
obvious move he's down to 30 seconds
he's backpedaling furiously and trying
to keep the center patched up I think
Hikaru can play Ed I think he'd play
Queen F2 this is like the worst kind of
position to have against Nakamura with
30 seconds left on your clock although B
takes C4 is an option the B file is open
and be very careful if you're a Hikaru
do not take your eyes off the B2 Pawn if
black and line Queen and Rook up their
Checkmate threats with a knight on D5
covers F6 so the queen can't get there
it covers B6 the queen can't get there
Bishop 6 is trying to eliminate White's
best piece all you can eat a car is just
grabbing and grabbing and eating but
apparently the email bar didn't like
this move what's the defense I don't
think Magnus can find this in 14 seconds
no he goes Knight takes he said but
Queen D6 Queen D6 Knight of six check
gets the queen right back Knight C7 as
you're pointing out also looks very
strong but Queen h8 wow that is so easy
to miss and then things get crazy you
can go E5 the Knight jumps into C4 if
Hikaru had 15 seconds at this point hey
this would have been a game but he's got
a minute 40 he's got an eternity on the
clock to figure this out and he starts
with E5
okay oh my gosh not loved by the engines
Rook B5 if Queen takes a six you swap
queens and win the D5 Knight so uh you
know you gotta keep your material and
speaking of material white is only up
one Punk Queen accepts and queen takes
B5 as a Desperado he's gotta move this
guy wait what does Magnus do
what a shots
and then Rook 65 at the end and the
Knight oh nice thought trap is Rook B8
wow this goes right for the pawn he just
wants an attack of the car could even
play like King A1 Bishop B1 he can curl
up into a ball instead he eliminates the
attacker
and his Rook takes a two of possibility
but he car going for mate he wants
rookies
one second left Magnus lose on time
Hikaru Nakamura sticks a knife on F6 and
it is knockout five to two is the score
nobody's counting back as Carlson out
but who would have believed that Hikaru
Nakamura would jump out to a three-point
lead this early in the match the
original name of hikaranakamura's stream
back in the Stone Age back before he
streamed on his own twitch Channel it
was naka's Knockouts little known fact
and he is scoring one knockout after
another repelling Magnus Carlson's
King's Indian Robert that game it wasn't
even close see Cara was in control
essentially from the first move until
the last in that game
he was now he hopped at night from F3 to
H4 into F5 he played D6 and cleared the
D5 Square for his other Knight brilliant
play from icaro Nakamura now with the
white pieces uh Magnus Carlson now
obviously got a must-win territory but I
think for his confidence for his psyche
he needs to get one right now he does
and the lead itself from a sort of pure
match perspective it's a three-point
lead we've seen three-point leads
disappear like I don't know what
disappears name something that
disappears but Houdini Argentina's lead
uh in the first half of the World Cup
except they ended up winning so that's
not a very good analogy Houdini Houdini
doing an act we've seen three-point
leads disappear in the bullet segment
and Magnus still has an entire 60
Minutes of three plus one but given the
way this match is gone Robert that may
be a bad thing ikaro is playing with
such confidence he feels that he can
just put this match away I think with
another couple of victories
and Magnus gets the same position he had
earlier right this was good for him in
that game uh where he just allowed the
bishop to take on C3 got the open B file
and it looked very promising so we have
the same position Knight E5 to C4 and
will Hikaru try to get B5 in earlier
this was the closest Hikaru came to
losing a game what I'm implying here
Robert is that Hikaru still hasn't lost
the game wait is that true that is true
hikara has not lost the game in this
match he's pulling a Magnus and he's
taking another Swig from that I think
it's called a Stein s t e i n I learned
that word recently it's like a big big
mug
yes but usually you drink beer out of
the stone so no I don't know
that is an old school chess reference a
good one at that what a legendary player
uh but C5 is a good move hiccard played
it before and I just have to say really
quickly here that Hikaru Nakamura he's
looking poised he's looking like he
literally doesn't care and he's
definitely not phased by playing Magnus
Carlson he definitely is and you can
just see it in his body language we've
tried to put less of an accent on body
language we don't have the ultimate
Hikaru expert Danny wrench here to guide
us but still I mean you don't need more
than a perfunctory glance to just sense
that the confidence right now is in
Florida it's not in Norway and Magnus
Carlson well he's got 10 more minutes in
the five plus one to chip into this lead
he does and just want to give a shout
out to the over 140
000 of you watching on Twitch and
YouTube we appreciate it I think the
players they love the support even
though this is stressful time for them
but Rook to B1 played by Magnus he is
putting some stress down the B file
because the queen on B6 is under attack
behind it the pawn on B7 and the B5
square is just one The Rook would like
to jump to Queen C6 not possible right
now because Knight E5 is a fork the
queen goes back to C7 at the very least
Tanya black had a kind of retreat the
last couple moves and white has this
healthy two Pawns in the center and is
targeting the pawn on B7 and I guess
Hikaru believes in the pressure that he
is exerting on White Center from a match
from a stylistic perspective I think
this is right up magnus's alley he loves
these types of positions practically
speaking I think he's got a slight Edge
and like I said this type of position is
where Hikaru came close to losing so
he's gonna have to continue being
precise and I think we might see a
change of opening against the Catalan in
the three plus one segment
and then their third head-to-head SEC
final this will be the first win against
magazine any time segment so uh Hikaru
in Blitz against Magnus is not one that
those time patrols he is going to win
this one because Max this game and
another remaining so it looks like
Hikaru is going to take a lead heading
into the shorter time controls it most
certainly does and he piles up on the D4
upon which is currently safely defended
by the Knight the problem is that if you
try to jump into E5 you take your eyes
off of the pawn and the D7 Rook just has
this nice parking spot on D6 you can
keep chasing it but that doesn't really
lead anywhere or does it Magnus sinks
his teeth into B5
I like that move why not that's a good
Square you force the trade no more
tension and B6 but quickly buy Hikaru
um that pawn now is targeted by this
Rook the D4 Pawn well defended but done
at the E4 Pawn that feels just a bit
loose and if black can induce the move
E4 to E5 then Knight and F6 hops to D5
where it protects the B6 Pawn we've
talked about this in these types of
structures that's precisely what Hikaru
is trying to engineer and Magnus says
I'm not playing E5 I'm playing D5 first
and now I think he's gonna play E5
basically filling the cavity with a pawn
before pushing the pawn to E5 and then
he gets this D4 Square for his Knight he
takes on B6 first he might take an F6
okay he doesn't but I was looking at a
possible exchange sacrifice on the F6
square instead Magnus pushed to E5 now
the Knight going to D4 is excellent for
white the Knight goes to C3 maybe
there's Queen G4 with Knight F5 to
follow so maybe there's a rook sack on
B1 for the attack oh my gosh so maybe
another Rook sack on G6 later on and
literally this is exactly what Magnus
needs to do more of he needs to take
these tactical risks but he just doesn't
believe in himself tactically thus far
in the match and he lets another
opportunity go by the wayside
yeah I think Knight D4 was a huge attack
it looked very strong but he wants to
bring his second Rook to B6 after the
queen slides away to C8 The Rook on B1
goes to B6 there could still be a rook
sack along that rank over there and
Knight D4 is to follow but see the
problem is that you've given a Hikaru a
Tempo now what is he going to use this
tempo for I think he's gonna go Rook D7
to C7 not so much to infiltrate although
that does become a big threat but also
to involve the queen in the defense and
the move Knight D4 it loses a lot of its
luster because the Knight doesn't have
access to F5 the Queen's going to be
controlling that square
it's a really good point because Knight
D4 to F5 was the threat now the queen
covers so Rook C7 looks like good up to
his Knight C5 back Donya giving up the
A5 Pawn whoa blank first passer he's
playing for a win he wants to take
control of the initiative here but
sometimes playing for a win is playing
for a loss this is a double-edged
decision all three results possible and
if I am Magnus here I'm trying to find a
way to stop that pawn before it becomes
a Runway train
and it's supported by two Rooks the pawn
is guarded from a distance maybe Rook B6
to D6 can be considered he slides his
Queen into C4 but ikaro easily repels
that move with Rook C7 that's the great
thing about being doubled the other Rook
still protects D4 this is anybody's game
and Knight B7 becomes a huge threat of
Discovery against the queen on C4
hitting the Rook on A5 so you have to
watch out for that you can play Rook A5
to B5 for example and then we Rook B8 is
you know available but you still have to
watch out for this passer the black
queen can jump into the action you
should play a knight B and D7 and D7
available you can actually attack both
of white trucks and I mean let's not
forget about the past d-pawn that's
still in play and it might remind us of
its existence on this very move
Queen before what a choice if Pawn to D3
is it goes Knight D3 instead using the
Knight to hop in and that Rook can go to
C3 the queen go to G4 Knight F4 check is
available this is Scary For What Black's
position is filled to the brim with
tactical potential and what's not filled
to the brim look at magnus's clock he is
again down two minutes and the position
is just getting more and more out of
hand
it is he's just allowed he's one for
Knight F4 and it's mate yeah hey car
season he's a car can't believe it he
looked at this
this is basic Brian Robert this is an
idea that occurs across all openings
this is universal and you can't step
back to the first rank because of Rook
C1 with maid it's over yeah no Hikaru
saw it and look at him he's like are you
serious am I really playing Magic this
is all you got he says to Magnus he's
gonna be up four points and Magnus has
got a match on his hands doesn't he oh a
match I mean he's gonna have to work
hard to stay evil because he won Queen
H3 yeah just look at that mate
yeah oh that's over
hack horror
six to two and you know what hakara's
face said is the double question mark
that you saw it in his eyes he's like is
is this really Magnus Carlson or is this
an imposter uh this isn't Among Us you
gotta play chess and right now Magnus
Carlson is down six to two Dania can you
believe it
I cannot believe it he's under magnus's
skin he is filled with confidence he
believes right now does he Kara Nakamura
that he can win every single game in
this match it's like what basketball
players talk about when they start
hitting shots the net is as wide as the
ocean right now for Hikaru Nakamura and
that is a terrifying Prospect for Magnus
he's down by four this is the final game
of the five minute portion and once
again Carlson going for a very tactical
opening and look at Hikaru he meets him
at the top he says you want a night off
I'll give you an idol I'll give you the
sharpest night of because I want to win
this game and get to a five point lead
I just am in disbelief Bishop D7
covering the C6 Square so you can be
familiar with that move and neither is
the power by the looks of it
uh
uh you why does this always happen to us
it only took nice say 87 minutes
well we've been here the whole time the
players giving it their all in the CaRu
he's giving it that stink eye he's like
this smells fishy I don't believe in it
but it actually looks quite solid for
black because the one downside of
playing Bishop D7 is your Pawn on B7 is
a bit loose uh E5 comes to mind for
white just trying to get at that pawn on
B7 uh but there might even be like a
knight C6 follow-up in that position so
you have to be very careful before you
push E5
that is a worthy line to show but we're
not going to show it because they are
past that Hikaru decides to continue his
development it is very typical in this
line to Castle queenside and is it time
for E5 no another developing move
and the evil bar not a fan is that
Bishop going to be vulnerable after
black put something on the C file yeah
Queen C7 that's a standard Sicilian move
uh the bishop that kind of sews in
Bishop on C4 not great here it's
vulnerable to attack the Knight can hop
to A5 later so I feel like the black
position is extremely solid at this
point and so Magnus has everything he
could hoped for out of the opening this
was a very astute Choice Bishop D7
taking Hikaru out of his comfort zone I
assume he'll meet Queen C7 with the
sozen-esque bishop B3 where the bishop
is very safely protected but I suppose
the problem in that position isn't so
much the bishop as the attack the
blackened on roll on the queen side of
the Moonlight B5
it can get really scary so I like the
move Queen C7 just getting off the D
file I just don't like the look of E5
with some kind of like Knight takes E6
at some point it just looks scary to my
eyes I know it doesn't work Dania right
there you get too many pieces but I just
don't like the queen staring down the
line towards an enemy Rook no you're
absolutely right I don't either
and Magnus doesn't like the placement of
the bishop on G5 which can now drop back
to H4 but then you have to start
Reckoning with tactics based on the fact
that the bishop will no longer be
defended of course the immediate 94 in
that position fails because you take the
bishop first but you gotta watch out for
that that's just another thing for
Hikaru to keep track of and the queen
lands on B6
and hikar does not want to take on C6
that will improve the light Square
Bishop the light Square Bishop on D7 and
the Knight C6 fighting for the same
square I see an argument for Knight to
B3 here just trying to play on the queen
side but Bishop F2 great awareness from
ikaru he improves the location of his
Bishop because you didn't want to take
on F6 anyway and he defends the center
and perhaps forcing the bishop on F2
actually did more harm than good because
now the Knight it's a little bit more
solid you can consider taking and
playing E5 there's always this Prospect
of Bishop G4 pinning the the queen
but that involves making too many
weaknesses and Magnus sidesteps the
tension with another typical Sicilian
move we see this in the dragon and the
night or very frequently Knight A5
and the big question is when or if black
will Castle right Castle kingside you
may be walking into an attack because
you created a hook the pawn on H6 wishes
it could push back to H7 so that when G4
G5 happens the king isn't opening
castles hello weed side and it was an
objectively terrible Choice apparently
but I think practically it could be hard
to punish
yeah but look at the C file Robert look
at the C file he's gonna get a rook to
C1 and he's gonna harass the queen Force
to get to the side of the board this
just looks terrible
what you need for black is a trade that
dark Square Bishop away because if you
could get your queen to E5 oh that'd be
excellent for black but you can't get
over there so this is a big problem this
is a really really big problem Rook C1
already threatens discoveries like
Knight to D or B5 uh the queen will have
to go on a journey so I I'm not liking
this for uh for Magnus excuse me I feel
like castling Queen side was two just
too wild it looks so flimsy it looks
like he's already barely hanging on I
don't like to show engine lines but if I
may make this one exception it'll be
worth it let's bring up an analysis
board asicaro contemplates how to
continue this initiative Rook C1 is what
he's thinking about and if the queen
moves up to A5 look at this subtle move
A3 and you even say it quietly A3
repairing B4 where is that Queen gonna
go is it gonna go back to B6 walking
into one Discovery is it gonna go back
to C7 walking into another black might
have to play Rook C8 you played before
and now Robert you called it Queen E3 oh
that walks into a fork no it doesn't
Knight C6 check with Queen A7 coming to
a theater near you the attack is
decisive and White's gonna pick up the
queen after that with Bishop B6 check
well I don't think Magnus wants to await
that theatrical release that looks
horrible that looks scary and Hikaru of
course is aiming for just this variation
he plays B4 right away wow what a Hikaru
move he's like please take my Pawn on B4
uh play A3 and if you go Queenie fight
back there's Knight B93 and the queen
might get trapped 95. what an idea this
is amazing he reverses the order of
these two moves so that both of them
occur with Tempo and the queen has to
take the pawn you have no choice and
maybe you have to go to C4 but oh my God
black is walking on some red hot coals
here you have to look at a car's face
he's stunned I think he's playing it up
for the fans right now but he truly is
stunned that this is happening to Magnus
Carlsen and if Queen C4 uh these Knight
D5 discoveries you may be able to take
on D5 if you're gonna lose your queen
gobble up as much material as possible
right so Queen C4 Knight you have e
takes D5 Rook takes on the C4 you take
back you get a minor piece a rook and a
pawn Lasker cop compensation for a queen
and long Castle Robert that epitomizes
what has happened to Magnus in the five
minute portion that was such an
uncharacteristic decision castling into
the attack depriving the queen of
necessary Escape squares magnus's
judgment his intuition what he has hung
his hat on for his entirety of his chess
career it's it's left him it's
disappointed him to put it mildly and
Hikaru has exploited it for everything
he's got now does he play Knight D5 and
allow the Lasker compensation or do you
play something like B3 and B4 and keep
harassing the queen oh my God Robert
there's the way to trap the queen
yeah I see what you're saying B3 then B4
and then I need your night away yes
traps the Queen the reason why we're
talking about this is if Knight A2 right
away if white just plays that move the
queen is the A4 Square to run to so if
the pawn were on B4 that looks like it's
very weakening for the white king but
you actually lock the queen from
escaping you win the queen for some
material and now Hikaru who is down to
one minute 15 seconds he needs to
evaluate this correctly Dania because he
doesn't have that much time I know how
good he is and how quick he is but he
does need to be a bit careful and he
hasn't been in time pressure for like
four games really since the beginning of
the match so this might be magnus's best
Hope just keep things as confusing as
possible and hope that Hikaru panics and
time pressure but Panic has not been in
his vocabulary whether he's had three
minutes or 0.3 seconds
no but Knight D5 feels like the most
obvious move it's just not the best move
and that would get Magnus a chance back
in the game so I feel like here Hikaru
if he finds B3 that just shows The
Sensational forms it but he plays Knight
D5 I anticipate this would happen and
Dania now I really feel like Magnus the
chance of this game is Alaska station
for the queen named after Emmanuel
Alaska or the early world champion black
has a lot of stuff and after the bishop
moves back to f8 he's got sustained
pressure on the E4 Pawn don't move the
Knight away from D4 because then the
bishop is gonna Park itself on C6 he
cars got to be very careful he has to be
precise he's still better Robert but
this is encouraging for Magnus and he is
going to put his Bishop on C6 and maybe
and I think it should the apish by five
I was gonna say practically speaking
soon black may be better it just you
have more material the point value may
be the same but you have a bishop a
light Square Bishop a rook and a pawn
for one Queen and you're just staring at
this E4 one he plays Bishop d a good
idea by you played by Magnus Bishop man
live give me the Knight on C3 give me
the pawn E4 look at a car's clock and
the car says give me the Knight on F6 I
have to relieve the pressure but look at
that Mega Rook on E5 he cars just says I
don't care about anything I've got a
queen and I've got all of these weak
pods to capture I still think he car is
going to win this game
wow big move there by a car
understanding to take the Knight take
the pawn get all those pawns off the
board in the king side and let's see
Magnus with a minute and 20 plus he is
up a full minute on the clock what moves
does he have Queen takes F6 is the
obvious threat that H4 H5 H6 H7 and
finally h8 the pawn is just going to run
up the board and make a new Queen and
he's gonna run up the lead to five with
a victory in this game I think magnus's
only chance might be to use his Rooks
and actually try to Checkmate the king
in the corner try to put one Rook on B6
the other Rook on A5 it's slow it's
cumbersome I think he's trying to do
something like that but it's going off
the rail see cars just keeps munching on
Pawns
yeah though right now the Rooks are
defended The Bishop's defended if Queen
takes F7 I think his Bishop takes F5 is
his idea and the white king will be
victim to a lot of checks so that's the
one bit of good news Bishop G6 he
blundered and maxed it Magnus to play
too quickly Bishop G6 was a discovered
attack on The Rook honey one and the
Queen on F7 was hit as well
unbelievable blunder Magnus is not even
thinking about it because he's just he's
so used to losing games I think inertia
just carried him forward Bishop G6 a
discovered attack and you couldn't take
the bishop not because he lost the Rook
because you got made it after that
and listen a good practical call by
Hikaru no need to do anything crazy the
only winning move there was Queen C7 to
E7 but how hard is that to see with two
seconds
oh it's counterintuitive you want to
push your past Pawn or do something to
Shield your king but the point is the
king gets to run away here the C2 square
is covered and I mean I think we should
throw the show that Bishop G6 moment yes
we should Magnus had plenty of time on
his clock he was playing for hikaru's
time travel it was a purely Bliss
decision and a car would have made his
blunder if he had more time on his clock
but he did fall into this now there's
several big points the queen is under
attack The Rook on E1 is loose you can't
take on E5 with the Rook hoping okay you
know the queen is off and it gets your
Rook there's this check in between so
that's a very big check I might add
because if it is instead of Bishop said
you take on D5 and then White's pawns
run H4 and G4 and H5 you push the h-bomb
here white actually wins the game on the
spot so you know one could say maybe
Magnus saw this and mysteric D1 I don't
think so because he spent about a second
on his move but Bishop G6 would have won
the game and turned the well I wouldn't
say turn the match around it would have
still been a three-point game but a huge
miss my Magnus and this segment Robert
this segment it could not have ended
soon enough for the world champion
he is down by four points I repeat
Magnus Carlson Trails akaro Nakamura by
four points that is surprising a
surprising gets you don't expect to see
world champion down let alone by four
points to anybody but that is where we
sit Magnus has never been down by this
much to anybody in any speed test
Champion match so while we're here
hundred and fifty thousand yearly people
watching right now I just want to shout
out you all and well it's time to make a
you know kind of special announcement
because if you have a special somebody
in your life a chess player who would
love a premium membership on chess.com
if you have a holiday party tonight but
totally forgot to buy a present this
holiday season share the beauty of chess
with your loved ones purchase a premium
membership now and ship it off to its
recipient anytime whether it's tonight
next week or next month don't get into a
last minute time scribble for this
year's greatest gift drop the command
gift in the chat for all the details
we'll be right back for more from the
speeches Championship final this is
Hikaru Nakamura versus Magus Carlson
foreign
[Music]
ER Danny wrench Chief chess officer back
again with more chess terms here for you
today we're going to talk about the past
Pawn the past Pawn must be pushed you
hear it said often and that's because
just about every end game you see that
isn't a blowout often comes down to
maybe someone's up one Pawn or maybe
even just the first person to create a
past Pawn is the person who goes on to
win that game we're going to talk about
what the past Pawn is and to find it for
you in today's video let's do it what is
a past Pawn a past Pawn is a pawn that
has no enemy pawns stopping it from
moving forward that means pawns either
on the file in which it resides or on
the adjacent files that would therefore
capture the pawn should in advance so if
a pawn has none of those things stopping
its way then it's time to push them baby
as our boy Yasser would say it as you
hear mentioned on many broadcasts that
you would watch on chess TV and on that
note as we look at our game examples we
like to do this is taken from Thomas
chefsky versus rajaba here white plays
the move V5 X Clan which highlights
again it's not how many pawns you have
but who's going to be threatening to get
a queen first after black takes it white
pushes forward with gusto and because
the Rook can't blockade the pawn due to
the light Square Bishop this game is
already over black is going to have to
sacrifice the bishop for the pawn on B6
and white would simply be up a minor
piece note that after the first move B5
should a takes B5 have been played white
would have pushed this pawn and then
trap The Rook on A7 showing the power of
the pass Pawn as with it protecting the
bishop this Rook is completely out of
the game and white would easily go on to
win picking up pawns and just flexing
the rook's muscles over the bishop for
the rest of the game so here we see a
passport being used as a weapon to just
cramp down and trap all of your enemy
pieces so this has been another chest
rooms video hope you enjoyed it hope
you're enjoying all of them and with
that I will sign off hoping that you
learned something about what a pass Pawn
is and we'll see you around on chess.com
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
is brewing we see a statement
performance from Magnus Carlsen hey
Nakamura is surviving
93 Queen Knight H3 what a tactic holy
smokes my brain is exploding
he missed it and now it's a draw the
moves will be fast
starting to see Bishop C7
oh my God where's the mate though I
don't know but it's gotta be there oh my
God
the stakes will be high
the 2022 speed Chess Championship is now
fasten your speed belts my friends we're
in for a wild ride
when you don't lose you don't tilt
that's what Magnus Carlson said when he
defeated five minute carwana an unbeaten
match for Magnus but right now he is
getting beat down by Hikaru Nakamura
Nakamura currently leads his match by
Four Points Donya it is shocking I'm
still processing what we just saw in the
five minute segment I will be processing
it for a long time but Magnus Carlson
he's got to process it real fast because
he's got 60 Minutes in arguably hikaru's
most comfortable time control he's
staring down the barrel of I said
two-point deficit when we were going to
the halftime break it's now ballooned to
a four point deficit and Hikaru he draws
the Threshold at three points Hikaru
said in a previous interview that once
an SCC match gets past three points
you're kind of in blowout territory so
Magnus he's got to strike early and he's
got to strike fast and he's got to
strike often and if there's any player
who can't do it it is the number one
rated player in the world Magnus Carlsen
the 32 year old from Norway with the
highest Blitz rating on site at least
before this match began he won the speed
Chess Championship in 2016 and 2017. he
defeated Maxine vashir lagrub he
destroyed Fabiano caruana he also opened
with a nice match over gukash and his
strength Donya is everything but today
his Kryptonite is ikar Nakamura and
speaking of strength being everything
Hikaru he has shown skill after skill
doesn't matter what kind of position
he's gotten he's under pressure
resilient he has a tactical position
sharpness and calculation great time
management I mean this is what you need
to do to defeat a a goat like Magnus
Carlson and hikar Nakamura has done all
of it but it's a clean slate Robert it's
a clean slate there's an hour on the
clock and as we look at magnus's speed
chess resume I mean mouth-watering stats
and the resume me I'm a champion
he is a champion he actually was rooting
for France to become World Cup champion
that did not happen he doesn't want to
suffer a second disappointment of the
day but Magnus Carlson he is a beast at
bullet so even if the blitz doesn't
fully go his way he can make up ground
in the book one of the only players on
the planet who can do that against akara
Nakamura but Hikaru is just locked in he
has yet to lose a game to Magnus Carlson
in the year 2022. this year's almost
over if somehow doesn't lose in the SEC
match and it does play him in the world
wrapping in Blitz that's it he will go a
full gear without losing to Magnus
Carlsen despite playing many games that
would be the biggest accomplishment
perhaps of his entire career and let's
see what changes back as Carlson is
going to make both in terms of his
opening play and in terms of his match
strategy there's a change a2a3 on move
three taking a page out of hikaru's book
a little bit isn't he
I thought you would say there's a change
because magnus's undershirt is gone oh
God uh his attire has changed he's you
know nothing going right for him thus
far he's just you know I'm reading the
featured chat what do you want that's
beyond no it's beyond my intellectual
paper I was gonna compliment you give me
a chance I was gonna say that is you
know beyond the kind of humor that I'm
capable of you know me I'm nervous I'm
always worried that you're gonna I'm not
swinging at me just like a car who's
coming swinging at Magnus Carlson but
right now done it with this early A3 we
have a pawn structure that is not
symmetrical white with these double G
pawns a semi-open h far that's good for
an attack so if black Castle's King said
right now watch out so first the car
plays H6 he says what are you gonna do
with your king if you commit your king
to the king side I will very much do the
same so Hikaru is playing a little bit
of a waiting game yeah and of course you
can't Castle queenside anymore you've
already moved the rookie does Castle
King side and Magnus saying yeah I've
got some visual damage on the king side
but that pot on G3 could also
potentially serve as an anchor point for
a knight that jumps into H4 you see this
move sometimes we have a trade on e4 and
isikaru contemplating D takes E4 to push
the Knight off of F3
pretty risky decision because you don't
want to get caught with isolated pawns
or double pawns I should say in this
position but he goes forward and now a
big choice for Magnus to drop his Knight
to D2 so C5 Knight C4 Knight D6 for
white but as you're indicating black is
fighting for that very same Pawn push it
try to Chisel at White's Pawn on D4 and
there is a second Pawn push E6 E5 which
has the benefit of undoubling Black's
pawns but you're absolutely right Hikaru
doesn't mind these double pawns both of
them are serving a purpose the E6 Pawn
is protecting the bishop which is
protecting E4 this is like one defensive
unit and Magnus is driving his Queen up
to B3 forcing a little weakness and
making space for his Rook to enter the
party and here might come Knight B1
Knight C3 improving the night or he goes
Queens either he wants B4 perhaps white
is essentially up a pawn in many ways
because black has these doubled e-pawns
so let's slice the board in half you
know I love to do that if we look at the
a through the D file white has four
pawns black only has three so if you can
force that pawn off a C5 down yet like
that's a c takes B4 a ticks before we
have a pass Pawn ready to roll hey Cara
is gonna keep this Pawn on C5 as long as
it is humanly possible to do so one idea
that you can't fall asleep on right the
bishop on E2 right now is serving a very
important purpose it's preventing the
knight from jumping out to G4 otherwise
I could play Knight G4 and then Queen G5
H5 and before you know it you actually
could end up paying the price for that
open H file Magnus keeping as you said
chiseling away at black spawns and
creating for himself a mega pass pawn
and a big Square on T4 for his Knight
yeah and he essentially is up a pawn
look at the position that one Pawn on E3
covers two of Black's pawns on e4 and E6
and that Bishop 105 doing nothing you
have to play E6 to E5 just to get your
Bishop back from the game and stop the
pass Pawn but white may play Queen A5
next move just to trade Queens then play
C6 and just try to get that pawn as far
up the board as possible this is a very
nasty position for Hikaru and for a
change he is the one down a minute on
the clock and Robert it's hard to
overstate what a first game win in this
segment will do for magnus's confidence
and his Verve
yes and you see it got grimacing he's
like this position is really bad and the
worst part for him we know how good he
is at defense it's there's like no
defense here it's like you see what's
coming it's gonna happen and there's
nothing active that black can do say
Karu is down to 45 seconds he's in big
time trouble in his position just stinks
trying to drum up some counter play
Magnus saying no such luck I'm not
engaging at all maybe Rook D1 can be
tried but the problem is that even if
the Rooks are off the board that might
actually help white because the Knight
is more than capable of seeing the pawn
through to promotion Hikaru has to keep
the pieces on the board and he does and
queen A5 here is still possible
he goes Queen A4 doesn't want to trade
the Queens just yet because the Queens
are terrible blockading pieces yeah
Knight C5 Knight A6 is the threat Knight
C5 now drops the pawn on C6 so you can't
get away with that so I think maybe
bring the Knight back to D2 and go to
the E4 Pawn but maybe C6 was a little
bit Hasty it was such a tempting move
but Hikaru is pretty close to going
bishop e65 and we know what he's capable
of in these types of positions I'm more
worried about his clock the combination
of the past pawn and the 20 seconds on
his clock if Magnus doesn't win this
Robert if Magnus doesn't win this I
think Rook C5 that way your opponent C6
is defended you stop Knight D5 you can
win Knight C4 next I think it's a really
strong move and that way your pass Pawn
is safe and sound you can also play
Queen A5 to immobilize black strokes but
whatever you do don't start with Knight
C4 and blunder the pawn on C6
and look at how much time Magnus has
he's just playing much quicker now
Knight G4 for black if you can get your
queen over to H5 you'll deliver a
Checkmate the problem is the queen on C7
is doing an important job it's
blockading the past Pawn what are you
talking about Robert just Queen C7 H5
it's not that complicated
uh it looks a little complicated E5 is
in trouble Hikaru in trouble in the
clock and he's made both of our moves
Queen A5 and then Rook C5 but he needs
that final push that final push to get
the Queen off of C7 and get the pawn
through
yes so G6 played here what's happening
can I mean Rook C5 you can take E5 but
C6 Pawn then gets in trouble yeah Magnus
taking his time he's now below a minute
and we know what step one is for Hikaru
get Magnus under 30 seconds and no such
luck he's playing so confidently as he
massages Black's weaknesses But Here
Comes hikaru's work it's not over yet it
isn't because Queen E5 you swap because
rookie five trait of Queens there's Rook
C1 at the end now oh C7 Queen D1 okay
well we'll Rook F1 and queen D1 is
almost made there is Queen E1 though I
think you can just push
I love that move love the move Rook B5
oh the only move to win apparently
according to the engine
and hikar is going to lose some time and
the reason why Rook B5 was so good is
that Rook on B1 had no moves on that
last rank so you had to trade The Rook
was actually trapped in place Magnus
Carlson strikes back he wins the first
game of three plus one that is huge for
his chances that is just what the doctor
ordered I'll just contribute to what you
just said by mentioning that when The
Rook moved away from E5 the Knight on F6
became pinned you couldn't use it for
counter play
and black was out of resources and very
interesting development here they are
repeating the opening from game one of
the match who is going to deviate first
or is he Carter just saying hey I'm more
than happy with the draw
kind of a interesting decision I think
wow
maybe not look at this one look at that
black was the one pushing here wasn't he
car must have looked at it right he must
have looked at it but is this really
what he wants to do to get a position
where it you know Magnus seems to be the
one drawing from a position of strength
I guess Hikaru has looked at it to the
point where he feels super confident
that he can deprive lack of any
remaining chances
Bishop C2 that allowed Knight D4 check
but King G3 was there and that's when
Magnus played G5 but Bishop takes H7 was
a possibility and it is again
it's just a blunder
92 check I guess is his point but then
you go King F3 and White's better in
that ending because at the end of the
line Robert You're Gonna Go Rook D6 and
hit the pawn
Magnus looks puzzled what's he doing
I don't really know because when you
play something you expect your opponent
to look at it so I think Magnus could
have spent a little bit more time before
venturing into the same exact variation
now it's only one pawn and I say only
not because it's not a big deal but
because in many Rook end games being
just one pawned out still gives great
chances to draw so I do think that this
game is much closer to equal than any
sort of advantage for white I just am a
bit confused by this whole uh repetition
of the game and this was unnecessary
right you didn't have to do this to
yourself and now Magnus is on the
defensive but uh handily drawing with
that Knight being as active as it is we
should point out Robert to those just
joining first of all welcome to the
party we're glad you're here but the
reason they played this quickly is
because they had the exact same opening
up to move 24 in game one of the match
so as impressive as it looks they're
following a well-trodden path a path
that they themselves had laid out before
that's right Bishop goes back to D3 and
Knight to F3 will win the pawn in H2 but
white will then slide the king up to G2
that's very important you don't want to
get checkmated in the corner because
Knight F3 actually threatens Checkmate
in one an Arabian mate
is not going to be on the menu in this
game Knight F3 King G2 and if you
greedily capture H2 I can play F3
locking the Knight and now the Knight is
checkmated on H2
that would not be good at all so Magnus
thinking he can play Pawn to C5 just to
protect the Knight on D4 but that does
loosen your control of the B5 Pawn I
like C5 but I think white should respond
with B3 and that way uh you know not
line the pawn to keep pushing and
perhaps I can play B4 to beat Black to
the punch of course the pawn on B4 then
becomes itself a liability so game is
kind of hanging in the balance you know
the magnets that we're used to Robert
has no problem drawing these kinds of
positions I think he will have no
problem holding but something makes me a
little bit nervous
yeah it's the fact that you know he
repeated line Bishop takes H7 happen
he's playing relatively quickly uh his
King goes to F6 look at the car this is
the type of game that he wins against
most anybody but the problem is you know
Magnus Carlson isn't just anybody he is
the best player on the planet he plays
C5 tonight he's defended so Diane let me
ask you are there any winning chances
for either side here you know at first I
was going to say yes and I'm influenced
by the course of this match
I look at the night on D4 a little bit
more carefully and you know the Soviet
GM inside of me would say was such an
enlightened before you cannot lose it
it's crime to lose this night like this
on D4 so perhaps I can play B4 and lock
up the Queens on the queen pawns
entirely of course the drawback of that
move is that your own Pawn chain loses
its Mobility so Magnus keeping his
options open and preparing to swing his
Rook to A8
which might win a pawn if you're not
careful and the one Pawn on G5 takes
care of both of White's pawns on the F
and H far that's the problem with having
split pawns isolated pawns are not ideal
and if Rook a I guess Bishop B1 is
hikaru's plan a very passive defense oh
it's a defense against the job done now
wait a minute hello the pawn appears on
C4 that's the first pass Pawn of the
game and White's gonna get a
corresponding passer on A2 Robert not
the greatest pass Pawn in the history of
past pawns if White's not careful I
could actually see Magnus making a
sudden push to play for the win am I
delusional here you're not delusional
but I do think there are ways to force
to draw for example even if it costs
white a bishop as long as you trade off
the remaining black pawns it would still
be a draw so I think you could take it
but his rookie four as I say Rook C3 Oh
what now is he gonna try to trade the
punts preemptively so that you can then
give the bishop up for C2 and listen a
knight and Rook versus Rook it's not a
given that you draw it with five seconds
on your clock so can Magnus milky car
was clock down I think that'll be his
only chance to turn this game around and
actually win it
so should you go Rook C8 here just try
to push that on
rugby eight I guess he could go back to
E4 or even counter-attacking the Knight
yeah that's just equal so this Rook E4
idea is frustrating for black to deal
with
and you can't play C3
there are no Forks the king is very well
placed on G2 it's out of the checking
zone of the Black Knight Rook C8 your
call
it's on Knight B5 there might be Rook F3
check and then A4 but now Rook F3 is
Knight F4 check so you just block the
check with another check and then push
the pawn but now can you check and play
C3 you got to be careful not to lose
that pawn because white skin can
suddenly make a Mad Dash toward the
queen side black is definitely better
here this is uncomfortable to play with
47 seconds yeah and Hikaru trying to
whip up some counter play with his own
Pastor distracting black from the C8
square but the king can move into D4 oh
and then there's H4 undermining the
Knight watch out for that tactic
although C3 so tempting right here then
bring the Knight back around he was
watching it for anyone that's a fort
Hikaru avoided that with a 10-foot boy
he's like I'm moving out of there
but King 65 is not a threat because Rook
G8 check the King has to go to the side
of the board that seems uncomfortable
Magnus recognizes it rookie two check
opens up an attack of the night but the
king slides into D4 Here Comes sikaru's
Pawn we've got a good old-school Pawn
race
finally King takes G5 looks uh good for
white you probably have to take that
some point but Magnus by the way down to
18 seconds yeah this is a three result
game I know it sounds crazy but ikaro is
known to create crazy chants in these
positions there's a case in point rookie
four is the threat you gotta move the
Knight and he does King G5 96 F3 is
checking the Knight goes to D2 uh oh
intercepting the rook and stopping
rookie four check still a drop of the
cars got to be careful A5 is falling
maybe throwing for Basics first but he
takes the other Pawn Yeah it's crazy I
think Magnus has to be careful here that
pawn moves really fast and C3 is
restrained by the bishop so rookie Rook
everyone check first and he wants Rook
H1 at some point but he's just making a
draw here I think it's time to make a
draw with nine seconds on the clock no
need for Magnus to do anything crazy
no and he won uh the first game of the
time control so he draws the second with
black repeating A variation from earlier
this bishop takes H7 Pawn didn't amount
to anything but I'm still surprised to
see them repeat the opening but that was
a good result for Magnus Carlson and
tentatively a good start to the
three-minute segment he wins the first
game with white he draws from a position
of strength with black and the lead
hasn't reached the kind of proportions
where you need to go crazy in every game
I think he's realized that he's departed
from you know King's Indian and E4 C5
he's doing what makes him comfortable
and I think that's magnus's path to
coming back in this match
for sure he doesn't need to take huge
risks at this point so much time is left
in the match let's remind everybody
there are 45 minutes you see the top
left of your screen remaining in the
three minute plus one second increment
time portion after that we get 30
minutes of bullet chess so many games
remain in this match Magnus does not
have to just throw everything at a card
just yet absolutely not but he might
have to throw something at Hikaru
they've had this Pawn structure before
that game ended up in a very heated draw
is there anything for white here or is
it a purely symbolic Advantage the email
bar seems to claim that white has a
little something something maybe due to
his control over the e-file don't play
Knight C7 here Bishop takes Knight Queen
takes Queen E8 would be check and made
so watch out for your last Rank and it
would be a logical move try to get the
Knight around to E6 Knight T6 is a
better move because now if you do the
same thing it merely leads to a queen
trade you can pick up E8 and then block
on f8 Magnus poking and prodding and
shuffling and chiseling and he's trying
his best has to milk a little Advantage
out of this position
okay don't play F3 because there's
Bishop H4 something to to note so he
just trades light Square Bishops to take
the E file now this actually is a
nagging Advantage for white if black is
not careful because king of Fate you
would like to play rookie eight after
with his Bishop D6 check on some of
these positions you just have to be
careful here and he does play King of f8
so he sort of fakes Magnus that rookie
it could still happen Bishop D6
amazingly there's Bishop E7 Robert I'm
not actually sure that that's that bad
for black
yeah good point that you just are trying
to trade off these pieces there and
everything is protected for Hikaru and
I'm looking at the ratings a car with
32-17 Magnus 32-13 there are four rating
points apart they will jockey for
position on the blitz leaderboard so I
think the big question here if we pull
up an announce board we won't do that a
lot we promise in the three-minute
segment but real fast G3 rookie 8 Bishop
D6 check Bishop E7
the question actually is is the pawn end
game totally lifeless probably the
answer is yes but these Pawn end games
can be deceptive I was also thinking
about a move like Bishop E5 here but
black just pushes the bishop away and
then moves his Bishop back to d8 and if
you go back to D6 there's just kick F7
Robert so I feel like this is Hope Chest
I think rookie eight is is Unstoppable
and and the advantage is going to
evaporate just good recognition from
mikaru Nakamura Bishop D6 check may look
scary at first glance but it leads to
nothing so we're gonna get a pawn End
Game King upon the game that is and
there should be no Advantage for white
there and something a car does very well
Dania is waste match clock so G3 was
played by the way that if there is a
draw he'll play it out for the full 50
moves he's not just gonna go ahead and
draw
and they're playing this line out now
Bishop B5 F6
of course if white wants to draw you
trade everything on E7 but you're
absolutely right Hikaru is good at
forcing that clock down he's also good
at getting time advantages and Magnus
can't just let his clock get down to 10
seconds because anything can happen in
that situation against cicaro that's
right and I'm wondering why there's even
any advantage on the evaluation bar for
yeah
if you swap everything on E7 the only
difference is that weighs upon G3 and
Black's King is a little bit more active
so why would white be better that's
the question of the answer to and Bishop
F4 played Bishop F6 you might just see a
draw and Hikaru just adhering to his
strategies up by three he could try to
play that position I think against
anybody else he would make a move like
F6 but you respects Magnus and he knows
that as long as he holds his own with
black and puts pressure with white he'll
be good decision time for Hikaru
and I think I saw Magnus screen change
for a second so I feel like he looked at
the camera and he saw his car leaning
back because the car is going to waste
time right now oh he's gonna wait for
two minutes I forgot yeah he's gonna
play Bishop F6 after using all of the
time on his clock
yeah he's just gonna
sit around sip his whatever's in that
Stein of his
and this is gonna double as a rest time
for Hikaru you can just see him totally
relaxed there looking up at the heavens
Beth Harmon style and waiting for that
clock to tick down
you know how in baseball when you're
going to walk a better you can just say
I'm going to walk them so you have to
throw four pitches right all right watch
baseball but yes it's a waste of time so
my point is I feel like we should
Implement like a oh if it's gonna be a
resignation or it's gonna be a
three-time repetition you just allow the
players to tell you that you just take
it off the match clock because uh the
players they do get a little bit of rest
that's the good news for them but I
think it's hard to sit and just do
nothing as Hikaru is going to make the
draw but we're just waiting for his
clock to hit one second left what do you
think the stoppage time is going to be
when this match hits 90 but no just
kidding no stoppage time in chess well
Hikaru has stopped the match as he waits
you can let 48 seconds evaporate and
then call the time out end the game with
Bishop F6 he has measured it he knows
it's a three-time repetition and the
game ends automatically fun fact Robert
you'll co-sign me on this over the board
there's actually a very strict procedure
for claiming three-time repetition you
actually cannot make the move itself you
have to stop the clock call over the
Arbiter the tournament director the
person who makes the results official
and you have to show him the actual
repetition on your scoresheet a lot of
people don't realize this and they
actually miss an opportunity to claim a
draw because of the improper procedure
yeah but uh
unless preoccupied with procedure here
the draw is my repetition the card 12
and a half seconds on his clock so he
didn't go all the way down but he did
burn some important time potentially
because if Magnus can't score some
victories and you know then he starts
cutting to lead in bullet he needs all
the time that he can get yeah no this is
totally valid totally totally valid
match strategy and a little change as
Magnus tries to keep more life on the
board he doesn't just want another one
of those draws he plays the old school
Briar system
yeah this like zaitsev Briar uh he's
keeping everything defended uh for black
but at the same time you're quite
passive so white strikes on the queen
side with A4 and now you can be very
careful if you're Magnus the B5 pawn it
sticks out like a sore thumb it can get
in trouble if white piles up pressure on
it but he brings his Knight to B6 he's
challenging the A4 Pawn but B3 would
restrict the Knight The Briar system
named after duela Breyer Hungarian
player from the 1920s one of the hyper
modernists alongside rehard ready and
nimsovich and others who modernized
openings and played a lot of stuff that
we still play to this day and I think
modern computers don't particularly like
the Briar but it is a relatively fresh
position and one that Hikaru might not
have looked at in a while that's at
least what magnus's thinking goes
and that's smart that's how you prepare
at the highest level because all players
are well versed in a variety of openings
you need to catch your opponent off
guard and lastly Bishop D3 may have
caught Magnus a little bit off guard
because he's sitting and thinking his
idea behind the move A6 to A5 was put
his Bishop on A6 and start taking over
light squares on the Queen's side so the
bishop comes to D3 to stop that plan in
comes the car's Bishop to B5 I don't
really like the look of the move C7 C6 I
know you block the bishop and attack it
but your Bishop B7 will look silly oh
and neither does Magnus but neither does
the eval bar like the look of Rook to E6
this invites D5 Robert and D5 opens up a
pathway for the dark squared Bishop
isn't D5 just good for white what am I
missing
it is all right we see the evaluation
bar go up but I feel like if you're not
precise this is a position that gives
black some chances to strike back
because you've closed the center and
maybe at some point you can try to play
on the king side the issue is you're
never getting F7 to F5 and even if you
move your knight because look at the
pawn on e4 and the Knight on G3 why is
this ready to meet that pawn break yeah
Bishop to G5 inducing F6 now drop the
bishop back to E3 he goes Bishop F6 but
still you now can no longer play the
move F5
wouldn't be surprised if the card was H4
he plays Bishop E3 instead I thought he
might just try to keep his Bishop in
place but the Knight comes up to C5 take
me please says Magnus give me the bishop
pair and maybe it's I was gonna say time
for Bishop G5 but I forgot the Rook is
awkwardly placed on E7
I don't like this I don't like this one
bit this is actually a position very
reminiscent of a king's Indian structure
on both sides of the board and normally
when you get a knight in sconce on C5
like this black freezes White's pressure
But Here Comes the Knight around to B3
it goes and once white goes C5 that's
like stepping on something with your
shoe bang Crunch and Black's Queen side
can collapse real fast
it's looking bad for Magnus Carlson
right now he would like to connect his
Knight but as you're pointing out the
Knight is going to B3 anyway
there's just no pressure in the position
black has nothing here nope
and I'll tell you what black has a one
minute deficit on the clock
not good King G7 is a very magnus-like
move but he has to already watch out for
Bishop takes C5 and Knight B3 that you
might just lose a pawn in positions like
that a knight B3 by itself is looking
strong and you see ikari keeps raising
his eyebrows like what is going on in
this match something about magnus's play
seems very off and that decision to play
rookie six I know I have the benefit of
the eval bar I get that but you know put
that aside very uncharacteristic
misjudgments intuitive misjudgments
errors and calculation and the problem
when you're down by three is that you
lose all of your momentum if ikar wins
this wins this game it's as if nothing
ever happens is it as if Magnus never
won that first game
it's true
Bishop G5 F6 location takes F6 you don't
have Rook F7 so he trades but what's the
idea here he sacks oh he sacks the pawn
to keep the Knight alive on C5 that I
actually really like from the world this
is positional Brilliance because yes it
gives up material to keep the knights on
the dark squares and if you can play
Bishop A6 or Bishop D7 and trade off
that light Square Bishop A4 C4 and E4
and D3 and B3 all these squares are
vulnerable to Black's Knights you're
absolutely right and this is the magnets
that we're used to he's shown Signs of
Life in the three minute portion but can
he finish this defensive effort he's
still worse right no question about that
hicaro very much still playing for the
win and he Karma might try to trade
places maybe go Bishop C6 and Knight B5
he trades and will go Knight B5 I assume
no he puts his Rook on the open file
and the good news for a car is he has
all of those pawns protected now he's
got a beautiful Pawn chain Connect Four
and then other Knight comes to C5 for
Max I wouldn't be surprised if there's a
G5 H5 G4 at some moment just to get some
kind of play on the king side you're
down a pond there but you can open up
lines for your Rooks and white has all
the open lines he needs he has exactly
one open line and he might put a second
Rook there and try to infiltrate B8 I
don't know who exactly benefits in the
event of a rook trade what if both Rooks
are off the board is that Knight end
game drawn questions that Magnus just
doesn't quite have the time to answer
but if I was thinking here because he
was Knight E2 and I guess if there's
ever G5 he has Knight G3 to F5 so you
need to be careful before you push any
pawn because the square that was
previously under your control gets weak
and maybe Magnus just wants to lock up
the king side with H4 and G5 no he does
go G5 he allows Knight G3 and I think he
carries gonna play it there might be an
exchange sack I was wondering if he was
gonna play H4 and second exchange and
bring his King up
he's going for an attack he wants to
Checkmate the white King on G1
eventually
and he plays G4 the point is you take
twice E4 is hanging with check so you
cannot keep capturing on G4 the lines
are opening up and that's good news for
blacks Rooks and potentially bad news
for the white king and even better news
for Magnus the clock situation beginning
to equal I see cargo forced to calculate
and this has been phenomenal defense
thus far by Magnus Carlsen but can he
keep it up rook to AJ preparing to
occupy the open file he's created for
himself he's got the most counter play
he's had in a while and there's Knight
D3 check if you're not looking out if
you're Hikaru there could be a knight D3
to F4 so if it's Rook D1 he hangs the A4
Pawn because he wants Rook A1 at the end
winning the A5 pawn and maybe Magnus
will just double on the G file that pawn
is a decoy it's a juicy Pawn indeed
watch out for Rook takes C5 and D6 I'm
wondering if there's an exchange sack
here oh just going for that night on F5
no hikara brings this road back to A1
Magnus find with a repetition
you wouldn't be fine with repetition why
not he has 16 seconds he's go Rook V8
down a pawn he goes for B8 I'm wondering
if Rook 65 will be played by akaru that
would be an incredible call and very
risky move but a potentially rewarding
move that night is a beast
but no a draw and a dodged Bullet by
Magnus
in a different game different match
perhaps a car would go for it but he
doesn't need to take a risk he's up
three points it's about eight to five
but Magnus Carlson gets the white pieces
and we have another Catalan another
Catalan another A4 system and I think
that was a really big result Robert even
though it wasn't a win that was one of
the biggest games of the match Agnes
loses that one like I said it's back to
a four point lead I think he's played a
couple confidence boosting games thus
far but can he make the most of the
white pieces
that defense was unbelievable right he
just gives up the F Pawn and then makes
it look easy from there so a great job
for Magnus he's getting this position
again we keep seeing this opening played
and this time there's a knight on B4 and
the dark Square Bishop remains for white
it does indeed and have we had a slight
deviation from the five plus one I feel
like they haven't had this exact
position they've had this exact
structure The Rook usually comes to d8
we know the drill by now don't we
yeah the bishop on F4 is gone for that
night on B4 so it is a different
position more pieces remain and that
should be good news for white because
black is a big cramp
and H4 by Magnus using tactics to defend
the pawn
the bishop will drop back to E3 pinning
The Rook to the queen
and queen A6 so if you trade Queens the
Knight goes back and look at this Knight
C4 Bishop C7 you might just win a pawn
not quite yet though the Knight
defending that square but at the moment
it moves you are leaning into C7 all
right I got you I gotcha I gotcha piece
there yeah but you know it's my rules of
commentary you always have to be willing
to be incorrect I blundered a piece it
happens but no Bishop C7 would be great
except for the oh no way oh my gosh
oh my gosh
kidding me I think I should apologize to
Magnus is this a dream
if it is a car never wants to wake up
did you just do what I thought you just
did
that is the ultimate commentator's curse
I don't think I have ever seen a call
like this I think I should retire I
think Magnus probably prefers that
I think you should
republish the new edition of
nostradamus's
prognostications or whatever his book is
called that was insane
oh my gosh
um well if anybody wants predictive
advice I'm GM Hess on chess.com so you
can find me there no but that was just
crazy I
when does Magnus blunder a piece like
that name a time that he's done that
and look at him I mean he just looks
just confused
upset he's not like that was a one move
blunder in a good position
there was a knight on A6 he played
Bishop F4 to C7
putting the bishop on pre we don't have
to show it again that's literally all
that happened he's still shaking his
head he's got to put it behind them
though right the good news 30 more
minutes this lead is what it was at the
start of the segment
so it's important for Magnus not to blow
this up
into greater proportion than it was but
oh my lands what a blunder
and I'm looking at Hikaru he remains
very focused because I think when your
opponent blunders yeah it's easy to
laugh okay that's not gonna happen again
but it's also easy to lose your focus
okay Karu he's still evaluating every
single turn that's played and this
position is one where I would say black
doesn't really have problems look at the
coordination of Black's pieces the
bishop on B7 is Stellar The Rook on d8
staring down the line towards many of
White's minor pieces so I actually like
magnus's position in this game and what
I would compare this to in a weird way
is the match with mvl the first couple
games of the three minute portion where
Maxime was in control every single game
and all four of the first games ended in
a dry he was not able to cut into the
lead and ultimately I think that was the
match deciding storyline we're seeing
something similar here when Magnus is
playing much better but he doesn't have
anything to show for it on the
scoreboard as of yet
no he does not and we see the queen go
out to E2 Rook goes to eight that's the
only open file you know the D file is
open no Pawns in its way but there are
minor pieces in the path so I still like
Black's position
um white has a long-term advantage and
what I mean by that is you have two on
one on the queen side that's good for a
pure end game but with many pieces on
the board it's often good at more Pawns
in the center because that restricts the
enemy pieces and gets you good control
of important squares this is essentially
a dream setup and Magnus inducing yet
another weakness F2 F3 then fine gold
cringing somewhere hopefully he's
watching the match where is the Knight
gonna go back to because you actually
have to be careful there are some Knight
takes these six tactics hanging in the
air
foreign that would be just an absolute
shot if you can get Knight takes E6 to
work and Knight C5 protects what B4 not
the question it's very loose right B4
Knight A4 even if it works out it's
scary to play it's hard to see all the
way through yukara making some progress
Knight to B5 Knight C40 E5 opens up a
line of contact between the queen and
the other Knight and it just feels like
your car was more comfortable in all
these positions
Magnus just seems discombobulated and so
do his minor pieces
yes there they are connected with one
another that's the good news is Rooks on
A8 that's an open file the push does
hurt White's dark Square so you can
count your blessings in that way but as
you're highlighting the queen is in the
Rooks path if it goes to D1 uh you can
get that open file The Rook A1 for black
maybe at some point is worthy of
consideration but also look out for
Knight takes F7 and then the E6 Pawn
collapsing and you can preface that with
B4 to knock the Knight out of C5 and
actually I think white is very close to
making that working car definitely going
to spend some time to calculate it but
if he doesn't want tactical
complications he can just play a calm
move like Rook D1 and keep the tension
yeah Rook D1 is viable here B4 looks
very strong I don't I actually don't it
does what Black's response is after B4
because Knight takes F7 while my queen
takes E6 and there is B4 step one um you
see Hikaru looking off screen I actually
think I don't know for sure and I'll ask
our team I wonder if he has Magnus like
his camera there and he's trying to look
at magnus's reaction
which is a totally viable thing to do
because at this point he can still
double back he doesn't have to play
Knight F7 and if he if he would see
Magnus huffing and puffing and shaking
his head I think that would increase the
likelihood of Knight takes F7 but let's
see Eddie Caro come on Knight F7 Queen
E6 Bishop C4 looks like a long-term
attack and two pawns for the piece I
think it's a practical decision
but he doesn't do it he was a little
indecisive when it came to that
sacrifice it was Bishop D2 just
protecting opponent C3 but now he
saddled with some long-term weaknesses
the C3 Pawn is attacked by two of the
Black Knights if you were pushed up to
C4 B4 Falls so I think that Magnus he
will remain alert to the F7 Capture wait
now takes takes the Knight D6 at the end
he just
I think I gotta stop talking
this is you're unbelievable
oh we did it again come on as always but
Hikaru he has to decide on it it's still
not that obvious after Knight D6 there's
Queen E7 it's messy but but look at a
car he's spotting the tactics Queen E7
play look wait a second was was 96 the
best move because I feel no
yeah once we got here the evaluation
went down and the reason why is if Queen
E7 the bishop takes back you take this
on B7 C3 Falls B4 Falls next and then
Knight is kind of Trapped stranded on B7
you called it earlier white is beginning
to pay the price for the move before the
positional price
and now Magnus actually keeping pieces
on the board what a move by Hikaru as he
squeezes his way into C6 and another
blow for Magnus I don't see him holding
this with 30 seconds yeah because my car
is taking this one Knight E7 there's
Bishop C4 threatening Checkmate on F7 oh
yeah you stopped one idea but you opened
a different avenue there and Magnus is
down on the clock you might have to just
don't take on C3 like I think he just
has don't you dare yeah I was gonna say
don't you dare call 97 Bishop C4
whatever you're saying seems to become
the truth where does the queen go though
everything's collapsing pieces are
hanging Queen A7 on the board take the
Knight okay Bishop takes C6 with a
knight on C3 if you take an eight Queen
you have everything covered Perpetual it
might be time for white to bail out you
could take on B6 I feel like ah but then
Queen D5
is Magnus the one going for it no he
can't go King G6 can he
wow and Magnus just you know throws his
hand up he makes a drug but that is
break time here in the three plus one
portion Donya I can't believe it I know
I suggested a blunder I owned it and
unfortunately Max did the same mistake
and now it's hikar who owns a four point
lead once again
he does indeed this could not have
gotten better for Hikaru Nakamura he's
wiped off 37 more minutes off the match
clock and if he can sustain this lead
going into the bullet I mean we've seen
absolutely everything the bullet is
going to be ridiculously Epic no matter
what hikaru's lead is going to be but
every second is golden right now every
game is an opportunity that Magnus has
to try to exploit yeah I think Magnus
needs to get one of these games down the
stretch of the three plus one portion he
needs to cut into this four-point lead
he can't allow his car to maintain this
confidence but Carter looks just as
confused as anybody he's looking left
he's looking right is this really Magnus
Carlsen making these mistakes it is so
Magnus Carlson your Mains of the world
champion until he gives up his title and
the match between John the Palm Street
and dingley Wren he'll need to find his
form but before he can the players are
on a break Daniel and I will do the same
and we're in return it's the finals hear
the speed test Championship zakara
Nakamura versus Magnus Carls
foreign
[Music]
just played an exciting game and want to
see if you got a brilliancy or maybe
where you could have improved
chess.com's game review is just a click
away
game review is a fast fun and
instructive guided review of your games
see your accuracy and your opponent's
accuracy check out the eval graph for an
instant overview and scroll down to see
how many great moves best moves blunders
and yes brilliancies you have played
learn from chess.com's coach who gives
move explanations opening statistics and
shows you the best lines of play
with retry mistakes you can get another
shot at finding missed opportunities
try game review today on web iOS or
Android
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
videos
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
to the speed Chess Championship final it
is Hikaru Nakamura with a four point
lead over Magnus Carlson it is shocking
but it is all Hikaru to this point and
hikar Nakamura the player is somebody
that the chess fans are very familiar
with Tanya he has had so many successes
to his name at 2022 May Vinnie his best
year of all
indeed and his dominance over online
Blitz really dates back to the early
2000s back with his Marathon sessions
against Alexander grishok and other
Grandmasters at the internet chess club
and as he's gotten older perhaps Hikaru
has lost a tiny bit of speed in time
scrambles but that's about it and he's
gained or composure he's more
well-rounded he's got more opening
experience he's got a lot of skills that
aren't talked about enough when a player
gets older and he keeps himself in good
physical form in good mental form as
hecaro undoubtedly does you acquire
other skills you acquire a certain
maturity and composure to your play that
has made Hikaru Nakamura an absolute
Beast in the last couple of years and I
think this is very meaningful to him
because beating Magnus Carlsen over the
course of several hours that is a big
accomplishment beating him one game the
car has done that plenty of times in his
career but beating him like this in a
match that has not happened because
Magnus Carlson has only lost one speed
chess championship match it was to
Maxine versus the grave and a car
Nakamura has only lost to one opponent
and that is Magnus Carlson so he has
revenge on the brain
we talk about the elements of greatness
what makes the goat the goat and one of
the qualities that all greats share
across all sports basketball football
chess is the ability to get up when
you're knocked down I mentioned this in
the pre-show Magnus hasn't been knocked
down at all in the SEC he's knocked
people down how is he going to react
when the hunter becomes The Hunted
it's a great question and well Hikaru
he's out there he is pouncing on his
opportunities and right now Magnus he
has the white pieces he needs to get
this one he plays A3 again and you see
Hikaru left
yep A3 and the actual point of the move
A3 is to discourage C7 C5 because there
I could have grabbed that pawn and
protected it with B4 but that ship has
sailed there once again repeating a very
similar line to the first time they had
this the queen comes out to B3 and
Magnus of course trying to provoke a
weakness on the on the queen side right
if you play the move B6 as the car just
did there's some light Square problems
in the long term White's Pawn structure
positioned very healthy it's not like
there's an advantage we just hope that
the right moment you take on D5 and try
to use the light squares to your
advantage I've been fine with magnus's
opening choice I think he's just trying
to aim for the positions that he feels
comfortable in but Hikaru is just so
solid he's he's so hard to break down in
these types of symmetrical positions
Magnus trying to whip something up on
the queen side he takes on D5 and what's
Hikaru going to recapture with your big
question and notice how Megan's waited
until the Rook went to see it because
now the bishop can go to A6 with Tempo
it's a shot against The Rook on c as
Magnus tries to gain control of the C
file so Bishop A6 there is Rook C7 uh
then you can even play Move Like Knight
B8 at some point just to get that Bishop
out of there and white we might see just
that you have to be careful about the
move B5 locking the bishop oh on A6 is
there a knight B5 Rook c75 that is sick
the bishop on F5 is loose as is The Rook
on eight and look at Magnus he's looking
at the board from the side and I think
he can't miss this he can't he has to
find the move and Knight takes D5 does
the same thing right
he plays Knight before it might have
even been better Knight takes D5 there
might have Bishop B6 and Magnus delivers
he had no right to miss that tactic this
is what he eats not for breakfast he he
eats harder tactics than this for
breakfast and a big missed by Hikaru how
lost is this Robert is this just a pawn
down and you're losing a second pawn and
your position is collapsing or is there
any hope for Hikaru uh in the ensuing
position it looks extremely lost you
have to take on C7 now right I don't see
another move and after Queen takes D5
loose pieces drop off lpdo says Donna
nerdinsky The Rook on eight is loose the
bishop on F5 excuse me is similarly
loose and so you lose a pawn the np5
drops and you're gonna lose this game so
it the break could not have come at a
better time for Magnus and well he's
trying to break his losing streak and
finally get a series of wins Bishop A6
was such a devilish move and Hikaru
blunders The Rook in the corner or does
he he's trying to trap the queen so
Bishop no he didn't plunder that okay
four is the idea
but what if I plays for instance D5 here
just to intercept the diagonal whoa
icaro what is he doing
I don't know you know he's always
looking off to the side and of course
they're the chess.com staff they're
looking at his screen they know
everything's good but I wonder if he is
looking at Magnus but either way he is
trying to trap Max's Queen in the corner
Bishop E4 there is that D5 move I'm
skeptical and yes we have the evil bar I
will admit that's coloring my
interpretation of this position it's a
creative idea by Nakamura no he did not
blunder The Rook he saw that it could be
captured but what he might have missed
is that after Bishop B4 T5 there is the
massive Unstoppable threat of 95 to C6
uh pinning the Knight on B8 and fully
extricating the queen with interest from
its perch in the corner Hikaru actually
is going to go King H7 to try to free up
the Knight but it's too late look at
Magnus forcing the exchanges
yes and within the lead in material uh
and deleting the clock it should be
Magnus Carlson's game and the reason why
Magnus is winning this game is he timed
the release of the tension well he went
c65 when he Bishop A6 with Tempo and
then he found the Tactical shot so uh
this was a really good game thus far by
Magnus if he doesn't win this game I
mean he just has nothing going his way
today
but it's not over from a practical
perspective that Bishop is still in
prison now it's not in danger of being
trapped black can't attack it but listen
the King on G1 is feeling the
heebie-jeebies just a little bit and
maybe it's worth
bringing the queen to G5 you can grab
another Pawn but I think White's got
enough of a material advantage already
magnus's priority right now should be to
repel the initiative black is kind of
threatening Bishop before maybe 94
Knight D2 ikaro is so good at creating
complications in these types of
positions and hold on I mean you are
right to our judgments are being colored
by the evaluation bar it's still heavily
in White's favor but it was Sky High and
now it's shrinking a little bit and
that's how Max Carlson you know that was
happening Hikari Nakamura that's how he
even wins games like this we saw him do
it against nielsarin
yeah we most certainly did he chips away
at the advantage he forces you to solve
problems he gets you low on time and
that is my biggest concern right now 50
seconds for Carlson he hasn't been up to
his usual level of sharpness let's see
if Hikaru can keep this complex
very complicated because the King on G1
doesn't have many Defenders around there
right Bishop E4 Queen G5 things of that
nature go after the white king the
bishop on A6 is imprisoned over there it
can't get back in the game very easily
and the rook and the queen are not
coordinated at least not optimally
Cara making a one move threat and then
another one the queen can drop back to
C1 for defensive purposes
if you slide The Rook up in cautiously
then the knight's gonna jump into E4 and
The Rook is suddenly trapped so that's
how easy it is to lose control of the
game if you're Magnus that would be
terrible and even that still should be
good for white I think because you could
take the bishop would take an F7 but why
get into a situation like that he slides
his roof to E1 and somehow his Rook is
Untouchable there the queen can't attack
a B4 was defended C3 was defended Icarus
no choice but to drop his Queen back but
he's listen he's keeping the tension and
the clocks were at a minute now they're
both at 30 seconds and this only favors
one player all right 94 this queen D4
that's the good news for Magnus he's
essentially forcing the Queens off the
board in short order so Queen D4 is a
massive threat right now and I think
it's going to be played and hikara might
be preparing Queen G5 slippery as an eel
he sacks on F3 the last attempt
okay King F1 there's always Queen C2
check Knight F5 Knight and the queen
very strong pair but this is obviously
lost queen C2 I would play he just makes
a Mad Dash for the center yeah the king
runs away and you can get a couple pawns
he didn't take an F3
it should be two okay so you can give
all your pawns as long as you have
checkmated
yeah and Hikaru has only two of them at
the moment Bishop D3 forces the Knight
off the board and ends the game your car
is not gonna resign though he's gonna
get every possible second off the match
clock right he should there's no reason
to resign if you're a car Nakamura you
should waste none the match clock
and it's not you know we've seen crazier
things happen I don't think Magnus is
giving this game away but with nine
seconds hey
it's chess nd5 is a great move yes
shattering Black's Pawn cover Magus
could take on F6 with the queen you
could take E6 that was a big moment
there because if he took an F6 Donya at
any point black would have two pawns
passers against a rook so and then it's
a three result game again this was
accurate play there by Magnus he trades
the Queens at the right moment he gets a
new one and well the car is going to
continue trying to waste a little bit
more time and he's gonna do it it's not
made just yet it's going to take a
couple more moves Ring Around the Rosie
and there it is made on the next move
well King Avenue still
Queen E2 is mate
okay and a win for Magnus another great
win Knight take Knight B5 he was
tactically alert and his technique was
Exquisite let's give Magnus some credit
for the way he converted that because a
car Nakamura is a tenacious Defender he
put up some resistance there but Magnus
he got that one and now he's playing one
of the cagey openings the modern the
Pierce he wants queen A5 to come but
Hikaru Nakamura isn't playing this since
he was a child this is a very dangerous
line from Black's perspective I hope
Magnus did his theoretical homework here
because this is as you said one of the
most dangerous theoretical lines in
chess and if Hikaru knows it you're
going to be in trouble I know there's a
forced to draw here there's some sort of
draw yes that's it and he car was going
for it and he's forgotten about it I
think yeah this was from Lev Albert's uh
perk alert that book from way back in
the day I had that book I played this
opening from black and the point is
Bishop F2 check King D2 Bishop E3 is a
force draw if you take the queen on d8
now white has the possibility of playing
Knight B5 hikar is not gonna dip his
toes into that toxic pool he's gonna
accept the draw a great result for
Magnus but he's not gonna accept it
again yes so hikaru's clocked in two
minutes and 30 seconds he's gonna take
it down all the way to a couple seconds
and then he's gonna play King D2 and
King he went back black has no choice
you've given up your queen and so you
have to play this forcing sequence of
Bishop E3 check and Bishop F2 check
and both players going to set back
Magnus with a bit of a smirk on his face
but at this point plenty of time there
will be 12 minutes left that's at least
two games probably three more games and
if Magnus can keep putting the kind of
pressure he's been able to do with the
white pieces Robert he could get this
lead down to two or maybe even one if he
continues to play well
look at Magnus I mean he's he's probably
just annoyed right now but there's a lot
of good news here for Magnus right when
when this is happening you can compose
yourself get ready to have the white
pieces he did just win a game so he
should be feeling better about his
chances and he actually did just smile
for the first time in hours
and maybe in days he didn't seem to be
in the best of spirits after his
previous match he expects Perfection
from himself he can't be happy with the
way he's playing but he's definitely
happy there's time left on the clock
making one more move and now he's gonna
wait again uh he's not waiting he's
thinking
he's contemplating choosing candidate
moves King D3 here is attempting what
that needs to be calculated wouldn't you
say uh illegal moves sorry unfortunately
can't be done uh so yes this is a four
sequence the bishop on the light square
is cut cuts across the board no King
runs for you and so this is a known
Force draw unfortunately it was
forgotten by Hikaru heading to this game
so that makes Madness opening Choice
look pretty brilliant and that's another
thing you mentioned what are you doing
during this break other than crossing
your arms and sipping water and smiling
you're thinking if you're Magnus Carlsen
about what you want to do in the next
game you're reviewing your files in your
head and I know that sounds crazy but
these players have so much going on in
their head these extra two minutes as
you said it allows Magnus to compose
himself and make an informed choice
about his opening in the next game which
if I had to predict I'd say he's likely
to repeat that A3 uh Shenanigans we've
seen him play thus far the same holds
true for hikara though because he could
spend this time thinking about how to
play as black so that's exactly what he
is thinking about is the next game the
next opening what he should do and well
this game is about to be a draw as soon
as king U1 is played
and and don't lose on time there we go
okay we have the drawn game by
repetition ten to seven still a
three-point lead for hitkara Nakamura
and Magnus keeps going back to the A3 if
it wins you games why not keep going if
it ain't broke don't fix it and
obviously it's not an ambitious opening
it's not like white is aiming for a big
opening Advantage you're aiming for a
relatively fresh position where white
has a tiny bit of pressure and given the
state in the match this could get
annoying for Hikaru he knows that a lots
in this game will get Magnus the closest
he has been all segment long and they've
transposed Robert into a pretty well
known line of the Queen's gamut accepted
this is the world championship match
between Magnus and Fabiano from 2018.
this opening was played a lot in Hikaru
and Magnus have played this stuff a lot
yeah it's it's really complicated here
because the threat was E5 to E4 after
attacking the bishop on F4 but now the
Knight on C6 is under attack if you take
on D5 there's Bishop takes H7 check and
and you get to win that night on D5 so
it's a really complicated sequence here
and Magnus is still laughing about
something and has Hikaru walked into
magnus's preparation because he car is
the one taking a chunk of time here
it gets crazy after efdc there's the
threat of b2b4 in the end
and if the car doesn't know this Robert
this is Major trouble you could lose
this in the blink of an eye well look at
the time Hikaru is spending time not
because he has a forced draw but he
really doesn't know the position and
it's what you're saying he takes F4 you
get a bishop D takes C6 you get a knight
white is up a pawn in that position and
B4 is a huge huge threat so it may look
like uh black is gonna go Pac-Man he
takes a four take on E3 he goes Knight
D4 which apparently is a slight
inaccuracy but still a good move boom
shakalaka that night opens up the e-file
and white is up upon it could be
recaptured on the next move Magnus still
seems to be in his preparation which is
pretty ridiculous oh here comes the
Knight Knight E5 is Bishop E6 but even
if you trade the Bishops there Dania
it's clearly an advantage for White and
the reason why is that dark Square
Bishop for black can't really attack
anything and white is kind of up a pawn
it's even material six pawns per side
but we have a past D4 pawn and you have
this Pawn on F4 that's doubled and not
going anywhere and Magnus starting to
get into his Groove I like this move by
Hikaru he's gonna take that Knight and
take on D1 but we always talk about this
Robert opposite colored Bishop positions
are a totally different kettle of fish
when the Queens are still on the board
when they're on the board it favors the
attacker so Hikaru definitely has a
serious defensive task cut out for him
in the next couple of moves yeah and
this King on G8 is not the safest piece
on the board because E6 at some point uh
will be a strike Rook D7 is also a
threat and B5 speaking of whoa huge move
from ikaru he's still my Beating Heart
Don't take on B5 because then the white
king will not have a beating heart but
maybe the bishop can move to D5 maybe
the bishop itself can take but then
you've cut out the pressure on F7 and
black can capture this very annoying
Pawn on E5 what a move by Hikaru and
actually under Bishop B5 degree Rook B8
you got to be careful for that move
because Rook takes B5 is suddenly a
threat as is Pawn to A6 because the
bishop is pinned The Rook on D1 is loose
the queen on B3 is overloaded great
point this should be five Rick I think
Magnus should just go Bishop D5 and then
do not go Rook d8 if you're Hikaru and
walk into Bishop takes F7 he's probably
gonna go Rook C then E6 oh
so then is he gonna go Rook B8
I love how we did that process of
elimination stuff like I feel like I'm
back in like third grade you know like
doing a little math problem and nothing
exactly not that one oh okay so rookie
it is the only move there uh it's a very
important move to find and hikar will
find it uh but Bishop D5 hits The Rook
Rook has to slide over one square
and if I may show something on the NL
sport real fast I promise it should be
five if you go Rook to E8 I don't think
we discussed this but there's still E6
you might say well what's the problem
I'll just take and you can't take
because the Queen recaptures the check
and here Bishop slides into F7 with a
fork so literally process of elimination
yields only one square and Magnus has to
see that Hikaru has to see that Carlson
not only is he no longer up on the clock
he's down 20 seconds and still thinking
and finally decides on Bishop D5 he
carves saw that instantly I wonder if
he's thinking about Bishop takes F7
check Queen takes F7 Pawn to E6 it gets
really sharp there because if the queen
tries to blockade the pawn so there's no
discover check the Rook flies into D7
there's a lot happening in this position
and it's not forced by any stretch of
the imagination but I'm guessing Magnus
is considering options like that great
call I definitely think he's you might
play Bishop F7 no he makes a very Magnus
move but is he taking his foot off the
gas pedal here well Bishop C5 is a great
choice you actually would prefer your
Pawn to be on B6 if you're black to keep
that Bishop stable but the F2 Pawn is a
target Queen H4 it's a moment can be
annoying or queen to E2 even more
threatening it's unbelievable but Magnus
was up a full minute as they entered the
middle game now he's down a minute and
he hasn't played E6 yet and the tension
is still building up can Magnus handled
a position of this complexity with 20
seconds left so he goes Rook C1 the
bishop goes back to B6 Queen takes
because Bishop F2 does not work you get
you lose your queen but you get a check
what a fine by Magnus Carlson and queen
65 blunders as you're showing there's
discover checks Galore here White's
Works blacks doesn't work and that's
because white has some lufts and black
does not and maybe Hikaru should create
some Luft but then you have to watch out
for E6 it gets ridiculously complicated
he's six wait can you sack the queen you
could have I think he could six was
winning wow he could have got a new
Queen and won the game but King F1 I
can't blame it for the king h8 what a
cool move by Hikaru but I would argue
that an on four Magnus we might show
this later would have seen E6
nonetheless he's got a big advantage in
the open in the end game you like to
point out the pawn majority black spawn
majority is fully crippled and you might
not have a pawn majority fight takes on
F7 at the right moment although if you
took on F7 there would be Bishop B2 so
it goes Rook C4 first that would Bishop
B2 doesn't come with Tempo he can put A4
then B5 he has a clear extra Pawn does
Magnus on the queen side materials even
but the position is not
and neither is the time 11 seconds for
Magnus he's got to build some time up
here can he win this basically blitzing
out his moves trying to maximize the
activity of the Rook we're accustomed
Robert to see Magnus win these types of
games can he pull another vintage
endgame Victory off look at this King C4
his King is going up the board the king
is a weapon in the end game Rook A6 Pawn
A4 coming first B5 Bishop C6 is possible
oh my goodness this looks very
unpleasant progress being made but after
the king Parks itself on D6 you can
never really go B6 car throws off a pawn
to [ __ ] White's Pawn structure but
the king just comes back he wants the F2
Pawn he's not getting it he's not
getting a single pawn and here comes the
a pawn and here comes Black's King yeah
maybe oh you drop the bishop trapping
the bishop if that Rook could get back
around the bishop is trapped but look at
this the H6 pawn and the F6 Pawn both on
the F6 Pawn King G4 King H5 oh my God
he's infiltrating he's taking he's
pressuring he still has time
he's just moving his King around now
moves the bishop back and Sack on F6 he
wants B6 and if you go King c5s Brook
takes A7 it's winning he's on knocking
on the door of having this lead can he
finish it off whoa
what recognition and this is winning
King F6 and just go back
move
oh the AC Pawn is lost but the bishop
was back I guess and then the King was
out the way and the F Pawn runs but do
not trade that last Pawn no because then
it's a drug King G7 what recognition
Magnus is the king of that Rook H4 and
Rook F4 it's not over yet he Karma look
at this bishop
he is this is insane
and this was necessary because Hikaru
would have otherwise given up the rook
and traded the last pair of Pawns and
look at Magnus you see the relief on his
face he gets this last game into three
plus one he can cut the lead down to one
point heading into bullet and Dania that
was insane Precision he found every
single move that liquidated that kept
the advantage and let him win the game
this is the Magnus that we know and I'm
not implying that this is normal in some
way or yeah well of course we're seeing
this Magnus is the only person in the
universe who can win an end game like
this with five seconds and he has been
winning on games like this throughout
the whole SEC and they're repeating this
again
yeah hikar keeps going back to this line
which seems to be more or less a fourth
draw I mean yeah there's never been any
trouble but look at the clot situation
three minutes in change for Hikaru three
minutes of change on the match clock so
if Hikaru does nothing this will be the
last game of the three plus one and he
will retain a two-point lead and he went
for this at the start of the
three-minute portion I didn't like it he
goes for this now I do like it because a
two-point lead is still significant for
Hikaru going into the bullet and clearly
he's found an improvement during the
break A4 rather than what he was doing
previously which is to prepare C4 what
do you make of this
oh I think at least gives us something
new to talk about but I don't think that
there's much going on now you'd be very
careful if you're blocked because a
takes B5 a takes B5 Rook A6 is a huge
threat because you're removing the
defender of the Knight on D5 and the
geometry is such that you could lose all
your pieces as black if the C6 Pawn
false so Magnus has to be careful and
ikaru he's just switching a little
something here and a professional
approach by Magnus he takes as long as
it takes to find what was the only move
to maintain the balance I checked and
now you are just in time ABAB Rook A6
The Rook captures on B2 but more
importantly it forces the bishop off of
the diagonal Hikaru basically has to
bail out with Bishop takes D5 check this
game I'm quite confident it's gonna end
in a drone just look at magnus's body
language he feels satisfied and
confident and he seems as engaged as
he's been all matched more engaged he
really is and if you're a hit car here
don't take any unnecessary risk I know
you're probably displeased that you had
a four-point lead now it's down to two
and you're playing Magnus Carlson who
can beat anybody at any time right once
he turns on the Jets he may never look
back but if you're Hikaru he's looking
he's doing he's just gonna spend a lot
of time he's probably going to simplify
make the draw and then go into bullet
with the lead
both players have to take a breath as
experienced as they are there's going to
be a lot of jitters to go around in the
bullet segment he does take B5 how
exactly do we bail out without losing a
pawn here because Rook takes me to
Robert ah and after Rook B3 don't go
Rook D3 and allow B4 move your king or
move your F Pawn and this is a drop
dead draw Rook takes B5 we just have
King rook and two against King rook and
two there's one minute remaining in this
time Patrol yeah but there's no way
Hikaru is gonna let uh another game be
played in three plus one it would be
absurd to not to not milk the rest of
this clock down given how Magnus has
played with the white pieces
and avoid repetition if you're Hikaru or
get a repetition going do what he's done
previously which is to sit
uh and then repeat for the third time
once his clock is down oh I thought yeah
that's what he's gonna do I thought you
said do what he did previously and win a
rook again like he did against Neil
sorry we had almost this exact structure
he was on the black side of it and nehal
got himself skewered I will never forget
that moment from that match
wow we are gonna have a two point lead
for hikar Nakamura now if before the
match you say Hikaru you'll be up by two
points going to bully he said of course
give me that lead but I feel like right
now he has to feel a bit disappointed
it's hard to put losses out the window
especially when they're recent because
if we just look at the last bunch of
games it is Magnus Carlson who's been on
a bit of a winning streak and they made
a draw it is the end of the three plus
one and that means we are heading to
Bullet chess and Magnus he seems happy
he seems for the first time to really
believe that he can equalize this match
and end up winning it car is definitely
disappointed he was still up by four
with halfway through the three plus one
portion he was looking to bring the
hammer down and instead Magnus Carlson
arrives on the scene the Magnus that we
know has this lead he stands really
really well going to the bullet I think
Magnus is more than happy to be down by
two given the circumstances oh yeah he
blundered a bishop on one turn that was
shocking I made the same mistake but
still you don't expect Magnus Carlson to
do that so to be only down by two points
that feels like a small victory he will
head into the bullet with a very real
chance but before we go to break I want
to make an announcement because there
are many announcements to make in the
Chess World uh this the get ready for
the Q4 2022 state of chess.com coming to
you live on December 21st we're
announcing some huge news from the chess
Community followed by Community Q a with
Danny wrench live guests include the
Magnus Carlson we'll be taking your
questions in chat you don't want to miss
this show December 21st at 10 A.M
Pacific right here on twitch.tv chess
like the players Donnie and I are gonna
head to break when we return it is the
last but not least
segment it's a two-point match it is
Hikaru Nakamura versus Magus Carlson
thank you your subscription makes shows
like this possible which is why our
twitch subscribers will never see ads on
chess.com
connectyourchess.com account and Twitch
account at go.chess.com connect accounts
and bang boom voila you're done a
hundred percent ad free Bliss
forevermore whether you're following our
events on site or on stream type the
command connect in the chat and thank
you for helping bring these shows to
life
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
a storm is brewing we see a statement
performance from Magnus Carlson oh
Nakamura is surviving
what a tactic holy smokes my brain is
exploding
the moves will be fast starting to seem
Bishop C7 oh my God where's the mate
though I don't know but it's gotta be
there oh my God
the stakes will be high oh my God
the 2022 speed Chess Championship is now
fasten your speed belts my friends we're
in for a wild ride
in return here at the speed Chess
Championship final between Magnus
Carlson and ikar Nakamura I'm
Grandmaster Robert Hess alongside me my
good friend Grandmaster Daniel nerdinski
we have to call we're entering the final
portion of this match it is 30 minutes
of one minute plus one second increment
bullet and Donya there is a lot of money
at stake there's a lot of Pride but the
prize is they are huge let's take a look
at the performers thus far we don't know
who the top two will be nihal sarin made
over 10 grand as a semi-finalist So
Daniel as we see down the list here a
lot of money has been at stake and a lot
more in this bullet segment the entire
SCC is at stake those are some Sleek
totals even on a carwana taking home
over 3K anyhal Sirens total enough uh to
buy a car and more money to be
distributed between icaro and Magnus but
right now what's on the line is pride
what's on the line is the opportunity if
you're Hikaru Nakamura to keep his lead
and defeat the world champion reversing
their lifetime Trend and there is our
scoreboard ladies and gentlemen it's ten
and a half eight and a half but Magnus
Carlson he has gone from from down four
to within two and he is most certainly
in Striking Distance Robert especially
given his bullet record against icaro in
the SEC he has previously defeated
Hikaru seven and a half two and a half
one year and the other year it was close
I think he lost six to five so he's got
a shot
he certainly does and you mentioned the
word trend and this match is trending in
magnus's Direction he was down by four
points and looked really bad for him he
won two games down the stretch of the
three minute plus one second increment
time Patrol but this is chaos this is
Mayhem this is bullet chess and this is
the speed Chess Championship final it's
Hikaru Nakamura with a two-point lead
over Magnus Carlsen we are about to have
liftoff oh my gosh folks it's an honor
and a privilege to be a part of this it
all comes down to these 30 minutes speed
builds fast and here we go Carlson all
the white pieces and a queen's gamut
declined carlsbat structure in game one
Magnus once again sticking to a solid
approach Robert wow and Knight H5
Knights In The Rim are dim but that
Knight attacked in Bishop 104 but look
at the Knight remaining out there the
queen on D1 spies it at some point 95
might be a good move but look at Magnus
playing smart chest with Knight at four
you love the night out oh an early
oversight he has to move the bishop back
that gives secaro a Tempo now it's not
the end of the world because his Pawn
structure can sustain it but he'll need
to smoke smoke that night out of f4 ASAP
well he's about to Castle Queen side and
then I will have to move now the C6 Pawn
is a target he goes Knight to E2
and now it's a backwards Pawn so done
even if 92 Bishop B2 we just get some
trades white has the structural
Advantage but he blunders with Knight D2
could be two oh what a move oh what a
tactic in game one of the bullet it's
gonna win a pawn the knights dropping
back to C4 and he car is basically
winning in the end game and you saw
Magnus he's like yep I missed that one
and ikaru needs to put this one away it
will give him a three-point lead but
what a mistake by Magnus Carlsen he has
just been off form in so many of these
games
so many one move blunders and we're just
not used to that but Hikaru as you said
he has to put this game to bed build up
that cushion early in the match because
almost all of the bullet comebacks we've
seen they start from the very first
games and this is not moving in magnus's
Direction Robert the f file is going to
open the F2 Pawn is a Sitting Duck look
at that Rook aiming hungrily at the pawn
wow H4 G3
is also really nice but the pawn F2 is
going down if you go Rook H2 then G3
comes with Tempo and you just have
nothing here you might even think
goodbye hello 93 Bishop D3 Knight F1 you
can take anything in any order Magnus
needs to resign and he needs to do it
now every second is golden right now oh
my gosh Bishop G4 check it Bishop to
this Rook F1 check things like that it
looks very very bad for Magnus Hikaru
sees it
guess what he's doing something he's
never done before he's bringing some
time off the clock resign right now if
you're Magnus Knight C3 oh and he does
that's it yeah he resigns he sells over
27 minutes remaining that is plenty of
time for this comeback he goes for the
Sicilian he had a good position earlier
in the match into Sicilian but he did
not play the con
it's very common for players to trade
blows at the start of the bullet as they
adjust to the new time control but one
thing's for a certain Magnus is going to
lose the match if he continues to make
these one move tactical blunders he had
a great position there he just simply
overlooked Queen takes me to and great
recognition from Hikaru and look at this
G4 that is something that strong players
do even if they just want to draw and
keep a match lead they play like it's
any other game you need to play in your
style you cannot play with fear
hikara might even be playing more
aggressively than usual he wants to put
this match away in the next 10 minutes
he doesn't want this coming down to the
last game he doesn't want any of that
Intrigue he wants to end this here and
now and he's trying to end it on the
king side Magnus is trying to put his
King to the death on the queen side here
we go folks this is almost like the on
Drake and Wesley so game from the cgc
and I'm waiting for G6 from white but
Queen C3 threads creepy to me then
Knight will have to move out the way so
it's a close call and look at Max like
Bishop F6 you think gf7 the king might
take on F7 the king is out in the open
but he's protecting everything for the
time being it's a messy position
it is but Hikaru adroitly handling his
minor pieces and stopping the queen from
infiltrating to C3 it just seems like
that G6 one is going to wreak havoc once
the F7 Pawn is eliminated and we see a
swap on C1 and Knight C5 Magnus so is
there Knight takes E4 shots you'd be
very careful here if you're a Karu but
there's E5 beating him to the punch and
smashing through the center the Knight
on C5 is now hanging as is the Knight on
D4 but you can just recapture and
where's the crusher
wasn't it still good for white
apparently but if Bishop F3 you're
forcing of Knight takes F3 because
otherwise you might lose peace
but then then how is black just going to
keep all his minor pieces in tactic
going back to d8 Best Move by Magnus
that's a huge nominal defensive move
Rook C5 you can't take the Rook when you
can take the bishop on G5 and I do
believe that White's King is less safe
so I see the evaluation bar but I
actually believe that White's position
is a little bit more precarious you're
absolutely right the pawn on A3 offers
long-term chances against White's King
that could be significant in a Time
scramble they are nearing a Time
scramble and Magnus opens the f file
he's taking over the initiative here
he's got a serious chance to win this
game is there some kind of Bishop F3
here Bishop F3 yes and then Rook F3 in
the end yeah there's like Bishop C5 idea
so maximum 10 seconds oh he completely
misses it but he keeps himself with
three past pawns on the king side again
it's all about practical perspective
here I still think magnuses get great
winning chances Bishop D5 stick it on
the center everything he takes there is
F3 hanging belts Queen takes d8 first he
plays Bishop D5 he wants those pawns to
go uh oh but here come the knights uh
Rook B6
H4 the H6 and then G5 you got to throw
all your pawns at White
it's anybody's game I see the eval bar
forget the eval bar it's 10 50 50
position he carves stopping the pawns
Here Comes magnus's Rook yes but the
b-pawn might seal the deal for white at
some point it's gonna go up the board
and the knight's gonna jump into F6 at
the right moment oh this is not looking
good for Magnus no it isn't A2 is also a
bit loose so you if you take it right
off the pawn you could lose the A2 when
he goes oh my gosh
where do you go you have to give up A2
you called it
should pay two now oh hey Cara is
collapsing he's losing control of the
game Bishop B4 and eg3 was winning
Bishop E4 is next and b5's hanging as
well
grab that pawn and move the bishop back
and do it now look at all these pawns
going forward take on H2 back Rook F2 to
G3 and just take on 18. going for maid
but there's no mate and look at Magnus
he realized it I think he's looking from
side to side no Checkmate and he's gonna
pick his Rook to have all the check oh
and the King making a Mad Dash to the
other side of the board it's a promotion
it's a win Hikaru he does what he
usually does
Robert what did we just see what a win
this has been a crazy game and Magnus
Carlson he is showing his world
championship medal his pedigree his
ability to stay alert to stay in this
match and he's going to Checkmate Hikaru
in the next few moves and look at that
and what for the quickest checkmate
yep clinical Until the End even with two
Queens on the board he ain't lazy every
second matters here and only seven
minutes have gone off the match clock so
it has not been a catastrophe Magnus
gets this lead back to two in another
pivotal game of the white pieces
these two are the absolute best in all
forms of speed chess but in bullet this
is incredible stuff we see a capture on
C4 this game Donna that'll allow white
to strike in the center with E4 a big
Center for white we've seen many
positions just like this and look at
Black's kind of awkward setup with the
Knight on C6 this is some sort of a
grunfeld but in the grunfeld you usually
want to be able to play C5 in this case
Hikaru pushes E5 and he's gonna stick
that Knight on D4 practically I do like
Black's piece activity piece activity is
so important in bullet but this is like
the most Magnus position ever like you
have the bishop here you're getting in
the end game there's no target you're
just better here and I feel like this is
trouble for Hikaru
Bishop C5
[Laughter]
let's stop it stop it no you stop it
okay
94 is a counter shot for black that's
the good news for hit car right now
and he's gonna play it and he has to
seize on the opportunity to create
Intrigue with his Knights Knight C2
maybe get that Bishop out of the picture
Bishop C5 can you throw that in he goes
Queen c3s he's singing oh nice Bishop my
G7 is terrible Knight T5 almost Works he
plays it now and he's gonna play C6 I
think to cement the Knight now he goes
back
and you need to get Knight C5 or at
least threaten Knight C5 is white
trading everything here should sort of
be better for Magnus but a card doing a
very good job of being solid Magnus has
made zero progress the last five moves
and Hikaru UPS 17 seconds huge time
Advantage for a bullet game can he stay
afloat in this highly charged situation
I love that move yeah but don't play
1966 367 losing the spot oh my God Who's
That Knight to D7 don't take on B2
either there was a fork on B3
it's an ic5
get into those light squares
for sure and Magnus slowly accumulating
this is his type of position you called
it
yeah this is dangerous because the black
king is less safe than the Viking I will
play H4 at some moment maybe H5 just
chisel at the black king
whatever you do don't lose this game if
you're Magnus this would be a
heartbreaker 9600 a piece oh my gosh
and he resigns right away so see I think
Hikaru feels that the match is slipping
so instead of just wasting time he's
like I need to get in the flow because
right now he is a bit rattled and Magnus
Carlson has cut the lead to just one
point
he ties the match with the win in this
game but look at Magnus adhering to his
strategy he's not gonna try to do
everything at once he's going to play
solid chess he does not mind a draw with
the black pieces it's the same strategy
oh that finally got him success in the
end of the three minute portion Knight
takes D3 as a threat I like that way
this is going for him again Knight of
four threads right away you don't have
to take a pawn just hit the Rook hit the
bishop and then maybe go Queen H4 next
or queen D7 and Rook a to E8 you need to
bring that Rook to the e-file stat if
you're black he's thinking about Queen
H4 you can tell
it's a big move and hikar might have to
play G3 but the Knight goes into H3 with
check things like that it looks a bit
dodgy but perhaps the white king is just
safe enough Hikaru is mad he is really
frustrated with how these games have
been going
the first two-game winning streak for
Magnus this entire match and it comes at
the perfect moment but can Magnus
produce compensation he's down 30
seconds Robert this ain't isn't looking
good all of a sudden yeah Carl's playing
easy moves too right he pushes Pawn to
D4 when it was attacked he is making
simple choices and doing it well C5
striking you want to open the board for
your Bishops and Knight E4 so you can
take on e4 get opposite colored Bishops
but then for white Hikaru could take a
lot of time off the clock at this point
it doesn't matter the match is too close
love what Magnus did there he blockades
the pawn but in comes the rook and he oh
oh I thought he Blended yes there is a
back ranked Checkmate so rookie eight
very small but if you take any four
Queen takes there's a mate threatened on
H7 but Hikaru is so good at tightening
the Noose in these types of positions no
risk he can play this forever and the
moment Magnus slips and that pawn runs
into D6 it's over you gotta keep that
Bishop on D6 firmly entrenched
okay so now A4 can open up that Rook on
A8 you might put his King on G7 at some
moment he goes Rook d8 he wants firm
defense
Hikaru trying to induce more weaknesses
on the king side and infiltrating to the
seventh rank attacking F7 so many
threats here Robert and the pawn is
hanging if you are and you can play D6
wow Rook D6 huge move
opening the diagonal attacking F7 Magnus
pushed to the back great awareness by
Magnus to play bishopian H5 a great
choice of midcaro H6 if you take you
lose F7 so he goes King f8 now the H6
Pawn is either strength or a long-term
weakness Magnus making a Mad Dash to the
center the king is weaker than it's been
the whole game he's basically lost but
still we're guessing
D6 shot B7 Chuck
he gets the B7 check-in and F7 wait
he left the king slip
and there was Bishop C7 there but still
this looks like anybody's going oh
my gosh Bishop C7 threading mate and you
have to trade Queens but now black is up
a pot all of a sudden and G3
but so is H7 this is still a three
result game with two seconds Anything
Can Happen a mouse slip a blunder Rook
have five another excellent move Robert
he's going for that pawn and he goes
Kingston is that Rook trapped Bishop A6
Force
Brooks take it watch out the 87 Pawn is
safe and sound and H6 is a problem
you might lose this if black wins h60
wins the game now if you're Magnus do
not flag do not flag F6 F6 quick move
Bishop GA draw that's a good awareness
no you can't take it oh you can't take
the Pod it's tied Hikaru resides and we
have a tied match with 17 minutes to go
for the first time since the beginning
of this match Magnus Carlson is level
it's 0-0 that was one of the most
unbelievable bullet comebacks I have
ever seen in the SCC this is insane your
speed belts you need six of them right
now Magnus has white and a chance to
take the lead for the first time in this
match
and the car was telling himself to wake
up to see the tactics despite what's
going on he was up a pawn it seemed like
a risk-free position but Magnus Carlson
is on fire right now look at this move
Rook D1 he takes on D4 he just has more
activity So Daniel if the minor Pieces
come off watch for the second Rook to
reach D1 and it is just completely easy
chess for Magnus Carlson I always say
this when there's only one open file the
side that controls it controls it holds
all of the positional keys to the
kingdom black is firmly worse here and
Hikaru in his rattled condition he's got
to make sure he doesn't make any one
move blunders no you can't make it easy
for Magnus and he's got another Magnus
type of position yeah Queen E5 and Rook
G4 was an option he goes Rook D6 instead
we need five now black has to shuffle
right if you push your Pawn to E5 which
just does Rook D5 give me some squares
and look at this now all of a sudden it
carves out of it that was an incredible
sequence of moves by Hikaru he drives
the pawn E4 to lock in White's Queen and
hits both of these pawns at once and
suddenly Magnus is in Syria he might
already be worse he's given
but I think that was a really good
decision by Magnus he doesn't let blood
continue becoming even more active he
gives up material and now if you swap
Brooks well okay that still keeps the
extra EPO slow down if you're Magnus you
got to be accurate because he car is not
letting this opportunity slip
or is he okay you fine with a repetition
if you're Magnus so maybe keep going
Rook D5
okay he knows for it he goes Rook D6 he
just wants to keep control of black
suits you go Rook E5 Rook goes to D7
Queen maneuvering dodging Meandering
trying to Chisel its way into White's
position that Queen on E3 moves away to
D4 threatening Rook d8.
okay he doesn't have to take the Rook
that's very important
and fe3 rookie three right it looks
scary or he's in Queen takes E3 23. I
think we gotta go Queen E3 well it would
be nice but Hikaru can squeeze this out
forever yes although if the queen side
pawns come off that we know that's a
theoretical draw but yeah the question
is does hikara want to squeeze forever
it's a tied match he no longer has the
lead so what do you do I think you you
try to squeeze just because you have the
upper hand you've got the color oh
apparently Rook C4 here might win a
second Pawn no way the Rook eight eight
oh and then Rook takes B4 Magnus just
blundered with C5 he he rushed it oh my
goodness he rushed it huge moment this
game
how does he my Lance how can he survive
here
I don't think he can I think he's gonna
end up two pawns down and that is still
salvageable in some cases but not here
you gotta try right you can't resist so
much time left in this match you'll only
be that one point even if you lose but
great recognition by car first with
Queen A6 then they're The Rook C4 the
pawn on C5 is an extra one but the
problem is the black king can't really
get out what black wants is to trade the
seep on for the H Pawn a three on one on
one side is easily winning can Hikaru
get that to happen or can Magnus keep
the Fortress alive
stop G4 great move fantastic move he
should have played G4 first Robert he
should have stopped at five he's gonna
lose yeah I think he's gonna lose
there's Rook C5 at some point but
how does this window okay G5 how do you
get in
well you zigzag your way through but the
evil bar 2.2 is like Fortress 53
blunders loaded on the spot but you see
the evaluation bar when it's at that
level that means there probably was some
kind of draw but so difficult when you
have no time
and another uncharacteristic blunder it
has played Carlson all match long and
with 13 minutes on the match clock you
can't really afford to lose another one
if you're Carlson he needs another
clutch match Time Performance what a
recovery by Hikaru what a recovery
amazing right it looked like everything
was going against him he was able to win
that game and look at this position here
nine moves in H3 played it's a quiet
position cut the board in half black has
an extra Pawn from a through D white has
an extra Pawn e through H there's a
Kings on the on the one side of the
board white has an extra Pawn on that
side I think white is going to try to
get an attack
but from a match perspective Carlson
getting what he wants an unbalanced
position definitely chances to win here
but with a knight coming to F5 Queen
chief of Robert you called it this is
getting already practically unpleasant
look at the clock Magnus falling behind
again he's in trouble again he is and he
might need to swap nights and put Bishop
D7 just to cover the C6 Square something
move do you not want to lose your
blockade of the E5 pod that is not what
Magnus wants but he's playing so slowly
down 24-23 seconds remaining this ain't
a three-minute game anymore they're in
bullet time Magnus playing fast free
moving trying Hikaru blockading he's got
the dark Square control on the queen
side he's in control of the game rookie
three and he goes Queen either he wants
to swap Queens but look at this F4 F5
thrusting that pawn forward that's bad
news for black
uh oh F5 coming and the end game offers
no relief at all because the C file
opens and Magnus gonna go after that
hikar gonna go after the C6 Pawn yeah
this is looking very ugly you can't even
go F6 because E6 upon is driven forward
suffocating totally suffocating well I
can hardly move he wants F5 even if it's
good for white Magnus just wants
something he wants some space for his
pieces
but he's got 10 seconds on the clock
that's where he really wants more time
equal time but with 40 seconds Bishop
trying to get to E4
we have a trade hh5 rookie 6 Rook G6
something like that is what black needs
Carlson once again dude this is already
heroic defense wow holding on G6
oh but the Queen's getting a trap G4 is
coming it's Unstoppable that is crazed
in F5 and so what awareness from ikaru
Queen H5 get rid of the pawn shops the
bishop
even better
Hikaru is a beast oh but what a move by
Magnus GF there's nothing that didn't
work Queen couldn't have taken the Rook
still two-point lead for a car it's back
to that lead Hikaru Nakamura just when
it looked like you know a mortal player
might tilt he shows his superpowers
your car is showing some nasty and
showing us another Queen's gamma decline
if you're Hikaru you're more than happy
with a drop Robert 10 and a half left
Magnus he's the one who has to avoid
panicking now where's his momentum gun
it's out the window because
hikaranakamura stole it and we have over
150 000 people watching on Twitch and on
YouTube Welcome to the biggest party on
this Sunday night E4 played by Hikaru
Nakamura jumping in the center Donya I
feel like white doesn't really have much
of anything here but this is the hikar
excuse me the Magnus type of position
they can try to grind Hikaru down it
and it's what Magnus was unable to get
the last couple of games the last couple
of losses he's gotten back to what makes
him the most comfortable positional
maneuvering games he's got a clear
Advantage here and at this point he's
got exactly zero room for error and he's
a rook A2 Rook a one at some point
through an a takes P5 can toss in Knight
C5 any moment you have a clamp on the
queen side but Hikaru with 53 seconds of
he's moving so quickly and just honestly
very well and I think Magnus just can't
match him on the speed and Hikaru
consciously adjusting his speed he's
getting faster and faster he's putting
pressure on magnus's clock and here we
go with this again more counter play on
the king side more of a Time Advantage
Knight F6 E4 oh Bishop F3 so you want to
give your Bishop for the night Bishop C8
hitting H3 Pawn you gotta move your king
out the way doesn't the C6 is hanging so
he's an and F7 and F7 so you have to oh
very careful black if you take only five
de5 the C6 Pawn is loose so it's
tactical Solution by Magnus Carlson and
Magnus is more than happy to give up a
pawn If It Means A queen trade if he can
get rid of that King side pressure he
will breathe a major sigh of relief he's
eliminating some pieces But Here Comes
sicaro again
great moves my current Knight P2 I like
that move from Magnus King safety is
Paramount the E1 Square now covered
Knight D2 is there like a rook B7 at
some point oh well there's a queen takes
F2 tactic we saw that in the first game
but Magnus again forcing the queen
Trader at least he's trying to yes
because the end game looks terrible for
black that's not a bishop on B7 it's a
big Pawn
it is and it can't move away because
then white will have full control of the
seventh rank in 93. oh okay moves
yeah it's not close yet
there's Rook A1 Queen C 1.86 made sense
okay he wants to trade Rooks
whoa Rook B8 no the bishop 103 is loose
five deserves attention it is played
Rook a six oh and if you take on E5 D in
the c600 we'll fall Bishop takes D5 is
another threat and C6 is hanging
directly but Hikaru can throw in H3 at
some point if he can make this messy
he's had the edge and time scrambles all
match long this is what it all comes
down to here we go
but look at that he was Knight C4 Knight
takes C6 keeping more pieces on the
board you could take on D5 and play
Queen uh forks and play Queen D5 he said
takes right away but there's Perpetual
ideas there are I don't know if he can
win this look at that Knight and queen
combo but the queen A1 there's no more
check of the king of two and H4 is loose
is it losing ikar thought it was Queen
H4 take a pawn bishop E4 but then the
Knight might slide to G4 when you're not
paying attention it's so easy to miss
mate here it's easy to miss a fork it's
easy to blunder upon and if you do any
of those things you're not gonna win but
look at that move Bishop E2 and G3 King
G2 then push your B Pawn no checks
available for black
twisting the knife is Magnus Carlson and
moving the pawn forward keeping time on
his clock he should be able to win this
game Queen E6 is defending both
Queen E5 oh that's nasty where's the
move but please stop threading anything
he's gonna go B7 but Queen takes C2 and
queen or Check Yes gotta see it does
Magnus he doesn't it's okay he moves his
bishop and then b7's Unstoppable still
totally winning but you don't want to
give Hikaru any added chances okay so it
goes Queen E4 he's attacking the Knight
like just really precise play from
Magnus not pushing the pawn and now
portal Queen E7 there's got to be a way
to force promotion okay this is simple
but hit car's in a waste of the match
clock and what that does is it forces
Magnus basically to win the next game
yes it does six oh don't take G oh you
can you can there's no stalemate it was
close though scared both of us it was
very close and don't pre-move you might
stalemate by accident yes
oh no stalemates available
he's trying to find the questions he's
trying to find this Checkmate but you
got time if you're Magnus there's no
need to do any crazy pre-moves at this
point the Supreme Queen C2 yeah oh my
gosh we'll have six minutes remaining
Magnus oh my God he can draw the next
game right if he draws the next game
there still will be enough time right
six minutes is plenty of time to make up
a one point deficit but he cannot afford
to lose and he plays the French defense
of all openings
and that's what Lavon arone you know
that's what Dimitri on Dragon played in
a must-one situation he lost that game
but Magnus has done this before and he's
getting the same type of comfortable
position with the queen side fiancaro
that he got previously
E6 Bishop B7 that position
Magnus oh Hong goes all the way up to A6
oh he forces him to give away his Bishop
right you see the evaluation bar in
White's favor but it's a long-term
problem for white in some end games that
A6 Pawn may have wandered too far but
here's a short-term problem for black
white is threatening Bishop A3 and
forcing magnus's Queen back maybe he
wants to go there anyway don't blunder
Bishop A3 he might sack his Queen right
it's not out of the question but he goes
Queen back to C7 you called it
the car is over a minute Robert yeah
he's playing so could B5 is an option
for black now
this is bad this is bad for black he
needs to make something happen he needs
to change the trend of the game quickly
he does because white has the bishop
Perry and all the Knight B5 coming in
then not look Pleasant if he senses that
he's losing he has to resign promptly
because he can steal it he has enough
time to start two games
he does that's true four minutes and 40
seconds remaining in the match clock
he's playing like a computer here Knight
B5
Queen be gay so Rook b196 the A6 Pawn is
a bit loose so Rook A2 rookie two very
alert by Hikaru but now maybe that gives
Magnus the D file you gotta take it you
got to take what you're off does
and but the knights have no squares the
bishop on C2 just completely Corrals
those Knights and 28 extra seconds
Hikaru continues to push magnus's pieces
back we're entering the territory where
even resigning might not help but it's
way too early for that Magnus is still
very much in this game
Knight C5 he's going after the A6 pump
Bishop E7 will be the move after Knight
takes A6 so you can't even capture the
pawn oh my God there's Knight takes A7
and he sees it oh the bishop is losing
E5 he's lost he might need to resign
actually it made would make sense to
resign here yeah he actually has to
resign and win the next game his no the
Knight C6 is over
he's got to resign he might be using too
much squawk
oh he's still trying though but he ends
it yeah 97 check after Rook C8 it's over
you've got to resign three it's gonna be
close
it is and we have seen bullet games
especially Hikaru games last over four
minutes so the match might already be
over Magnus has to play very quickly
and Hikaru can bleed try to bleed the
rest of the clock down
car Nakamura just when it looks like
Magnus Carlson is about to get his way
he finds a way through he's been playing
marvelous chess all day c35 by D4
speaking of marvelous that punk oh is
that something pretty marvelous there
and Magnus has managed to play Super
quickly he's got over a minute he has to
avoid the situation where hikaru's time
on the clock is higher than the overall
match time obviously because Danny Carr
will just wait it out and a closed
position is just what Hikaru oh Magnus
is much better Rook ad1 yeah Rook B1
Rook D1 there are issues left and right
for ikaru I'm looking at the master
literally the time two minutes 35
seconds so plenty of time left he just
needs to win this game in the next two
and a half minutes yeah there should be
enough time here we remind you that if
any time remains and the game starts it
counts and is this end game gonna make
it is he gonna make it count Rook d8
Rook d8 is a great opportunity six oh
but Robert there's no square for the
bishop he's got to play Passive no
that's really bad Knight takes C3
to check this might already be a draw
holy car going after the night and now
he's going after the bishop yeah he's
gonna go after the pond Magnus he's not
losing this no And even if he loses I
think it might take more than two
minutes
might be at the verge of an SEC
Championship he is in the driver's seat
he's not losing this game with the black
pieces
unless something just happened oh he did
he blundered the pawn now he's got 50
seconds he might even be able to build
up enough time to bleed it out it's
gonna be really close but Magnus says
winning chances now oh for Chicago oh my
gosh before at some point but one Robert
35 seconds remaining on the mass clock
look at what he car is doing he's just
playing instantly he's trying to bleed
this out he's got 40 more seconds
he's lost his position he doesn't have
enough time oh my gosh Magnus has to
show off the mouse speed right now
because this is a winning position for
white he is winning a second Pawn just
like a car did in a previous game
Magnus cannot afford to waste a single
second this could be over if Hikaru can
bleed another minute off the batch clock
here we go one minute 10 seconds every
second counts King he checks he's gonna
win G5
and kg7 it's winning oh my God no but
Hikaru he has 15 more seconds he needs
to bleed 15 seconds
if you're Magnus your car is gonna make
it happen
he wins the speed Chess Championship
Magnus gives a little bit clap forehead
car Nakamura but what a performance from
the American Superstar he has won the
Fisher random World Championship this
year he's winning title Tuesday pretty
much twice every single Tuesday and now
he has taken the speed Chess
Championship that is your streamer that
is your SCC winner of 2022.
fans aren't happy when Hikaru bleeds out
the clock when he waits a minute to
resign guess what every second that he
bled out this is the three second
difference right here and right now
Hikaru Nakamura how did he do that he
was losing for like 40 moves and he
somehow built up enough time to bleed it
out he has won the match unbelievable he
has and you see jubilition on his face
re relief I mean they have so much
respect for one another and I said as I
said earlier Hikaru Nakamura just
defeated Magnus Carlson in three hours
of many many chess games that is such a
huge accomplishment the only other
person who has done that is Maxine
Bashar lagrav now it's a car nakamura's
turn and it is his SCC title his fifth
in a row
he wins and he wins and he wins and the
match was tied about 15 minutes into the
bullet it was the first display of
negative emotion from Hikaru but he let
that out Robert he let it out and then
he kept playing like the Beast that he
is immediately coming back with two wins
and doing just enough to keep this lead
going to the end of the match what did
we just see we saw smarter chess's
prediction come true Hikaru Nakamura
wins a nail biter 14 f-13 and half look
at those scores is all the five plus one
time control where CaRu dominant he got
a huge lead and he was able to Stave off
the world champions comeback what a
thrilling match that was Dania Hikaru
Nakamura what can we say about that guy
I can't wait to hear his thoughts hey
this match we're gonna remember it by
asking where were you when Hikaru
Nakamura beat Magnus Carlson in the SEC
these guys they've played a lot of
matches I dare say this might be the
most epic Carlson Nakamura match that
we've ever seen and perhaps even the
start of a tradition I can't wait to
hear what hikara has to say I'm so
pumped Robert I'm sad it's over but I'm
smiling because it happened
it is a great saying by you Daniel let's
show the bracket again to show where
Hikaru Nakamura came from it was the top
left of things in the bracket he was the
one seed he came into the first round
against David paravian one by 12. and
then based off against levada ronian one
by seven things got closer against dlsar
and he won by four and last but
certainly not least he beat the number
one rated player on the planet the
highest rated player of all time the big
boss of Chess Magnus Carlson and Hikaru
Nakamura you see him up there with the
trophy above his name he is your SCC
title winner so we are going to get
Hikaru Nakamura in for this call You're
Gonna Hear His Thoughts in a post-match
interview with a car Nakamura he's your
winner Donya it's going to be an epic
stream the next time he goes live
it really is and deservedly so listen
Magnus says a ton of fans Hikaru has a
ton of fans wherever you stand on on
hikara you just have to admit that this
guy is ridiculous he's ageless and he
puts through another one of his just
endless insane performances in 2022
Fisher random world champion and now the
winner of the SEC on the heels of one of
the most epic Blitz matches we have ever
seen
we're gonna bring Hikaru Nakamura in for
an interview for those of you in chat
there are so many out there leave your
questions in the chat you may be
featured if you ask a good question so
we will have Hikaru Nakamura your 2022
speed chess champion infant interview in
just a few minutes do not go anywhere
use gifts not GIFs from the biggest
chess stars on all of your favorite
platforms just search chess.com and your
favorite chess star on Discord Twitter
WhatsApp and more to find hundreds of
gifts from chess.com's biggest broadcast
and events Pokey main Ludwig moist
critical xqc and even me Danny try it
today
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
and we are joined by your 2022 speed
chess champion Hikaru Nakamura five
times in a row must feel good doesn't it
yeah I mean this was a crazy match
obviously Magnus was definitely out of
sorts in the five plus one um I jumped
out to this big lead but his credit
Magnus always kept fighting back I mean
it was it was insane I mean there were
probably two or three times in the
bullet that I thought finally the match
was over and he found a way to um to to
keep it complicated complicated and um
yeah it was just a great match
fortunately I came out on top but you
know I think the fans enjoyed it and
that's what that's what matters most
Hikaru is there a unique particular kind
of euphoria that stems specifically from
beating Magnus
well I mean I think to beat Magnus in a
match uh means a lot more than a one-off
game obviously it goes without saying um
but I think you know when I look back
there was this 2020 final against Magnus
and the chess 24 event um the Melt water
or I think it was shot Shaman store at
the time um where he played best of
seven matches and I I would say that
that was probably the best that I've
ever played and unfortunately this
Heartbreaker I won the first Blitz game
lost a second one then I couldn't win
the Armageddon game and um you know I
think uh after that like it's it's hard
to know whether it's possible to beat
Magnus but I think today I came with a
strategy I got out to lead which of
course helped a lot and then you know I
know a lot of people don't like the idea
of stalling or using time but again it's
a match and honestly uh there was this
match that played against Magnus in 2017
I think was or maybe 18. there was one
of the ones where I played I actually
played it from Florida maybe it was the
first one in like six 16 or 17 whatever
it was on the one when I was not not in
South Africa and I remember in that
match that I think it was relatively
close it was maybe a couple of games
um going it was like two or three that I
was down going to the bullet and then I
start off the bullet poorly of course
Magnus ran away the ran away with the
match and so in this match my main
strategy was try to keep it as close as
possible going into the bullet and I
mean there were there were a couple
games uh where I kind of messed it up in
the the three plus one like this one
game in the French were I pretty much
had to use the restroom really badly so
I was just like blitzing every move but
when I sacked on F7 and took the pawn on
E6 I mean if I had more time maybe I win
that game but you know it's of course uh
things played out the way they did so
yeah I mean it's you try to play as well
as you can you try to use the clock to
your advantage you know Magnus obviously
very formidable competitor and um it's
it's just it's it's wild that I won but
but you know I kept it together
yeah you were just talking about your
match strategy Hikaru you kept repeating
this line that traded off all the pieces
in the Marshall what was your mindset
with that line because I think all those
games ended in a draw were you okay just
settling for the Half Point as long as
the games took a long time bleed bled
the match clock and you were able to
keep your lead
well I mean the first thing is I didn't
prepare this line I had another line
that I thought I might play with Magnus
played the Marshall but then of course
as everybody knows I had this famous
game in 2005 and the Isle of Man against
catronius where I played the martial
black I mean I think I played I think I
played F5 Bishop F4 I don't remember if
I played F5 Bishop F4 and I I didn't
know to play Bishop 3 I lost the game
afterwards I think was katroneous or
maybe it was errone one of the two they
came over and told me like oh you just
you take on that four go Bishop F3 it's
just an easy draw and then I think in
2008 I played it against Lavon himself
in Gibraltar maybe I have the year wrong
um and at any rate I just figured with
the lead there was no reason not to do
this again if Magnus is I feel like you
have to try and use every Advantage you
can have against Magnus and he was being
very very solid and if I'm not trying
I'm not trying if I start playing
creatively I mean why do I want to take
the risk I'm up by two three four games
at various times and it's just a way to
bleed the clock out and um I think
strategically it makes sense obviously
for the fans I mean it sucks because I
mean you just see like 10 games in a row
where where basically I just run out
like three or four minutes and we we end
up drawing but
um you know it's it's what it is and
then Magnus try to get a little bit
creative and I was I mean I wasn't able
to punish him but it was still the onus
was still on him because he was down
after the five plus one so
um I mean it just it was wild but I
think I did just about everything right
other than maybe there were two games on
three plus one the game which I should
have won right before the break where I
sacked on F7 and it was the next game
that I lost or was the game before there
was one of these games where he played
this A3 and I took on e4 the pawn as
though I thought it was a qgd Lasker and
then it was in Alaska I mean it was a
little bit different and Magnus played
great and I lost that game it was two
games and three plus one I think if I
had kind of not messed up those teams
maybe I could have won uh more cleanly
but you know it's Magnus he's going to
create chances no matter what you do so
it was uh I was just it was wild but at
the end of the day I I won so I'm
obviously very happy
uh hikar I have a more general question
about your approach and your record
against Magnus when you first started
playing him you were writing a pretty
bad streak and then right around covet
you really turned things around you
started beating him really consistently
in those rapid tournaments and now of
course an SCC victory was there
something specific that changed in your
approach against Magnus or would you say
you know it was more coincidental did
you do something consciously to alter
your attitude when you're playing him
no you know I don't think I I changed
anything in terms of my Approach
necessarily but but one thing kind of
happened at that time which is I kind of
became a streamer and I basically
stopped playing chess and I think that
shifted my whole mindset to where it
doesn't matter you know I don't have
these thoughts anymore where like okay
if I if I beat Magnus fine if I lose the
mag it's fine like it doesn't really
change anything in my life at this point
I think the fact that I don't have to
worry about the pressure there isn't the
stress there of like oh my God if I lose
to Madness it's the end of the world
um that that helps a lot because I think
for a lot of players who are
professionals certainly when they play
against Magnus anytime you lose everyone
obviously is going to be like haha you
lost it kind of Madness you all suck um
that's you know pretty standard doesn't
matter whether it's me it doesn't matter
whether it's Fabiano whoever it is
um but you know I think for me the fact
that it's not the main focus the fact
that I can sort of just relax and you
know if I lose these matches or I lose
these games it doesn't change anything
um has made me play better and I would
just say that I'm just I'm very very
proud of my performances
um the Grand Prix and the candidates I
mean even this it's all all kind of
gravy if if covet had stopped and I
played terribly lost 30 40 points in
classical and gone to 2700 it still
would have been a great career but have
all these events um where I've where
I've been playing so well uh it's it's
it means a lot so I'm very happy
yeah you the other day you sounded and
told us that you were exhausted sounds
like you might be rejuvenated so do you
feel like this fires you up for the
upcoming World rapid and Blitz
no I mean I I think the thing is I'm
playing Magnus I mean if you can't get
excited by playing Magnus then why are
you even playing shots I mean he's the
best player in the world he's a world
champion is if you can't if you can't be
excited then like there's something
wrong with you so uh I mean I I think
right now at least it's just adrenaline
just kind of like the you know just
having having won the match certainly it
feels amazing
um but yeah I think going to the world
often Blitz obviously you know I'll
probably play Magnus again and we'll see
how it goes uh he always has been
someone who comes back from defeats very
strongly so uh it's uh it's gonna be
exciting looking forward to it
uh before we let you go ecar we got a
couple of feature chat questions I'm
gonna package two of them in one the
easy one is question for Hikaru asks
Sheba what's the Mystic drink you're
using and then the second question is
how did you avoid tilt question from
Silva 1988 when Magnus managed to tie it
up in the bullet does that have to do
what you mentioned about putting less
pressure on yourself overall
yeah so in terms of the first question I
mean I was drinking the classic Dunkin
iced coffee uh that's what I drank for
this five plus one portion then on the
break the Keurig machine stopped working
so I had to make my instant coffee
um for the three plus one so so that's
what I was drinking I had a little bit
of Kombucha as well
um that's what I was doing in terms of
drinks
um and yeah as far as tilt I think the
main well the thing is it's very hard
because I think I was up by one and then
I lost this horrible game in the
marshaller Magnus played this bishop G6
stuff and I was completely winning up 30
seconds and then I completely messed it
up and um and then the match was even I
think the main thing for me and this is
not even so much about today but just in
general is sort of I have this ability
now to where I don't care I'm just able
to get over it and you just move on to
the next game and keep going in the past
I would have folded like you know like a
cheap suit there I would have probably
lost the next three or four games lost
the match and I'm gonna be saying okay
well Magnus like you know Hikaru he
chokes again Magnus in his head all the
time all this nonsense so
um at any rate I think it's mainly just
you know when I look at the performance
I've had in all the tournaments share
after after critical loss like I looked
at the Grand Prix I lost LaVon in the
first game third Grand Prix I came back
and then I beat him in the fifth game
and I won when the last game as well um
you look at the candidates I lost fobby
in round one then I'd be two more around
two I lost with somebody later and then
I beat
um I beat Fabiano I think so I've just
been able to bounce back because I think
it's just there's no pressure it's very
easy when you have no pressure in chess
there's there's you know if I do badly I
do badly I'm still a streamer who cares
I do well that's great too but it
doesn't doesn't matter
well that makes perfect sense a car and
you have stated that before in a related
question from uh Carey chess is do you
feel a greater sense of confidence
against Magnus now than ever before
I mean I I don't I don't think it well
okay I'll tell you guys a story so this
is one of the things I've seen about
before the match now some years back Mr
Danny wrench uh the chief chess officer
over at chess.com he said that he said
that according to chess.com stats
apparently when I play Blitz
um I'm more accurate the Magnus except
when I play magnets and I play like a
complete clownfish so
um you know that was in my mind that
basically if I tried it if I'm able to
just keep it together and not lose my
mind good things can happen
um but in in general I think it's it's
it's really just that I try to play good
chess and I think everybody else is
under pressure and I have nothing to
lose and that makes a world of
difference you know for Magnus for
example uh I mean there's definitely
pressure he has an incredible score
against Me In classical chess I mean
over the years just in every format
frankly
um so the pressure's on him I mean
there's no pressure on me if I lose I
lose big deal but I know I know it's
like very sort of psychological and
stuff that a lot of people probably
won't understand but certainly when when
you don't have to worry about the
results it changes a lot and I don't
think that I can I can state that enough
I think actually to use another example
I'll look at Fabiano you start doing
this podcast doing some other stuff he
goes plays the US Championship wins it
and so there might be something to be
said that when you're not like
completely hardened and that's all
you're doing that things uh can become
better
hey Cara based on what you just said I
have a follow-up question do you believe
that if you didn't know who your
opponent was like if people didn't know
Max was the opponent that they would
play better against him based on oh
absolutely I mean absolutely that's that
that's without a doubt that's true but
you know the thing is it you know chess
is obviously a mental game or a mental
sport versus say a physical sport but I
use this analogy very often times and
it's like if you look at say tennis for
example this is a sport that I played um
or I took lessons for many years if you
look at tennis is there any actual
difference between the best players the
number 100 in the world no I mean they
can all hit the same shot so what is it
that really makes those top couple of
guys really good A lot of it is just
like the mental aspect knowing sort of
what what to do in those critical
moments and the same thing is true in
chess like I don't I don't think you can
say that anybody in the top 10 can't
can't beat mags on a good day but the
fact that you're playing maggots the
world champion he has that um you know
everyone knows how good he is at
defending playing end games openings I
mean just everything you know put it
simply um it just sees just astounding
so I think certainly everybody would do
better if they didn't know they were
playing Magnus
well speaking of Madness I got one final
question for you and I don't even really
have to ask it I can just say one move
Bishop C7 your thoughts on that blunder
and how infrequently uh do you see
something like that for Magnus how
shocked were you to see that move
um I mean I I was definitely surprised
it seemed like Magnus is definitely out
of sorts or maybe he just wasn't wasn't
there I think for me the moment that I
knew that I was gonna have chances was
probably the second game when I played
the king's Indian and Magnus did not put
me away in that game he was up a pawn it
was a very typical Magnus kind of
position with a great night on F5 and in
the time scramble he was very shaky and
the game ended and drawn I think from
that time on I I felt good about my
chances because it was just very
uncharacteristic
um for Magnus to not not be precise
there so
oh that was one that was when I sensed
that something might happen but of
course uh Magnus kept fighting to the
end and you know a lot of credit to him
because there were a couple times when
he he also could have just Fallen apart
but he kept it together and um yeah I
think all the fans enjoyed it and um I
guess that's a fifth year in a row that
I've wanted uh which is nice
definitely nice to car and I just have
one last question uh you just use the
word sensing things it seemed to me like
you were looking at probably off screen
at Magnus on camera were you looking for
his reactions throughout the match did
that sort of help you find your Rhythm
and was that something valuable to you
well I actually think that Magnus and I
are the only two people who take
advantage of that you put the zoom up in
the like the right hand corner you just
periodically look at critical moments I
know Magnus has definitely done that
when we've played before and yeah I mean
I was looking to see what his reactions
were um there are a couple times that he
also like he said a few things as well
obviously Norwegian so I have no idea
what what they were but
um yeah I mean it just seemed like
Magnus was a little bit just a little
bit off I mean it just it it felt like
he was off and definitely I'm always
looking at the cams to see what the
reactions are um from the players
because again when you're playing at
home versus in person it's a lot easier
to be your true self and let the emotion
show like it's very easy to forget that
something's happening like you know I've
slammed a mouse when I lost to Shanklin
I think Magnus is like I think he's done
something similar when he's lost in the
Melt water melt water tour so I I
definitely definitely think that it's
something that more people should be
taking advantage of it's just
periodically in those critical moments
just looking up at that Zoom call to see
the uh to see see what the reactions are
well hey Carl when can we expect a
celebration stream is it after we let
you go
um I mean I'm I'm pretty beat but I'll
definitely be streaming tomorrow and
Tuesday all the all the usual Jazz
um but yeah I mean it's nice to win but
it's all honestly just gravy at this
point it doesn't change anything in my
life so I just got back to doing what
I'm doing and um that's yeah that's what
it is
well it must be nice cruising to a fifth
straight speed chess champion title
Hikaru Nakamura huge congratulations
what an epic final that was and we'll
definitely be seeing you soon
thank you so much you guys have a great
one
and you heard it from the man himself
the champion Hikaru Nakamura wins a
fifth straight speed Chess Championship
it is amazing he defeated Magnus Carlson
in the final and well speaking of Magnus
Carlson before we wrap up the 2022 SEC
we are told that Magnus would like to
share his thoughts on today's match so
we're gonna take a quick break and when
we come back we'll hear from Magnus his
thoughts on an amazing day and wrap up
the SEC see you soon everybody
use gifts not GIFs from the biggest
chest stars on all of your favorite
platforms just search chess.com and your
favorite chest star on Discord Twitter
WhatsApp and more to find hundreds of
gifts from chess.com's biggest
broadcasts and events pokemane Ludwig
moist critical xqc and even me Danny try
it today
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
it's always an honor to be joined by the
world's number one rated player Magnus
Carlsen Magnus sorry that today's match
didn't go your way and I guess in your
own words can you describe what you felt
what went wrong especially in the early
going of the match
well I mean first of all sorry for
wasting people's time in the sense that
the event could have sort of have been
over with the interview with uh after
the interview with uh Hikaru but um I I
mean I just thought it was such a
fascinating match that I wanted to to
share some of um some of my thoughts
well Magnus will definitely give you the
floor and you can take this in whatever
Direction you want all sort of uh prod
You by asking at which point in the
match did you recognize that you were
sort of off form was it something you
recognized before the match began or
during the five minute portion
yeah I mean before the match I was uh I
was feeling a little
[Music]
sort of a little bit of an energy
deficit but uh I thought I was still I
was still fine and then
um the first couple of games were sort
of sort of okay I felt and then yeah the
third game was just a
um
uh you know that was a bit of a meltdown
it was just I was out playing him a
little bit I got a better ending there
with um
uh the bishop against uh bishop and
Knight against two knights and I was
sort of building in the center and then
he set up this Fortress I tried to
um try to break it and all of a sudden
like he was playing for a win and
uh I was just that boosted by by that
and I I lost some time in a position
that was still terrible so that was
really um
that was really when it all sort of uh
started and I mean frankly for the next
uh for the rest of the five minutes I've
portion I felt that he played fantastic
chess
um he was just way better than me in in
every
in every aspect and
[Music]
um
at that point I was just looking forward
to somewhat faster time controls because
I felt that um he was doing a lot better
than I was when we could when we both
had a lot of time to to to think uh like
he was strategizing better
um
in the middle game and
generally
um
seeing things better so I thought and
so I thought like when we have less time
there will be less time for him to to
think and also force me to play a bit
faster so that's
um
so that's fine uh also when when I got
my first win I sort of
um calmed down a little bit I think
um
to be fair like
um a couple games later I mean I put my
Bishop on pre uh overlooking it
backwards night mode which is
not uh not impressive to say the least
um
but I felt at that point that he was um
that he was vulnerable and I was already
like really cherishing the challenge of
making it making it all the way back and
I I even with even with that game I felt
that I had had a chance uh so the rest
of the match was just
really really enjoyable
um
I didn't didn't make it in the end of
course I wish I had But like after after
the start I had I'm just happy that it
was it was
um competitive uh and
um
yeah I was was it was a joy to
um to participate in uh and um I mean we
both obviously
blundered a bunch
um in the um
three plus one and and um
and and the bullet
um and we also both did
make some very very good moves both um
in time pressure and otherwise but um I
felt that at that point it was just a
really really fun uh struggle and um
I could I really could have gone either
way
um
in in the um the the game that happened
after uh I tied the match I was white I
was sort of pressing a little bit there
um
and then then I blended upon we got into
drone Rook ending and somehow there I
exchanged the Pawns in the wrong way so
I lost the pawn and after that yeah I
was really really tough uh again
um the last game I was looking at the
clock understood what was going to
to happen but um yeah at that point
there was nothing I could do but um yeah
generally
um
his uh he's amazing at this
uh at this format uh I remember
his match against feducev two years ago
he's five plus
uh one segment there I felt that that's
pretty much as well as it possible to
play
um
in that particular time control and I
did feel today that he came sort of uh
at least very close to to that level so
you know had stuff for for that that was
um
um not not fun to to face
um in that particular segment but it was
um it was amazing to see
Magnus it sounds like you love a good
challenge and everybody remembers or has
heard the stories of you and ikaru
duking it out in a dark hotel room
playing a lot of Blitz now you're
playing Blitz in front of over 150 000
fans can you explain what has changed in
ikaru over the last few years because of
course in classical chess you have most
people's number but you you know
especially at his what have you seen the
growth in a car's chess over the last
couple years
yeah
I mean obviously he he's getting
practice all the time uh from from his
streaming that I think helps I also
think that
um his uh his attitude has become a
little bit better in the sense that he
doesn't doesn't care as much anymore I
know that's a meme but I think it's
genuinely helping him and he's always
had
he's always had Talent uh I think the um
the start of the pandemic the results he
had there in the uh in the in the
Champions chess tour also helped his
confidence quite a bit
um then I mean we played an epic match
then as well
um seven seven matches that I finally
won on Armageddon in the last game could
have gone could have gone either way uh
now we've sort of played two of them and
and
we won one each so I feel like that's
probably probably fair enough but uh
yeah he's he's just uh he's just a beast
at this format like I generally still
think that I'm a little bit better uh
but
um I didn't prove it didn't prove it
today and um he certainly has as close
as it uh
as uh well I mean basically anyone's
ever ever been so it's um it's it's a
great challenge
Magnus we got quite a few feature chat
questions to get to but first I have
another more general question uh how how
would you compare uh over the board
versus online Blitz do you have a clear
preference and uh can we expect you to
play online Blitz and bullet even let's
say into your 50s and 60s how strong is
your addiction to online Blitz
uh
no this is one one of the things that
sort of
um
that sort of hit me uh
I think it hit me like one of the days
when I played the Mrs darje Invitational
before this it was like
I absolutely love I absolutely love
playing Blitz like and I I just had this
I mean I've always loved it but I just
I guess I started
like appreciating it more and more and I
I just had had these moments where I was
thinking that
I don't feel like it's an addiction in
the sense that it it just
I feel you know some of the
matches where you've been you play for a
long time
that can be put down to addiction uh but
I'm not sure it does a lot of a lot of
harm
uh so for me it's just
improving quality of life to to have
this to have this passion so yeah I
agree
yeah I absolutely I absolutely love it I
I have to say and uh that's sort of
why this struggle was uh
was uh was so much fun because I mean
I've
frankly I mean I had a score to settle
in this
tournament so I've been like a little
jittery at at times uh but when I got
here to the final I thought
then uh at least the most important
important part soda has been has been
done so uh I have to say like I couldn't
believe how much I enjoyed uh
the match today and um the addiction
whether it lasts into into the 50s or
60s
uh be that the um
uh decade or my age who knows but uh no
I absolutely love it
well Magnus we had about 150 000
concurrent viewers watching for you know
four to five hours here what do you
think that says about the growing
popularity of speed chess and and what
you see for its future
it's amazing to see
um I guess a lot of people
um who just finished watching watching
the the World Cup final
and didn't want to leave the couch quite
yet so uh thank you all for for sticking
with us
um I mean some of them are probably
probably still watching so
um it's yeah it's it's it's good to uh
to see obviously this is um
I think this is this is as good as it
gets like
uh speeches
marches between her car and I be that
Blitz or uh Rapid or even bullet I think
that's a good as good a show as it as it
gets in in chess
um so I'm glad that people appreciate it
as much as as much as I do
well we got an interesting feature chat
question here Magnus from Zita koalo uh
could we have your honest take on
hikaru's clock running strategy do you
feel like it's just totally part of the
match or was a little part of you irked
no it's fine
it's it's completely fine
um I um I was impressed by um his
constant awareness of of those matters
um there was this one game in the 3-1
where I played the modern and he's
actually done this against me before in
the um it was one of the years in Norway
chess in the uh in the qualifier there
where he I think he was half a point
ahead of me for the last round I played
the pits and
um he played the very same line where
basically black has to go for the
Perpetual not to not to be worse um and
in that game I actually went for for
something else
um which is really too abusive white
nose what he's doing
um that game was was drawn
as well but I figured he'd um he'd
learned a line so I could really do that
uh and
um I didn't like realize the
implications immediately I was thinking
that
um
basically um
[Music]
that you know we're going to have a draw
and then of course
at some point yeah I realized that
he's gonna take the three minutes and um
yeah I just gotta say
um it's a props to him for for
recognizing that and it's absolutely
absolutely fair game I have to say
though if it's one if it if there's one
thing
um
there are that I regret a little bit in
this match it's it's the uh sort of a
little bit of compromising openings I
played at at various points as um as
black because generally this a for uh
this A3 analysis was really working well
for me uh I was getting playable
positions and generally out playing him
as white at some point uh so well first
of all maybe should have started that
earlier rather than
um the Catalan but also a couple of the
losses that I had with uh black uh
playing combative openings were maybe on
unnecessary I think that there were
enough White games for me to
um
to just say that you can have all the
draws that you that you want this white
you can even even run some clock uh I
have I have enough time I'm going to to
win most most of the white games if if I
can have my
gonna have my way there so
um no uh but basically the answer to the
question is I'm
I understand that
um I understand the um the the the
format and uh it doesn't bother me
doesn't bother me one bit
well Magnus we have another uh featured
chat question for you uh you tied the
match up after being down by Four Points
so sir laser asks do you feel that you
had the momentum when you tied things up
yeah
um it's fun when you have these um Zoom
chats where you can where your opponent
is Mike miked up so I can actually hear
things that people
uh sitting at home kind of cannot hear
and he can he can hear it when I'm
mothering to to myself as well so I
think I think when
when I won the third game in in a row
and tied the match he was shouting to
himself like I think maybe I heard the
slaps maybe he was like slapping his
face and saying wake up wake up I
thought that was that was funny it was
it was a clear clear sign of course that
I had the the momentum and I as I
mentioned earlier
um
that game really was saying
it was a bit of a back breaker for for
me because
um I I was I was applying pressure and
if I hadn't given him this chance to go
Pawn hunting I think I could have put a
lot of pressure in on in him in that
game and uh and probably won the match
one thing I should say though that in
general
um there's there's been this sort of
it's always been this discourse that um
uh hikar is um is much better at
uh that bullet than everybody
um I think at least at one one uh oh I I
think it doesn't practice really one
zero I don't either these days but so I
don't know he's he's level there uh but
I think in one one
um I was not the least bit worried about
that I was still thinking at the end of
three like if I'm within a couple of
games I thought like I'm a slight
favorite for
um for bullets so I should be I should
be uh it should be fine so I feel like
sort of the notion that he's
um
that he's a lot better than everybody at
one one is um is a bit outdated at best
Magnus uh we have a feature chat
question from honey bear who asks what
your mindset was going to the term and
I'll just tack on uh a question about
you mentioning settling scores uh could
you expand on that a little bit and on a
broader scale Magnus does it motivate
you when people uh respond very
reactively when you don't win a
tournament which is of course very rare
does it motivate you when people start
talking about uh you know magnus's
domination is coming to an end all of
that nonsense does that give you even
more motivation to set the record
straight
yes of course I and uh I really I really
wanted to to set the record certain this
tournament there is no doubt about that
so uh that was sort of my my main
motivation for
uh for uh well I mean it's a fun event
but
um so my motivation was set the record
straight to show that I'm
still still the best
um
I remember before
uh
uh before the uh 2020 uh event I was
thinking that
um
like I thought that at the start that
there was a about 20 to 25 chance that I
would lose to a car and then uh probably
uh
five percent or a little bit less that I
would lose to uh to somebody somebody
else and
um I think it was pretty similar this
time uh actually uh and
so these things obviously do happen so
that's why I'm also sitting here like
it's as I said like I think I'm I'm
somewhat better uh
but uh it's close enough that it's it's
uh
that it's you know uh it's an exciting
matchup and that's really all you can
all you can uh all you can hope for um
and uh I think it's really it's really
fitting that as
even though like the quality of the
matches were a bit varying
um that uh both of both ikara and I were
pretty comfortable in our our matches
coming into the final
um
and um so it only makes sense that the
final would be
uh would be a very very tense and very
close
well Magnus we asked Hikaru this
question
um you know he I asked him if he was
looking at the zoom call so uh one part
of that is how often do you look at the
call and is that valuable to see
people's reaction and the second part is
Hikaru said he believes that if you
didn't know that you were playing you if
nobody knew they were playing you that
they might perform better what do you
think about that would people perform
better against you if they didn't know
it was Magnus Carlson against them
yes of course and 10 plus years of
domination is intimidating to face
so it's just it's a simple uh it's as
simple as that and similarly people are
extremely intimidated while facing cars
that there's no there's no doubt that
that's a um
that's a factor like you double triple
checks stuff that you normally normally
wouldn't and you just I think you just
play
um
and play a bit worse and um I think it's
also all also the case that
um I'm not intimidated by him and I
don't think he's really that intimidated
by me anymore and that sort of frees us
up
um both a little bit as for the zoom
call no I
I've sort of spoken about this before
that
I feel like there are a lot of fake
tales coming from my car so I prefer not
to I prefer not to
uh try and try and look for them so I
don't I don't want to watch the call I
watched uh the board but I do do listen
to what's being said of course
oh Magnus final question uh from ipk1
your reaction to France losing and was
your decision to play the French in a
couple of games and homage
to uh unfortunately the losing team
no
um
no it wasn't uh I wasn't getting getting
great positions into French so maybe
that wasn't a great decision but um
um but I mean to be to be honest like I
was rooting for for France but um
uh like having Messi get his uh World
Cup title is so so not a bad outcome so
um the finals was uh very enjoyable to
watch
that's um
as a football fan that's um it was a
good warm-up
well as a chess fan your match
unfortunately got your way but it was
thrilling to watch so Magnus thanks so
much uh for joining us and as it turns
out we will see you soon since you'll be
a featured guest on the state of Chess
which streams this Wednesday at 10 A.M
with Danny wrench so we have some huge
announcements and we look forward to
seeing you then Magnus yeah thank you so
much uh for uh for having me this season
and uh I'm as uh curious as everybody
too
as to what this huge announcement could
possibly be so
um it will be exciting
it certainly will thank you so much
Magnus for joining us you know there's
so many people watching and it's always
a treat to have you on it is thank you
thank you
and that is the conclusion of both our
interview with Magnus Carlson the world
champion and the number one braided
player in the world for over a decade
and well Hikaru Nakamura did take him
down today it was a very close Affair
14f 13 F final score Hikaru LED early
Mega struck back but when all was said
and done hikar Nakamura keeps that lead
Dania it was an epic finale
I'm just mesmerized by this bracket and
it's crazy because the nepo mvl match
almost feels like it happened in a
different Century feels like dinosaurs
still roam the earth and the Model T was
on the streets when mvl defeated Napa
that's bottom right hand side Nakamura
paravian do you even remember that that
match and that's a good thing that's
because these matches they took so much
energy away from the players they felt
like events on their own and this match
that we just saw today the Karan
nakamura's victory over Magnus Carlsen
that felt like an event on its own and
so did Magnus Carlson's interview I just
have to compliment Magnus of course
Hikaru uh giving answers as well and
really offering us a lot of insight that
was awesome Magnus Carlsen deciding to
show up and uh being cheerful being
friendly that's not easy Robert as the
world champion when you lose a match so
just an honor to be a part of the Chess
World as it is today these players take
these matches so so seriously they're at
each other's throats but then they're
able to be courteous and super
professional afterward and I just think
that's awesome yeah and Magnus himself
said that he enjoyed the challenge he
was losing most people when they're down
you can count them out but never Magnus
Carlson he enjoyed the challenge he did
come back to tie the score but Hikaru
Nakamura he was strong as ever he wins
his fifth straight speech as
championship and he wants quite a lot of
money because the prize fund it gives
both a set number of dollars to the
winner and split by percentage so he
wins 33 000 Magnus there with 23 816 so
one point separated them and that was
the difference in their payout
it was indeed it was a nail biter I made
only one prediction this entire day I
refused to predict how the five minute
segment is gonna go all I predicted is
that this match is not going to be
decided until the final seconds takedown
and that is literally what happened to
Hikaru building just enough time in the
final game by a second by a move to milk
the clock down and cement his one point
lead both of these players they gave
this match their all and yes Magnus
Carlson was not in perfect form and yes
he blundered with Bishop C7 uh
uncharacteristically and yes he had some
bad positions out of the opening he
didn't play the way he wanted to play
but he gave it his all Hikaru gave it
his all and we truly live in the Golden
Age of Chess entertainment we certainly
do and it's thanks to players like
Hikaru and Magnus we all love seeing
those two players battle for chess
Supremacy this time it was akaru we'll
see what happens next time but the speed
Chess Championship was so much fun and
thank thanks to all of you watching you
make this so much better for us your
feature chat questions were excellent we
had Magnus Carlson on for an interview
after losing a match that is a special
treat and of course we've got to hear
hikaru's thoughts hearing from the speed
chess champion five championships in a
row for the number one chess streamer on
the planet he's a streamer he's a
superstar and he is the SCC title winner
so
Dania I've had a blast commentating with
you you have any final thoughts about
the SEC before I wrap this up
well I wanted to say something sarcastic
but I'm too emotional it's been an honor
to cover the SEC and in order to do it
with you
um I really feel like I'm not working I
feel like I'd be doing this anyway I'd
be on the edge of my seat anyway I'd be
shouting at the television screen if I
didn't get to commentate so a great
privilege and honor something I never
take for granted and of course just to
Echo my gratitude to the tense in this
case hundreds of thousands of people
taking time out of your busy days to
watch the SEC unfold this really is the
Crown Jewel of the annual chess calendar
this is an event that has gained
Prestige that has gained recognition at
his as it has moved from one year to the
next so I feel like this all went by in
a Flash it's been such a pleasure
covering it and Robert I can't wait for
next year I can't wait for SEC 2023 and
I think neither can Magnuson higaro no
because those two players they have a
long history a rivalry in the making it
is epic and I want to genuinely thank
everyone from the bottom of my heart
this was a special event Magnus and
Hikaru for the championship ikaru comes
out on top but you know just to be able
to cover chess it is always a pleasure
for me and Dania we are very close
friends you know off the camera we do
talk a lot everybody so it's a pleasure
to compensate alongside you I want to
thank the chess.com staff for putting in
all of their hard work the producers who
do everything behind the scenes they may
not get the recognition but we certainly
appreciate them and of course to you all
for making this so much more fun for us
and last but sir not at least the 16
players who took part in this year's
speed test Championship on behalf of
chess.com I'm Grandmaster Robert Hess
that's remastered down there ditsky
we'll see you next time
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]